FOR BEING HERE THIS IS THE
SELECT COMMITTEE ON MENTAL
HEALTH OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE AND THIS IS OUR FIRST
SELECT COMMITTEE MEETING OF THE
YEAR AND I LIKE TO WELCOME- THE
PANELISTS WHO HAVE WORKED HARD
TO PREPARE FOR THIS HEARING
AND- THANK YOU FOR
PARTICIPATING WITH US. NOW WE
KNOW THAT CALIFORNIA'S DOES A
LOT TO DO TO IMPROVE ACCESS AND
TREATMENT FOR MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES. THINK ALL OF US ARE
FEELING OPTIMISTIC BECAUSE THE
GOVERNOR GOVERNOR NEWSOME DID A
REALLY GOOD JOB EXPRESSING A
SERIOUS- COMMITMENT TO DOING
SOMETHING ABOUT BRAIN HEALTH HE
MADE A VERY SERIOUS STATEMENT
LAST WEEK. DURING HIS STATE OF
THE STATE ADDRESS. ANY
RECOGNIZE THAT YOU CAN'T
SEPARATE FROM PHYSICAL HEALTH.
AND HE'S MAKING INVESTMENTS IN
OVERHAULING INTEGRATING OUR
SYSTEMS IN THE PAST ARE
HEARINGS A FOCUS ON THE GAPS
AND PROBLEMS IN THE SYSTEM BUT
WE ARE TAKING A INTO A LITTLE
DIFFERENT TURN IN TODAY'S
HEARING HEARING IS NOT ONLY
FOCUS ON THE CHALLENGE BUT WHAT
ARE THE SOLUTIONS. TO SOME OF
THE CHALLENGES THAT WE FACE AND
WE HOPE IT WILL INSPIRE YOU TO
EXPAND YOUR PARTNERSHIPS AND
COME UP WITH INNOVATIVE
PATHWAYS TO ADDRESS GAPS IN OUR
SERVICES THERE IS WILL FOCUS ON
YOUTH AND FAMILY MENTAL HEALTH
AND- WE'RE GONNA- HERE HAVE
PLAYED TIMES FOR COMMENTS FROM
THE PUBLIC. AT THE END OF THE
HEARING. AND WE WANT TO THANK
YOU ALL WE'RE GOING TO START
I'D LIKE TO INVITE DOCTOR JOHN
CONLEY- FROM THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCIES. DEPUTY SECRETARY OF
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND HE'S
GOING TO FOCUS ON DISCUSSING-
TRENDS IN OUR COMMUNITY AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH NEEDS AND
WELCOME AND HOW LONG HAVE YOU-HAD THE JOB AT ALL- JUST A
LITTLE. FIVE WELL THAT'S GREAT
I'M GLAD TO HAVE YOU HERE FOR
THE FIRST TIME IN THE
CALIFORNIA SENATE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON MENTAL HEALTH.
THANK YOU GLAD TO BE HERE. CAN
WELCOME CENTER MONNING AND YOU
MAY PROCEED. THANK YOU THANK
YOU TO THE CHAIR AND TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR FIRST OF ALL YOUR
ATTENTION TO THE VITAL ISSUE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND FOR
INVITING ME TO TESTIFY TODAY
CERTAINLY THE GOVERNOR AND THE
SECRETARY SHARE BOTH THE POLICY
COMMITMENT IN A PERSONAL
COMMITMENT TO THE ISSUES- AND
THAT COMMITMENT WAS EVIDENCE
BOTH IN THE GOVERNOR'S. BUDGET
PROPOSAL AS WELL AS THE STATE
OF THE STATE ADDRESS THAT BUT
YOU MENTIONED LAST WEEK- IT
PROBABLY GOES WITHOUT SAYING
FOR MANY IN THE ROOM BUT I
THINK IT BEARS REPEATING THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH IS CENTRAL TO
LIVING A HAPPY. HEALTHY AND
FULFILLING LIFE AND WITH EACH
PASSING YEAR. COURAGE THAT WE
CONTINUE TO MAKE PROGRESS IN
UNDERSTANDING THIS TRUTH. AND
IN BUILDING SYSTEMS OF CARE
THAT RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE
OF TREATMENT AND RECOVERY. AND
BUILDING SUPPORT OF COMMUNITIES
THAT BOTH PREVENT AND FIGHT
STIGMA SURROUNDING MENTAL
HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDERS. STILL WE HAVE A
DISTANCE TO GO TO ENSURE THAT
ALL HAVE ACCESS TO HIGH QUALITY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CARE WHEN
THEY NEED. MOREOVER WE HAVE
MUCH WORK AHEAD TO REALIZE THE
VISION. OF ALL CALIFORNIANS
WITH MENTAL HEALTH AND
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS.
RECEIVING THE SUPPORT EMBRACE
OF THEIR COMMUNITIES WITHOUT
FEAR OF MARGINALIZATION A
CRITICAL FACTOR IN ACHIEVING
SUSTAINING AND CELEBRATING
RECOVERY. IN FACT CALIFORNIA'S
NOW GRAPPLING WITH A BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH CRISIS APPROXIMATELY TEN
MILLION CALIFORNIANS SUFFER
FROM BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DISORDERS WHICH INCLUDE BOTH
MENTAL ILLNESS AND SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDERS. PEOPLE WITH
SERIOUS MENTAL ILLNESS OR-
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS OR S.
U. D. DIE EARLIER AND ARE MUCH
MORE LIKELY TO BE INCARCERATED
OR HOMELESS THAN PEOPLE WITHOUT
THESE CONDITIONS. MOREOVER
PEOPLE WITH A SEMI AN S. U. D.
AND YOUTH WITH A SERIOUS
EMOTIONAL DISORDER. ARE AT
GREATER RISK OF SUICIDE WHICH
IS INCREASED MARKEDLY IN RECENT
YEARS IN FACT HOSPITALIZATION
FOR MENTAL HEALTH CONCERNS
INCREASED 50% AMONG
CALIFORNIA'S YOUTH BETWEEN TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN AND TWO THOUSAND
AND FIFTEEN- CLEARLY THE
SITUATION IS URGENT. AND
ALARMING. A FURTHER TOO MANY
PEOPLE FEEL THAT THEY CANNOT
RECEIVE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES WHEN THEY NEED THEM.
AND WHEN PEOPLE RECEIVE CARE
THEY TOO OFTEN FIND IT
INADEQUATE. FRAGMENTED AND
DIFFICULT TO NAVIGATE. AND
UNCOORDINATED WITH OUR OTHER
HEALTH CARE AND SOCIAL
SERVICES. GIVEN THIS REALITY
THE MAJOR QUESTION BEFORE US IS
HOW TO CHANGE THIS EXPERIENCE
FOR CALIFORNIANS. AND TO ME THE
CONSIDERABLE NEED THAT WE
CONTINUE TO SEE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES AND OUR FAMILIES.
ALL OFFER A FEW SUGGESTIONS
TODAY AREAS OF FOCUS THAT WOULD
HELP US CREATE A DIFFERENT
REALITY. AND OFFER HOPE IN A
GREATER CHANCE OF RECOVERY TO
CALIFORNIANS WITH MENTAL HEALTH
AND SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS.
FIRST ONE AREA OF FOCUS IS
PROVIDING TIMELY ACCESS TO
SERVICES. WELCOME CENTER- TO
THE FOR- ATTENTION TO THE FRONT
DOOR- FOR BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
CARE SHOULD BE ACCESSIBLE AN
APPARENT TO THOSE WHO NEED
SERVICES THAT INCLUDES HEALTH
PLANS. INCLUDING COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PLANS AS WELL
AS COMMERCIAL HEALTH PLANS AND
THEIR NETWORKS OF SERVICE
PROVIDERS- WHICH SHOULD OFFER
CENTRALIZED HUMAN CENTERED
SYSTEMS FOR SWIFTLY LINKING
PEOPLE FROM THE COMMUNITY TO BE
NEEDED BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CARE
IN EACH REGION OR COUNTY.
MOREOVER THE CONSTELLATION OF
HEALTH AND SOCIAL SERVICE
PROVIDERS AND THE BROADER
COMMUNITY SHOULD PROVIDE AS
MANY TOUCH POINTS AS POSSIBLE
WITH THE ABILITY TO MAKE
CONNECTIONS TO BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH CARE. OUR COMMUNITY
RESOURCES THAT INCLUDES
EDUCATION HOUSING PUBLIC SAFETY
AND OTHER SHOULD HAVE AN
UNDERSTANDING AND A CONSCIOUS
CONNECTION TO THE FRONT DOOR OF
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CARE THROUGH
LOCAL HEALTH COVERAGE OPTIONS
AND COMMUNITY PROVIDERS WHICH
ARE INDISPENSABLE IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES AND NEIGHBORHOODS.
THE SCHOOL ALSO REQUIRES MUCH
MORE MEANINGFUL INTEGRATION OF
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CARE WITH A
BROADER HEALTHCARE SYSTEM. WE
SHOULD NOT PLACE TREMENDOUS
ONUS OF NAVIGATING AND
COORDINATING CARE ON VULNERABLE
CONSUMERS WHEN THEY'RE IN TIMES
OF CRISIS AND ILLNESS-
EXPERIENCING MANY CHALLENGES
THAT REQUIRE US TO REACH OUT TO
THEM RATHER THAN THE CONVERSE.
IF WE STRIVE TO ESTABLISH
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH- IN BEHAVIOR
HEALTH CARE IS A VITAL
ACCESSIBLE HUMAN CENTERED
RESOURCE WE MUST INTEGRATE A
MORE BROADLY WITH WITH MODELS
OF CARE THAT SORT OF THE WHOLE
PERSON NOT JUST PART OF THEIR
NEEDS. WE NEED PROVIDER
NETWORKS TO CREATE TEAMS OF
PRIMARY CARE PROVIDERS CASE
MANAGER SOCIAL WORKERS AND
PSYCHIATRISTS TO PROVIDE A
WHOLE PERSON APPROACH TO CARE.
MEANINGFUL INTEGRATION OF
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CARE WILL
REQUIRE DEEPER COORDINATION
ACROSS DIFFERENT SYSTEMS THAT
MAY NOT HAVE EXPERIENCE
HISTORICALLY WORKING TOGETHER
THAT INCLUDE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
CITIES. COUNTIES HOUSING
AUTHORITIES JUVENILE JUSTICE
CHILD WELFARE AND OTHER SYSTEMS
THAT SERVE MANY OF THE FOLKS
THAT WERE ALL SERVING IN COMMON
ACROSS DIFFERENT LEVELS OF
GOVERNMENT AND IN DIFFERENT-
SERVICE DELIVERY SYSTEMS.
MISALIGNMENT SHOULD INCLUDE AN
INTENTIONAL FOCUS ON SERVING
THOSE WHO ARE MOST VULNERABLE.
BECAUSE OF THEIR SPECIFIC NEEDS
AND EXPERIENCES AND PRIORITIZE
INNOVATIVE COMMUNITY BASED
SERVICE MODELS THAT MEET PEOPLE
WHERE THEY LIVE WORK AND PLAY.
AS WELL AS WORSHIP. MOREOVER WE
MUST DESIGN THESE CROSS SYSTEM
COLLABORATIONS WITH THE
INTENTION OF MAXIMIZING FEDERAL
FUNDING AND STRATEGICALLY USING
OUR STATE AND LOCAL DOLLARS TO
MAXIMIZE SERVICE CAPACITY. HOW
DO WE DO THAT A FUSE A FEW
AREAS OF FOCUS FIRST WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT IS AN IMPORTANT AN
INDISPENSIBLE WAY OF BUILDING
OUR CAPACITY IT'S A MAJOR
ONGOING AREA OF FOCUS FOR
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CARE SYSTEMS.
AND WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT THAT
CALIFORNIA HAS THE CAPACITY TO
SERVE RESIDENTS IN ALL AREAS OF
THE STATE OF THE STATE WITH
CULTURALLY AND LINGUISTICALLY
SPECIFIC PROGRAMMING THAT
REPRESENTS OUR COMMUNITIES.
CALIFORNIA'S INCREDIBLY DIVERSE
AND LARGE AND A WORK FORCE THAT
INCLUDES PEOPLE FROM THEIR
COMMUNITIES AND WITH LIVED
EXPERIENCE WITH MENTAL HEALTH
AND SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS. IS
A AN IMPORTANT AND CIVIL
STRATEGY TO PROVIDING GREATER
ACCESS TO SERVICES IT ALSO
ENABLES PEOPLE TO FEEL SAFE AND
ENSURE THAT ENVIRONMENTS ARE
THERAPEUTIC. FURTHER THE
EXPANSION OF TELEHEALTH
PRESENTS A COMPLEMENTARY
STRATEGY TO EXPAND THE REACH OF
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SPECIALISTS.
IS WHERE THERE ISN'T A LOT OF
CLINICAL CAPACITY- FOR
CLINICIANS OF THAT TYPE. IF YOU
REALLY IN RURAL AREAS AND FOR
GROUPS AND COMMUNITIES WITH
SPECIFIC VULNERABILITIES ARE
NEEDS. TELEHEALTH ALSO PROVIDES
A KEY MEANS OF INTEGRATING
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CARE WITH
PRIMARY AND OTHER SPECIALTY
CARE BUILDING VIRTUAL TEAMS
THROUGH CASE CONFERENCING AND
ENHANCED INFORMATION SHARING.
THE STEPS ARE DESCRIBED WILL
HELP US PROVIDE GREATER STE-
ACCESS TO SERVICES OF COURSE
THE DETAILS ARE COMPLEX AND
IMPORTANT BUT WE MUST ALSO GAIN
A STRONGER UNDERSTANDING OF THE
TYPES OF CARE THAT WORK BEST
ACROSS OUR STATE HEALTH PLANS
AND SERVICE PROVIDERS. SHOULD
MOVE TOWARD MORE STANDARDIZED
METRICS TO ENSURE OUR
UNDERSTANDING OF HOW WELL OUR
SYSTEMS ARE SERVING
CALIFORNIANS. THROUGH ENHANCED
DATA COLLECTION INCONSISTENT
MEASUREMENT WE CAN BE MORE
RESPONSIVE TO COMMUNITY NEED BY
EXPANDING INTERVENTIONS THAT
WORK AND- THE MOST URGENT GAPS
IN SERVICE. FOR EXAMPLE WE'VE
LEARNED THAT EARLY INTERVENTION
AND ONGOING SUPPORT PROVIDE
CONSIDERABLE PROMISE AND HOPE
FOR YOUTH AND YOUNG ADULTS
EXPERIENCING A MERGING MENTAL
ILLNESS. COORDINATED SPECIALTY
CARE IS A TIMELY EVIDENCE BASED
INTERVENTION FOR YOUTH AND
YOUNG ADULTS AFTER THE
EXPERIENCE THE FIRST EPISODE OF
PSYCHOSIS AND WE KNOW THAT IT
GREATLY IMPROVES. THEIR LONG
TERM WELL BEING AND OUTCOMES
THE CURRENT YEAR BUDGET
INCLUDES TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS
FOR THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY
COMMISSION. TO SUPPORT THE
DEVELOPMENT OF INNOVATIVE
PROGRAMS THAT OFFER THESE
SERVICES TO OUR YOUNG PEOPLE.
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO THE
EXPANSION OF THE SERVICES
ACROSS THE STATE. ENHANCE DATA
COLLECTION ABOUT THE IMPACT OF
THESE SERVICES WILL ENABLE
CALIFORNIA TO EXPAND THEIR USE
IN OTHER EFFECTIVE PRACTICES.
TO IMPROVE POPULATION HEALTH.
AND POPULATION HEALTH LEADS ME
TO MIKE INCLUDING- POINTS WHICH
IS THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH IS A
PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUE JUST LIKE
NUTRITION AND EXERCISE.
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH IS A CENTRAL
PLANK OF HUMAN WELL BEING. WE
MUST CONTINUALLY ASSESS TRENDS
IN IN NEED RELATED TO
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH FROM A
POPULATION HEALTH PERSPECTIVE.
AND THE POTENTIAL DRIVERS OF
THOSE DYNAMICS DESERVE
EXAMINATION. TO INFORM AND
SHARP IN OUR PREVENTION AND
TREATMENT STRATEGIES. IMPROVING
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH IS A
COMMUNITY WIDE EFFORT WHICH
WOULD BENEFIT FROM ALL OF THE
STRATEGIES THAT I MENTIONED
TODAY AND OTHERS. AND IT IS
ESSENTIAL TO REALIZING THE
VISION OF A HEALTHY CALIFORNIA
FOR ALL. THANK YOU. UNLIKE DOWN
SOME ROOM JUST. TO HAVE SOME
DIALOGUE TRUCK. THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT OF RELATIONSHIP ON
MENTAL HEALTH- INVOLVES- CAL A
NAME WHICH IS YOUR MEDICARE ALL
AGREEMENT AND THERE'S BLOCK
RANCH THE- RECEIPT. FOR
SERVICES TO BOOST TREATMENT AND
MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT. OF
WHAT DO YOU PLAN ON DOING IN
TERMS OF THOSE RELATIONSHIPS TO
BETTER OUR MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM
IN CALIFORNIA CAN YOU GIVE US
KIND OF AN UPDATE ABOUT WHAT IS
HAPPENING WITH THE ACCOUNT NAME
AND SURE WHAT'S GOING ON WITH-
A BLOCK GRANT THE BLOCK GRANTS
OR OTHER. OTHER AREAS THAT WE
NEED TO WORK ON AND THOSE THOSE
TWO AREAS. SURE SO- TO GIVE AN
UPDATE ON THE PROGRESS WITH
CAROLINE IN THE PROPOSAL FOR
THE WAIVER RENEWALS AND BROADER
MEDICAL TRANSFORMATION THAT
PROGRESS IS KIND OF IN THE
THICK OF A STAKEHOLDER
ENGAGEMENT THERE ARE MANY
DIFFERENT. WORK GROUPS THAT ARE
ON GOING TO GET FEEDBACK ABOUT
THE INITIAL PROPOSAL RELEASED A
COUPLE OF MONTHS AGO- THE
PROPOSALS ARE BEING REFINED IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE MEMBERS OF
THOSE WORK GROUPS AND WITHIN
THE NEXT COUPLE OF MONTHS- THAT
FEEDBACK WILL BE INCORPORATED
INTO AN UPDATED ROPOSAL WHICH
WILL BE FORWARDED FOR
SUBMISSION TO. THE FEDERAL
CENTERS FOR MEDICARE AND
MEDICAID SERVICES- I THINK THE
PROGRESS HAS BEEN GOOD AND
FRUITFUL THE ENGAGEMENT HAS
BEEN HAS BEEN REAL AND THERE
HAVE BEEN REVISIONS BASED ON
THE FEEDBACK THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES HAS RECEIVED. I THINK-
ONE OTHER IMPORTANT PIECE IS
RELATED TO THE STATE OPIOID
RESPONSE GRANT WHICH IS A
FEDERAL GRANT APART FROM THE
USUAL- SAM'S A BLOCK GRANT FOR
SUBSTANCE ABUSE PREVENTION AND
TREATMENT. AND WE'RE UPDATING
OUR PROPOSAL TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT FOR THAT FUNDING IN
ADDITION TO THE USUAL BLOCK
GRANT FUNDING THAT WE RECEIVE
FROM SAM SO- TO FOCUS ON MANY
OF THE ACUTE NEEDS THAT ARE
RELATED TO- ARE OPIOID RESPONSE
BUT ALSO HOPEFULLY HAVING MORE
CREATIVE RESPONSES. THAT
REFLECT THE FACT THAT
METHAMPHETAMINE OVERDOSE RATES
HAVE EXCEEDED- OPIOID OVERDOSE
RATES. ARE YOU ARE YOU LOOKING.
TO COMPETITIVE GRANTS THAT THE
OFFER. IN WHAT WHAT'S THE
STATUS OF THOSE THOSE KINDS OF
ISSUES I'D HAVE TO TAKE THAT
BACK TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES TO SEE
WHAT WHAT APPLICATIONS THEY
MIGHT BE CONSIDERING BUT I'M
GLAD TO GET THAT INFORMATION
FOR YOU SENATOR OF WE WANT TO
HAVE. I GUESS A- RELATIONSHIP
WITH FAMILIES IN SCHOOLS
IMPROVED CAN YOU TALK ABOUT THE
ISSUE OF SCHOOL AGE AT THE
EDUCATION COMMUNITY AND MENTAL
HEALTH AND WHAT IS BEING DONE
TO STRENGTHEN THE CONNECTIONS
OF PROVIDING- MENTAL HEALTH
CARE IN BOTH IN AND OUTSIDE OF
THE SCHOOL SYSTEMS SURE I THINK
THAT THAT'S A REALLY IMPORTANT
PARTNERSHIP AND POINT AND I
THANK YOU FOR RAISING THAT AS A
FORMER EDUCATOR MIDDLE SCHOOL
TEACHER. UNDERSTAND THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE ALIGNMENT OF
BEHAVIORAL SYSTEM WE HAVE SOME
TEACHERS HERE OR JUST ONE I
THOUGHT IT OUT OF POINT THAT
OUT WONDERFUL GLAD TO HAVE
SPREAD TO HAVE A RUBIO WAS A
TEACHER AND CEREMONY RIGHT
THAT'S WONDERFUL. YOUR TEACHER
THE HOUSE WAS A BAD STUDENT.
GLAD TO HAVE ALLIES EDUCATE
HERE OKAY A FEW WORDS ABOUT
THAT SO. I THINK WE ARE WE
UNDERSTAND THAT WE HAVE SOME
WORK TO DO TO BETTER ALIGN WHAT
WE'RE PROVIDING THROUGH MANY OF
OUR COUNTY SPECIALTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SYSTEMS POSSIBLY ALSO
THROUGH. THE MEDICAL MANAGED
CARE PLANS IN TERMS OF SERVICES
THEY MAY BEOFFERING TO YOUTH
AND YOUNG ADULTS AS WELL- AND
TWO CHILDREN. AND THE MORE THAT
WE CAN ALIGN WHAT'S IN THOSE
BENEFITS PACKAGES WHAT CAN BE
DELIVERED ON SCHOOL SITES ON TO
MY COMMENTS THAT WERE PREPARED
HERE. IF WE CAN MEET STUDENTS
AND USE WHERE THEY ARE AND A
MORE INTEGRATED FASHION- WHICH
FOR MOST STUDENTS IS SCHOOL
THAT'S WHERE THEY SPEND THE
MAJORITY OF THEIR DAYS- I THINK
THAT WILL BE A REALLY FRUITFUL
EFFORT AND SO. I THINK TO THE
EXTENT THAT WHATEVER
PROGRAMMING WERE WERE LAUNCHING
THROUGH THE BUDGET PROPOSAL OR
WHATEVER WE'RE DOING THROUGH
THE WAIVER PROPOSALS THAT WE
ARE- BEING STRATEGIC AND HOW WE
INCENTIVIZE COUNTIES. TO ALIGN
MORE CLOSELY WITH THEIR THEIR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS. YEAH I THINK
THAT'S GOING TO BE IMPORTANT
AREA WE HAVE THE SURGEON
GENERAL IN TALKING ABOUT
ADVERSE CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCES
AND- HOW THAT AFFECTS A NUMBER
OF DIFFERENT THINGS. LIKE
EDUCATIONAL ACHIEVEMENT.
ABILITY OFTHE TEACHERS TO
TEACH IN A CLASSROOM WITH KIDS
THAT HAVE. BEHAVIORAL ISSUES
THAT NEED TO BE HANDLED.
APPROPRIATELY THERAPEUTICALLY.
AND IT THERE A STRONG LAW. TO
WE NEED. WITH THE EDUCATION
SYSTEM. AND A BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SYSTEM. I THINK THAT'S THAT'S A
VERY WORTHWHILE GOAL AND I
SHOULD MENTION TO THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION IS
OPERATIONALIZE IN SOME FUNDING.
FOR INNOVATIVE PARTNERSHIPS
BETWEEN SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND-
AND COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SYSTEMS TO DO THE KIND OF
INNOVATIVE WORK THAT YOU'RE
DESCRIBING SO I THINK.
ABSOLUTELY WE NEED TO THINK OF
HOW OUR TOOLS THROUGH MEDICAL
TRANSFORMATION HELP US TO DO
THAT WORK AND TO SITUATE THE
CLINICIANS THAT THAT ARE
PREPARED TO SERVE YOUTH
PARTICULARLY THOSE WITH SPECIAL
NEEDS WITHIN THEIR SCHOOLS AND
MEETING THEM. AGAIN WHERE THEY
SPEND MOST OF THEIR TIME. SOME
AND NOW I'D LIKE TO ASSN AREA
ABOUT- AN AREA I'VE BEEN VERY
INVOLVED IN THAT SO. THE ISSUE
OF PEER SUPPORT SYSTEMS THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS
SUPPORTED IN NOW FORTY EIGHT
STATES ARE HAVING ON YOUR
SUPPORT- CERTIFICATE. ASSESSES
AT THE STATE LEVEL AND WHAT IS
THE PROGRESS ON THAT- THAT IS
GOING ON WITH THAT ISSUE. I
THINK THAT WE ALIGN WITH A GOAL
OF HAVING A MORE PURE SUPPORT
AND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DELIVERY
SYSTEMS- I THINK THE ISSUE IS
HOW TO FINANCE THAT AND CLEARLY
THROUGH THE BUDGET PROCESS THE
THIS YEAR THE ADMINISTRATION IS
OPEN TO DISCUSSION ABOUT HOW TO
APPROACH THAT. THANK YOU OF
SENATOR MORNING. CENTER MORE ON
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR PRE
SHEET YEAR ORGANIZING THIS
DOCTOR CONELLY THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION IN WORK. ONE
OF FOCUS YOU YOU OUTLINED
BROADLY SOLUTION AREAS AND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT IN TELE
MEDICINE TELEHEALTH- TO HAVE
ANY MORE SPECIFIC
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR WERE THE
ADMINISTRATION SCHOOLS WOULD BE
SUPPORTED BY SPECIFIC
LEGISLATIVE ACTION FROM THE
LEGISLATURE. THAT'S A GOOD
QUESTION I THINK ONE AREA I CAN
JUST SPEAK BROADLY ABOUT AREAS
WHERE I THINK WE SEE NEED IN
WHERE TELL HEALTH COULD BE
HELPFUL CERTAINLY WE HAVE A
SHORTAGE IN MANY REGIONS OF THE
STATE. OF CLINICIANS WHO
CONSERVE YOUTH WITH BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH CONDITIONS A SHORTAGE OF
PSYCHIATRISTS OF COURSE BUT
ALSO OTHERS AND IF THERE AE
WAYS THAT WE CONNECT- RESOURCE
RICH CENTERS OR FACILITIES WITH
AREAS OF THE STATE REMOTELY
THROUGH TELEHEALTH TECHNOLOGIES
THAT WOULD I THINK BE A VERY
FRUITFUL ENDEAVOR. YEAH AND I
AGREE WITH THAT TO A POINT ONE
OF MY CONCERNS I REPRESENT A
RURAL AREA OF THE CHAIR
MENTIONS THEWORK OF THE
SURGEON GENERAL ON ADVERSE
CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCES- OFTEN A
PRIMARY CARE PHYSICIAN-
CLINICIAN. CAN DETERMINE THAT A
CHILD IS FACING CHALLENGES BUT
THERE'S NOT AVAILABLE-
MULTICULTURAL MULTI LINGUAL
RESOURCES- TELEHEALTH MAY HELP
BRIDGE THAT GAP. BUT I ALSO
SHARE CONCERN THAT WE NOT. LOW
IF YOU WILL. ACCESS TO
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES ONLY
THROUGH TELEMEDICINE-
TELEHEALTH THERE'S GONNA BE
CIRCUMSTANCES. NOT JUST IN
MENTAL HEALTH AND BEHAVIOR
HEALTH BUT ALSO IN. IN OTHER
HEALTH WHERE. TELEMEDICINE IS
NOT THE SOLUTION HEADING
HEADING YOU HOW DO YOU PROPOSE
THAT WE DON'T JUST SEE
TELEHEALTH IS THE PANACEA AND
THEN RELEGATE PEOPLE IN RURAL
AREAS SUPPORT COMMUNITIES TO
THEIR ONLY INTERACTION BEING ON
A VIDEO SCREEN. SURE AND I I'VE
I SHARE THAT VIEW I THINK THAT
TELL HEALTH IS ONE TOOL THAT WE
SHOULD BE EXPLORING AND USING
WHEN APPROPRIATE. AND IT CAN
ALSO BE USED NOT JUST FOR
DIRECT SERVICE DELIVERY BUT
ALSO CONSULTATION WITH
PRACTITIONERS WHO MAY BE
PRIMARY CARE PROVIDERS- MAYBE
PEDIATRICIANS ARE OTHER
PROVIDERS IN THOSE COMMUNITIES
SUCH THAT THEY CAN THEY CAN
GAIN SOME EXPERTISE FROM A
SPECIALIST TO MAY BE SITUATED
REMOTELY- SO WE DON'T REPLACE
THAT THAT IN PERSON- SERVICE-
RELATIONSHIP OR THERAPEUTIC
ALLIANCE THAT MAYBE THERE. IN
ADDITION I THINK- WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT STRATEGIES THAT
INCENTIVIZE CLINICIANS TO
RECEIVE TRAINING AND TO
PRACTICE IN THEIR COMMUNITIES
ARE ALSO THINGS THAT- THIS
ADMINISTRATION AND THE CURRENT
BUDGET YEAR HAS EXPLORED AND
THAT WE WOULD SUPPORT AS WELL
IF THERE ARE WAYS THAT WE THAT
WE CAN EXPLORE. AGAIN
DEVELOPING THE FOLKS IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES WHO UNDERSTAND THE
NEEDS TO LIVE EXPERIENCE-
PROVIDE CULTURALLY APPROPRIATE
IN RESPONSE OF TREATMENT I
THINK THAT'S THAT'S ALSO VERY
WORTHWHILE GOAL BUT THINK ALSO
IN TERMS OF SPECIFIC BUDGET-
FOCUS ON WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
CAN YOU SHARE ANY OF THOSE.
INITIATIVES WITH THIS I THINK
WE ARE CERTAINLY OPEN IT WE
REALIZE THAT IT IS A PRIMARY
NEED AND AN ESSENTIAL PART. OF
PROVIDING MORE CAPACITY FOR-
THE PEOPLE THAT WE SERVE IN THE
PEOPLE THAT. THAT ARE- NOT
NECESSARILY ACCESS ACCESSING
COORDINATED- AND TIMELY
SERVICES ACROSS THE STATE SO
IT'S AN AREA OF FOCUS THERE ARE
AND I THINK A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT IDEAS THAT WERE
EXPLORING. BUT AGAIN OPEN TO
CONVERSATION WITH THE
LEGISLATURE ABOUT ONE IS WE
HAVE A PROGRAMS WE'VE HAD
PROGRAMS TO ATTRACT. PHYSICIANS
TO HELP WITH LOAN REPAYMENT IF
THEY- PURSUE THEIR RESIDENCY
TRAINING OR PRACTICE IN RURAL
OR UNDERSERVED AREAS- THAT'S
BEEN A FIGHT. TO KEEP THE THAT
FUNDING IN OUR BUDGET I HOPE
THE GOVERNOR AND THE
LEGISLATURE WOULD SUPPORT. NOT
JUST RETAINING THAT BIT.
LOOKING TO HOW WE MIGHT
INCREASE THAT IN BEYOND JUST
PHYSICIAN TRAINING. IN
RETENTION AND UNDERSERVED AREAS
OTHER HEALTH PROFESSIONALS COME
IN AND FINELY DECEIT
MINISTRATION HAVE ANY
ASSESSMENT OF THE CURRENT
FEDERAL ADMINISTRATIONS.
LOOKING AT THE PUBLIC CHARGE-
RESIDENTS WHO ARE RECEIVING
FORMS OF PUBLIC ASSISTANCE
INCLUDING. MEDIC COUNT FOR
MEDICAL ASSISTANCE- THAT CAN BE
USED AGAINST THEM IN TERMS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS HAD IS THAT
SPILL OVER TO PEOPLE BEING
FEARFUL OF PURSUING- AVAILABLE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH COUNSELING
SERVICES TREATMENT BUT NOW THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IMPEDIMENT
DID YOU PURSUE THIS TREATMENT
OR YOUR CHILD A US CITIZEN
CHILD- YOU ME FACE DEPORTATION.
IT'S CERTAINLY AN AREA OF GREAT
CONCERN AND WE EXPRESS
DISAGREEMENT WITH THE FINAL
RULE THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT RELEASED WE WERE-
AND ALSO A BIT- YOU KNOW WE
WERE WE WERE I THINK
DISAPPOINTED BY THIS THE COURT
RULING THAT THAT WE SAW
SUBSEQUENT TO THAT. AND SO I
THINK AT THIS POINT ARE OUR
FOCUS HAS BEEN ON MAKING SURE
THAT PEOPLE HAVE THE
INFORMATION THAT THEY NEED TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT COULD HAPPEN-
IN WHICH CIRCUMSTANCES AND
BE NECESSARILY NEGATIVELY
AFFECTED BY IT ARE ABLE TO SEEK
THE SERVICES TO WHICH THEY'RE
ENTITLED AND THAT ARE AVAILABLE
EXACTLY AND WHAT ARE WE DOING
TO MAKE SURE THAT INFORMATION
IS BROADLY DISSEMINATED.
DISSEMINATED SOMETHING WE'VE
BEEN WORKING IN COORDINATION
WITH THE DEPARTMENTS- AS WELL
AS WITH HEALTH PLANS INC AND
COUNTIES. AND PROVIDER DELIVERY
SYSTEMS TO ENSURE THAT THAT
INFORMATION IS BEING
DISSEMINATED SO WE DO HAVE TO
WORK CLOSELY WITH WITH THOSE
SYSTEMS THOSE STAKEHOLDERS AS
WELL AS FOLKS WHO ARE.
ADVOCATES OUT IN THE COMMUNITY
TO MAKE SURE THAT INFORMATION
IS ACCURATE AND DISSEMINATED
WIDELY SO THAT. AGAIN WE'RE NOT
PREVENTING FOLKS FROM GETTING
THE SERVICES THEY NEED AND I
KNOW THIS IS. DYNAMIC AND IT'S
KIND OF IN A CHANGING TARGET
BUT I'D APPRECIATE ANY
INFORMATION YOU MIGHT SHARE
WITH US THAT. ILLUSTRATES HOW
THAT INFORMATION IS BEING
DISSEMINATED STRUGGLING TO DO
THAT SO I THINK YOU MISTER
CHAIR SERMONS. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. DOCTOR CONNELLY. THIS
CAN OF JOB OFFER CENTER MY-
THIS WE HAVE A MEDI CAL UPDATE
IN IN THE MATERIALS AND
GOVERNOR NEW SOME LAST WEEK IN
A STATE OF THE STATE REALLY-
BROACH THE SUBJECT OF LETTERMAN
PETRIE SHORT ACT. AND YOU KNOW
TRYING TO FIND FUNDING FOR
TREATING. INDIVIDUALS WITH
MENTAL ILLNESS- AND SO WE HAVE
THE INSTITUTION FOR MENTAL
DISEASES THE I AM D. THAT HAS
SORT OF EXCLUDED. A PAYMENTS OF
MEDICAID FOR FACILITIES THAT
HAVE SIXTEEN OR MORE BEDS- I
SAW JUST AT THE END OF MAYBE
LAST YEAR JUST RECENTLY THAT.
WASHINGTON DC IN THE
ADMINISTRATION WE'LL GET A
WAIVER TO THE TO THE TO THE
DISTRICT OF COLUMBIA AND SO I'M
JUST WONDERING WHAT
CALIFORNIA'S DOING IN THE SAME
REGARD TO TRY AND- A SIMILAR.
TO ASSIST IN WATER GOVERNOR'S
TRYING TO PURSUE. THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTION SO THIS THIS
PROPOSAL OR THIS OPTION IS ONE
ELEMENT OF THE KELLY IN SUITE
OF PROPOSALS AND WE ARE
EXPLORING HOW WE MIGHT MEET THE
REQUIREMENTS THAT THE CENTERS
FOR MEDICARE AND MEDICAID
SERVICES- HAS ATTACHED TO THAT
THAT OPTION TO RECEIVE AND I AM
THE WAIVER FOR SPECIALTY MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES- FOR EXAMPLE WE
HAVE TO GREATLY REDUCE THE
LENGTH OF STAY IN AND I AM D.
TO AN AVERAGE OF THIRTY DAYS
STATEWIDE. TO ACCESS FEDERAL-
MATCHING FUNDS FOR THAT LEVEL
OF CARE THROUGH MEDICAID AND SO
THAT THAT'S GOING TO BE A
CHALLENGE FOR US THOUGH I THINK
IT'S A HEALTHY CHALLENGE FORD-
BOTH THE US AT THE STATE LEVEL
BUT ALSO FOR DELIVERY SYSTEMS
TO TRY TO MOVE FOLKS WHENEVER
POSSIBLE TO THE LOWEST LEVEL OF
CARE THAT'S CLINICALLY
APPROPRIATE IN THE COMMUNITY.
SUCH THAT FOLKS ARE ARE SERVED
IN THE MOST INTEGRATED
ENVIRONMENT IN THE COMMUNITY
IM IN THE LEAST RESTRICTIVE
FASHION POSSIBLE- I KNOW THAT
WE DEFINITELY WANT TO ACCESS
FUNDING FOR WHATEVER
APPROPRIATE LEVELS OF CARE
AVAILABLE- IN OUR OUR COUNTY
DELIVERY SYSTEMS FOR SPECIALTY
MENTAL HEALTH. BUT ALL AND
DON'T WANT TO RETURN TO THE
DAYS OF WHEN WE JUST ARE LEAN
TOO HEAVILY ON HAVE BEEN PEOPLE
IN LINE CELEBRITIES ARE
INVOLVED IN INVOLUNTARY TREAT
ENVIRONMENTS. BUT WE DON'T
REALLY HAVE MUCH IN THE WAY OF
COMMUNITY- FACILITIES. THERE
CERTAINLY IS. BUT I WOULD AGREE
HE WON AT AND SO PART THIS
EFFORT BY THINK YOU YOU RIGHTLY
RAY. THAT A PART OF THIS OF DID.
A PROPOSED FOR THE FEDERAL
RELATED TO ACCESSING FEDERAL
FINANCING FOR MEDICAID FOR I AM
DISS ALSO MORE X. EXPENSIVELY
DEVELOPING. OUR COMMUITY BASED
SYSTEMS OF CARE SUCH THE FOLKS
ARE RECEIVING TREATMENT-
HOPEFULLY SUPPORT OF HOUSING IN
ADDITION TO AFTER CARE. WHEN
THERE AND- IN IN THE COMMUNITY
AS WELL. SO ARE WE LOOKING OVER
THE WHOLE STRUCTURE FROM YOUR
DEPARTMENT OR WE GONNA RELY ON
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
YOU'RE- GONNA GET SOME
LEADERSHIP AND TRYING TO. DO
SOMETHING THAT HS MISERABLY
FAILED FOR FIFTY YEARS IN THE
STATE. IT IS IT IS A HEAVY LIFT
I WILL ACKNOWLEDGE THAT AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES HAS BEGUN THIS
CONVERSATION THROUGH THE WITH
THE WAIVER AND WILL EFFORT IN
THE MEDICAL TRANSFORMATION
EFFORT. TO TALK THROUGH WHAT
THE DIFFERENT REQUIREMENTS THAT
CMS IS SET OUT FOR US TO GET
SOMETHING LIKE THIS APPROVED.
AND TO REALLY LOOK AT HOW DO WE
BUILD OUT THE CONTINUING I
CAN'T JUST BE AN EFFORT TO GAIN
MORE FEDERAL FINANCING FOR
LOCKED FACILITIES IT HAS TO BE
A MORE COMPREHENSIVE EFFORT. TO
BUILD OUT SYSTEMS OF CARE THAT
REALLY ENABLE PEOPLE TO MOVE
TOWARD RECOVERY AND SUPPORT
THEM THROUGH THAT PROCESS BUT-
IT IS THERE ARE MANY MANY
PIECES TO THAT. MANY
REQUIREMENTS SET OUT A MINUTE
WILL REQUIRE PLANNING AND A
LOOK AT AT WORK FORCES WE
DISCUSSED EARLIER
INFRASTRUCTURE FINANCING OVER
BREEDING ALL THE DIFFERENT- THE
DIFFERENT TYPES OF FUNDING THAT
WE HAVE FOR THAT. SO DON'T
DON'T HESITATE TO CALL ON ME TO
HELP OUT WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AS IT RELATES TO
THIS I AM DO YOU EVER. YOU DO
HAVE A COUPLE REPUBLICANS LEFT
THAT MAYBE. WE CAN YOU KNOW
ASSIST IN SOME FORM OR FASHION
IT'S A TEAM EFFORT AND WE'RE
WE'RE GLAD TO HAVE THAT OFFER.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU OF SIR MORE
LIKE WEEKLY. I THINK OVER THE-
THREE YEARS. I CAN GET A COPY
IS THE LEGISLATURE HAS PASSED.
ONE RESOLUTION AS AN ASSEMBLY
AND ONE IN THE SENATE. ARE
REQUESTING- MODIFICATION OF THE
I AM THE WAIVER AND ALL ALL
MAKE SURE EVERYBODY HAS A COPY
OF THAT BECAUSE WE'VE WE'VE WE
RECOGNIZE THE- THERE IS A NEED
AT SOME POINT FOR SOME TYPES OF
FACILITIES. ARE FOR PEOPLE THAT
NEED THAT KIND OF CARE. WE
SHOULD HAVE A FULL SERVICE OF
CONTINUING CARE. AND MANY
DIFFERENT- WAYS IF WE WANT.
AVOID PEOPLE GETTING TO THE
POINT WHERE THEY NEED THAT KIND
OF- OF HIGH LEVEL CARE. SO WE
NEED ALL THE TYPES OF CARE. TO
AVOID THE NUMBERS GOING TO THE
HIGH LEVEL OF CARE OR-
HOMELESSNESS IN ONE YOU KNOW
TALK ABOUT THAT TOO IS AN
OPTION SO CENTERS TO RUBIO HAS
SOME QUESTIONS SENATOR. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR I WILL FIRST I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE- THIS IS SUCH AN IMPORTANT
TOPIC ESPECIALLY AS IT PERTAINS
TO. OUR EDUCATIONAL SYSTEMS-
MENTAL CLARITY AS AN EDUCATOR I
SAW. BUT YOU KNOW HOW IT
ESCALATED THROUGHOUT THE YEARS
YOU KNOW IN MY AREA WHERE I
TODD- SPECIAL LIKE FOOD AND
SECURITY HOUSING CRISIS ALL
THAT CAUSES A LOT OF ANXIETY
AMONG OUR STUDENTS AND- I'M
JUST REALLY THANKFUL THAT
YOU'RE HERE AND DIE I JUST
WANNA. YOU KNOW SORT OF ECHO
WHAT I THINK MR MONEY IN SAID
HERE SOMETIMES- I REPRESENT
LIKE THE EAST LA COLLEGE AREA
AND WE HAVE PREDOMINANTLY.
SPANISH SPEAKERS AND MANY OF
THOSE AREAS INCHES BEING
MINDFUL OF HAVING CULTURALLY
COMPETENT PEOPLE TO BE ABLE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE DIFFERENCES
AND- AND YOU KNOW AREAS IS
IMPORTANT- BUT JUST THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE AND THANK YOU
CHAIR FOR ALLOWING ME TO SIT
HERE TODAY. THANK YOU THANK YOU
SIR I HOPE YOU FOLLOW UP
WITHOUT ISSUE I KNOW THAT. ARE
TWO SPEAKERS FROM WILL HAVE
WERE HERE FROM THE MASTER ON
THIS OF CHICKEN THAT'S- DOCTOR
GOT LIKE CO- FROM UC DAVIS
WHO'S GONNA TALK ABOUT THE-
DISPARITIES- RACIAL AND ETHNIC
DISPARITIES IN TERMS OF
SERVICES AND HIS. HIS THAN AT
THE MASTER IF YOU WANT TO SAY
IT THAT WAY ON THAT SUBJECT
HELLO WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR COMING IN AND WISH YOU THE
BEST AND- WILL SERVER THAT THE
SENATE. ALL UP ON MANY OF THESE
ISSUES THANK YOU. THANK YOU TO
THE CHAIR INTO THE CONSOLE HERE
MICHELLE CRASS CRASS SHE'S THE
DISTINGUISHED PROFESSOR. AND
DIRECTOR OF INNOVATIVE
TREATMENT NETWORK AT UCLA ON
DEPRESSION. GRAND CHALLENGE OR
TALK ABOUT THAT NO WELCOME I'M
GLAD YOU'RE HERE. SO TURN OVER
YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION. YES
SO I'M HERE TO TALK ABOUT WHAT
UCLA HAS BEEN UNDERTAKING IN
ORDER TO ADDRESS THE CRISIS
THAT'S HAPPENING IN OUR YOUNGER
POPULATION PARTICULARLY
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS AND
PARTICULARLY WORKING WITH THE
EAST LA COLLEGE AT THE MOMENT
SO. A LITTLE BIT OF YOU KNOW
WHAT IS THE STATE OF AFFAIRS
DEPRESSION AND ANXIETY-
DRAMATICALLY INCREASING
PARTICULARLY AMONG EIGHTEEN TO
TWENTY FIVE YEAR OLDS. AND THIS
INCREASE EXTENDS TO SUICIDE
SUICIDE IS NOW THE SECOND
LEADING CAUSE OF DEATH AMONG
ADOLESCENTS AND YOUNG ADULTS.
RUSSIAN AND ANXIETY ALSO
CONTRIBUTE TO OTHER RISKY
BEHAVIORS OF COSTS- SUBSTANCE
USE BEING ONE OF THE MAIN ONES
AND DEPRESSION AD ANXIETY A
MAJOR CONTRIBUTORS TO ACADEMIC
UNDER ACHIEVEMENT. SCHOOL
DROPOUT AND IMPAIRMENTS WOULD
WORK AND AT HOME AND SO AS YOU
CAN IMAGINE. A POOR MENTAL
HEALTH AND FINANCIAL STRESS
LIVE IN A VERY VICIOUS CYCLE
OFTEN CULMINATING IN POVERTY
AND HOMELESSNESS. AND SEVERAL
OF THESE REASONS DEPRESSION
ANXIETY A NOW CONSIDERED THE
LEADING CAUSE OF DISABILITY
WORLDWIDE AND THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION RECOGNIZES THAT
DEPRESSION. WILL BE THE LEADING
CONTRIBUTOR TO GLOBAL DISEASE
BURDEN ABOVE AND BEYOND ALL
OTHER MEDICAL CONDITIONS BY THE
YEAR TWENTY THIRTY. SO WITH
FACING AN EPIDEMIC AND THIS
STATE OF AFFAIRS IS ACTUALLY
AMPLIFIED IN COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. AND THAT INCLUDES THE
HUNDRED FIFTEEN CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES SWITCHING
ROLE TO POINT ONE MILLION
STUDENTS. RATES OF DEPRESSION
ANXIETY AND OTHER MENTAL HEALTH
PROBLEMS ARE TYPICALLY MUCH
HIGHER IN THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
POPULATION RELATIVE TO FOUR
YEAR COLLEGES ONE OF THE
ESTIMATES IS THAT ONE HALF. OF
STUDENTS AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES
HAVE AT LEAST ONE MENTAL HEALTH
PROBLEM. AND THOSE OF YOU HAVE
THE HAND SHOWS HERE THE RATES
JUST FOR DEPRESSION. AND
DEPRESSION SEVERE DEPRESSION
THIS IS VERY DISABLING SEVERE
DEPRESSION IS ESTIMATED TO
AFFLICT 20% OF STUDENTS AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. COMPARED
210% IN FOUR YEAR COLLEGES. NOW
OF COURSE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS FACE ADDITIONAL LIFE
CHALLENGES THAT INTERSECT WITH
MENTAL HEALTH PROBLEMS. SO IF
YOU LOOK AT THE NEXT PAGE
YOU'LL SEE THAT THE RATES OF
FOOD IN SECURITY. HOUSING IN
SECURITY AND HOMELESSNESS ARE
ALREADY AT ASTOUNDINGLY HIGH
RATES IN THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
POPULATIONS SIR THE TOP HALF
SHOWING RATES WHEN THERE IS NO
MEDICAL DISABILITY. BUT AS YOU
CAN IMAGINE WHEN THERE'S A
PSYCHOLOGICAL DISORDER PRESENT
THOSE RATES GO EVEN HIGHER.
SUCH THAT OVER ONE IN FOUR OF
THE STUDENTS ARE HOMELESS. AND
OVER TWO THIRDS OF FACING
HOUSING IN SECURITY. AND YET
THEY'RE ATTENDING COLLEGE SO
THEY'RE REMARKABLY RESILIENT
PEOPLE. SO ALTHOUGH WE DO HAVE
EFFECTIVE TREATMENTS FOR
DEPRESSION AND ANXIETY MANY
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS DO
NOT RECEIVE ANY KIND OF CHAOS.
SO IF YOU GO TO THE NEXT PAGE
YOU'LL SEE THAT- OF THE HUNDRED
AND FOURTEEN COMMUNITY COLLEGES
THAT WAS SURVEYED IT APPEARED
THAT NINETEEN HAD NO SERVICES
WHATSOEVER. AND OF THE
REMAINING COMMUNITY COLLEGE IS
IT'S VERY HARD TO QUANTIFY
EXACTLY WHAT THEY DO HAVE BUT
HAVING WORKED WITH EAST LA-
COLLEGE WHICH SERVES OVER
THIRTY SIX THOUSAND STUDENTS.
THEY HAVE ONE LICENSED CLINICAL
SOCIAL WORKER TO MASSES OF
SOCIAL WORK AND TWO INTERNS
SERVING THAT POPULATION WITH
SOME ADDITIONAL SERVICES FOR
VETERANS SO OBVIOUSLY UNDER
SERVICED. AND OF COURSE THE
RESULT OF THIS IS THAT STUDENTS
WITH VERY HIGH NEEDS AND
SUICIDALITY I'M NOT GETTING THE
RIGHT KIND OF CARE. THAT THIS
LACK OF- AND MENTAL HEALTH FOR
THE ENTIRE SPECTRUM FROM
PREVENTION THROUGH INTERVENTION
AND TREATMENT AND THIS LACK OF
INTEGRATION WITH ALL OTHER
KINDS OF NEEDS THOSE BEING
HOUSING FOOD AS WELL. AND ONE
THING THAT I'LL MENTION IS THE
HEALTHY MINDS NETWORK WHICH IS
A LARGE- TEAM FOR MICHIGAN THAT
STUDIES THE STATE OF AFFAIRS OF
COLLEGE STUDENTS ACROSS NORTH
AMERICA. HAS HAS MADE HAS
ESTIMATED THAT IF WE WERE TO
PROVIDE HIGH QUALITY MENTAL
HEALTH TO COLLEGE STUDENTS.
THERE WOULD BE SIGNIFICANT
SAVINGS IN TERMS OF TUITION
REVENUE BY REDUCING THE NUMBER
WHO DROP OUT BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY THE BE SIGNIFICANT
INCREASES IN THE EXPECTED
LIFETIME EARNINGS OF THE
STUDENTS. THE SOLAR FAR
OUTWEIGH THE COST OF DELIVERING
THE MENTAL HEALTH CARE. SO YOU
SEE LAYS BEING COMING UP WITH A
SOLUTION. TO THIS PROBLEM OF-
RATES OF DEPRESSION ANXIETY IN
COLLEGE STUDENTS- WE CALL IT
THE STAND PROGRAM SCREENING AND
TREATMENT FOR ANXIETY
DEPRESSION. IT DELIVERS
SCALABLE GOLD STANDARD EVIDENCE
BASED TREATMENTS THAT A
PERSONALIZED TO THE NEEDS OF
EACH INDIVIDUAL STUDENT. IT
PROACTIVELY IDENTIFIES IN
RESPONSE TO URGENT NEEDS
SUICIDE HOUSING AND FOOD NEEDS
AND IT CONTINUOUSLY MONITOR IS
THE PATIENT IN ORDER TO ADAPT
THE TREATMENT TO THEIR NEEDS AS
THOSE NEEDS EVOLVE OVER TIME.
SO IT'S A FULLY ADAPTIVE MODEL.
THERE'S A DIAGRAM ON THE NEXT
PAGE WHICH ACTUALLY OUTLINES
THE PROGRAM I'M GOING TO
BRIEFLY WALK YOU THROUGH THE
STEPS OF THIS PROGRAM. IT
BEGINS WITH A MENTAL HEALTH
TRACKER THAT CAN BE ACCESSED AT
ANY TIME AT ANY PLACE ON ANY
INTERNET CONNECTED DEVICE. BY
LINKING TO AN ONLINE ASSESSMENT
THAT MEASURES SYMPTOMS OF
ANXIETY AND DEPRESSION AND
SUICIDALITY IN MANIA. SO SELF
ASSESSMENT USING ADAPTIVE
TESTING. THAT SELF ASSESSMENT
GIVES IMMEDIATE FEEDBACK TO THE
STUDENT OF THEIR CURRENT
RANKING SO TO SPEAK IN TERMS OF
DEPRESSION ANXIETY AND PROVIDES
IMMEDIATE TRIAGE AND WITHIN
MINUTES TWO LEVELS OF CARE.
THOSE LEVELS OF CARE- ARE FULL
OF THEIR FOUR LEVELS OF CÃM
THE FIRST RECORDED TIA IS ZERO
TIA MEANS YOU'RE NOT CURRENTLY
EXPERIENCING ANY SYMPTOMS BUT
YOU MAY ENGAGE IN WHAT TROUBLE.
A WAITING WHERE YOU WOULD
CONTINUE TO TRACK YOUR SYMPTOMS
OVER TIME AND BE ALL FOOD
ONLINE EVIDENCE BASED
PREVENTION TRAINING PROGRAMS.
AT A GUIDED. IF THE STUDENT
COMES IN WITH A MILD LEVELS OF
SYMPTOMS THEY'RE ALL FOOD
EVIDENCE BASED ON LINE
COGNITIVE BEHAVIORAL THERAPY
PROGRAM SUPPORTED BY CERTIFIED
AND TRAINED COACHES. THE
COACHES ARE OTHER STUDENTS
WHO'VE GONE THREE YEAR LONG
TRAINING PROGRAM TO COMBINE THE
ON LINE THERAPY WITH IN PERSON
TOUCH. IF THEY PRESENT WITH
MODERATE SYMPTOMS OF DEPRESSION
OR UP TO SEVERE ANXIETY THEY
AGAIN ARE OFFERED ONLINE
EVIDENCE BASED COGNITIVE
BEHAVIOR THERAPY BUT WITH MORE
ADVANCED COACHES. AND IF THEY
PRESENT TO SEVERE SYMPTOMS OR
SUICIDALITY OR- MANIC SYMPTOMS
THEN THEY ARE ALL FOOD
CLINICIAN DELIVER TREATMENT
IT'S EITHER DONE IN PERSON OR
THROUGH TELEHEALTH DEPENDING ON
THE NEEDS I SHOULD ALSO MENTION
THE COACHING. CLIENT SO IT
TRYING TO COMBINE TELEHEALTH
WITH IN PERSON TOUCH. THEY ARE
CONTINUOUSLY TRACKED SO ONCE
THE TRIAGE INTO A LEVEL OF CARE.
THEY CONTINUOUSLY REPORT THE
SYMPTOMS THROUGH THIS MENTAL
HEALTH TRACKER SO THAT WE CAN
DO TWO THINGS. FIRST ANY
INDICATION OF SUICIDALITY.
SENDS A MESSAGE AN AUTOMATED
ALERT TO A TWENTY FOUR
SEVENTEEN THAT THEN REACHES OUT
TO THE STUDENT TO CHECK ON
THEIR SAFETY SO IT'S VERY-PROACTIVE OUT REACH. SECOND
THIS ONGOING TRACKING ALLOWS US
TO ADAPT TO THE TREATMENT
SURVEY INITIALLY BEGAN WITH A
MILD LEVEL OF DEPRESSION
ANXIETY AND RECEIVING ONLINE
THERAPY. THEIR LIFE CONDITIONS
CHANGE THEY WORSEN WE MOVED UP
TO THE HIGHER LEVEL OF CARE. IF
THEY STARTED IN THE HIGHER
LEVEL OF CARE WAS CLINICIANS
THE ROOM PROVED THEY'VE MOVED
DOWN TO THE LOWER LEVEL OF CARE
BECAUSE MAINTENANCE IS ACTUALLY
CRITICAL TO PREVENTION OF
RELAPSE. SO IF YOU GO TO THE
NEXT PAGE THAT SIMPLY LISTS HOW
THE SYSTEM IS INNOVATIVE. IN
THE WAYS THAT I HAVE DESCRIBED
IT'S AN FULLY INTEGRATED
ADAPTIVE SYSTEM OF CARE AND I
WOULD SPEND MORE TIME ON THAT.
ON THE NEXT PAGE YOU WILL SEE
WHAT WE'VE DONE AT UCLA THIS IS
UP TO A FEW MONTHS AGO WE'VE
OFFERED THIS SCREENING AT UCLA.
TWO FIFTY SEVEN THOUSAND
STUDENTS. A PERSON CLOSE TO
SEVEN THOUSAND HAVE OPTED IN TO
TAKE THE SCREENING THAT'S THAT
MENTAL HEALTH TRACKER. WITH ALL
FOR TREATMENT TO OVER THREE
THOUSAND STUDENTS. WE'VE
RESPONDED TO OVER A THOUSAND
ALERTS FOR SUICIDALITY AND VERY
VERY SEVERE DEPRESSION AND WITH
TRAINED OVER FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY
STUDENTS TO BE COACHES AS IN PS
SUPPORT MECHANISMS. WHERE WE'RE
GOING NOW ON THE NEXT PAGE IS
WE A- DEVELOPING A PILOT
PROGRAM. TO COST TO MINES WHAT
WE HAVE DONE WITH THE STAND
PROGRAM AT UCLA AND MOVED INTO
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES WITH THE
NEED IS SO GREAT FIVE GRACIA
THAN EIGHT UCLA. AND WE HAVE
BEEN WORKING IN COLLABORATION
WITH EAST LOS ANGELES COLLEGE.
FOR THE LAST SIX MONTHS SO THAT
WE CAN ADAPT- PROGRAM TO FIT
THE NEEDS OF THIS STUDENTS.
WELL WORKING WITH THE VICE
PRESIDENT IS JUNE FIFTH AS THE
DEAN OF STUDENT AFFAIRS THE
DIRECTOR OF THE HEALTH SERVICES
WE HAVE A STUDENT ADVISORY
BODY- TO SUPPORTING AND
ADVISING US TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE CONTENT IS RELEVANT TO THEM
IT'S CULTURALLY SENSITIVE. AND
IT COMBINES THEIR MENTAL HEALTH
NEEDS WITHIN NEEDS FOR HOUSING
AND FOOD SECURITY. AND AB TIME
LINE IS THAT WE WILL BE BETA
TESTING A PROGRAM THIS IN THE
NEXT FEW MONTHS WILL BE TESTING
THE CORE ELEMENTS OF THE
PROGRAM AT THE LACK OF THE SAMA
WITH THE EXPECTATION THAT IT
WILL BE FULLY IMPLEMENTED IN A
PILOT STUDY WAS SEVEN HUNDRED
STUDENTS STARTING IN THE FALL
AND I SHOULD SAY THIS IS BEING
DONE IN COLLABORATION. WITH THE
LOS ANGELESCOUNTY DEPARTMENT
OF MENTAL HEALTH. AND THEN
FINALLY. A VISION AND WHAT WE
HAVE- PROPOSED IS TO EXPAND
THIS BEYOND THE LACK. BUT
STATEWIDE. AND SO WORKING WITH
UCSF SO UCLA AND UCSF WORKING
TOGETHER AT THE AS THE HOBBS SO
TO SPEAK. TO EXPAND THIS
PROGRAM OUT TO STARTING WITH
TEN COLLEGES FIVE FOUR WHICH
UCSF IS RESPONSIBLE FIVE WITH
FOR WHICH YOU SEE LAYS
RESPONSIBLE. INCLUDING COLLEGES
IN RURAL AREAS WHERE THE NEED
IS EVEN GREATER SO THAT WE CAN-
EXPAND WHAT WE DOING TO THOSE
MOST IN NEED AND- EVENTUALLY
HOPE TO EXPAND THIS TO EVEN
MORE COLLEGES STATEWIDE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ONE
OF THE QUESTIONS I HAD WHEN I
LOOKED AT THIS WAS- IS YOUR
APPROACH FOR THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE. A DIFFERENT DAY IN THE
UC AND WHAT OUR WATER THE
DISTINCT DIFFERENCES THE
TEMPLATE THIS THE STRUCTURE THE
FORMAT THE TEMPLATE IS THE SAME
IT'S SO IT'S AN INTEGRATED
SYSTEM WHAT DID FOR THIS IS
PRIMARILY THE CONTENT TO BE
RELEVANT THEY NEED SO WE'VE
BEEN WORKING FOR EXAMPLE TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE CONTENT TO
THE ON THERAPY IS RELEVANT TO
VETERANS THAT COMPRISE SOME THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES- TO- THE
LATINO OR LATINA STUDENTS TO
SINGLE MOTHERS TO VARIOUS
SUBGROUPS WITHIN THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES ENVIRONMENT TO A MOST
VULNERABLE TO A DEPRESSION
ANXIETY. AND THAT'S WHERE THE
ADVISORY GROUPS FROM THE STREET
FROM THE STUDENTS AT EACH OF
THESE COLLEGE AT THE LACK HAS
BEEN VERY HELPFUL THE SECOND
DIFFERENCE IS THAT WE'RE
CREATING IN A SINGLE PORTAL
WITH STUDENTS CAN LOG ON TO NOT
ONLY ASSESS THEIR MENTAL HEALTH
BUT THE CURRENT WELL BEING AND
SAFETY SO THE PORSCHE WILL
ASSESS TO YOU HAVE A PLACE TO
STAY TONIGHT YEAH YOU NEED
FOOD- AND- MOVING OUT TO GET
THE RESOURCES AVAILABLE. OKAY
OF HAVE YOU TALKED TO THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CHANCELLOR WE
HAVE TALKED WITH US THEY'RE
TALKING ABOUT LIKE YOU I SEE
YOU'RE YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
GOING THE- TO CAMPUSES. OF
AROUND THE STATUS IN AN TRYING
TO LOOK AT. THE PRODUCTIVITY OF
DOING THAT CORRECT CORRECT YEAH
THAT'S THE NEXT STEP YES OKAY
THE QUESTIONS PLEASE SIR WELLS
WHO GETS TO GO FIRST THIS ONE
OKAY LET'S LET'S SURMOUNTING
OFFERS ANSWER. YES OKAY YOUR
AFTER HIM. YEAH THANK YOU JUST
REAL QUICKLY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
WORK AND FOR BEING HERE TODAY-
SO I GOT SCREENING AND
TREATMENT WHAT'S THE REST OF
THE ACRONYM OF SCREENING AND
TREATMENT FOR ANXIETY AND
DEPRESSION. ANXIETY AND
DEPRESSION AS A SUMMARY IT
ACTUALLY ALSO WORKS THE PROGRAM
COVERS SLEEP IT COVERS TRAUMA
AND WE'RE MOVING TO ALSO COVER
SUBSTANCE USE ME. IN THIS.
INTERACTIVE TOOL ON ANY STUDENT
CAN ACCESS IT. YOU MENTIONED
HIP A PROTECTIONS BUT IS THERE
ANY. DANGER OF OVERLAP OF A
STUDENT ACCESSING THIS- BUT
RAISING CONCERNS OF HOUSING OR
OR OTHER EDUCATIONAL ACCESS
DOES ANY OF THIS IS THERE A
DANGER IN THE THIS FILTERING
INTO A STUDENTS- ACADEMIC
RECORD IN. ADDING TO STIGMA FOR
PURSUING THIS SUPPORT A GOOD
QUESTION THE WAY WE'VE DESIGNED
INTO UCLA AND AS WE IMPLEMENTED
A LACK WITH THE RETAINING
CONFIDENTIALITY OF ALL THE
INFORMATION SO THAT IT DOESN'T
SLIP OVER INTO THEIR ACADEMIC
RECORD. BUT STUDENTS ALSO GIVE
US CONSENT TO HAVE ACCESS TO
THEIR ACADEMIC RECORD BECAUSE
ONE OF THE GOALS OF THE PROGRAM
IS TO IMPROVE ACADEMIC
PERFORMANCE SO IT IT WE GET THE
INFORMATION TO ADD TO OUR
DATABASE THE DATA DOES NOT GO
OVER INTO THEIR I CAN IS THERE
ANY RECORD THAT YOU SAW THAT
INFORMATION IF THEY SIGN THE-
RELEASE. IN IT TO SEC THEN IN
THERE ACADEMIC THAT YOU MADE
THE REQUEST BUT NOT. THAT WOULD
THAT THE CONSENT FORM YES I DO
NOT BELIEVE SO I CAN DOUBLE
CHECK THAT BUT I DO NOT BELIEVE
SO. IN ANSWER THE PILOT PROGRAM
IN EAST LA WITH PLANS TO TRY TO
EXPAND ITS TO TEN COMMUNITY
COLLEGE CAMPUSES YES. WHAT'S
THE FUNDING SOURCE FOR THAT. SO
THAT'S WHERE WE'RE AT RIGHT NOW.
SO WE'RE LOOKING FOR FUNDING WE
DON'T ACTUALLY HAVE A FUNDING
SOURCE FOR THE EXPANSION WE
HAVE BUILT A PROPOSAL OF
COLLABORATION BETWEEN UCLA AND
UCSF UCSF IS DEFINITELY ON
BOARD TO DO THIS BUT WHEN
SEEKING FUNDING AND LOOKING AT
VARIOUS SOURCES. TO TRY TO GET
THAT FUNDING ANY LOOKING IT
SOURCES OTHER THAN THE STATE
BUDGET FOUNDATIONS FUND
PHILANTHROPIC WE'RE LOOKING AT
PHILANTHROPIC WE'RE LOOKING AT-
NATIONAL INSTITUTES OF MENTAL
HEALTH AND WE'RE ALSO LOOKING
AT THE STATE. ONE THANK YOU I
MEAN NEAR YOUR OPENING COMMENTS
ABOUT THE SCOPE OF THIS PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS GLOBALLY. IT
NEEDS TO BE RAISED ARE. HELLO
ORDER YOUR HERE TODAY HELPING
EDUCATE US ANY OTHER- PUBLIC
EDUCATION OR LEGISLATIVE
EFFORTS TO RAISE AWARENESS
AMONG OTHER POLICY MAYOR OTHER
POLICY MAKERS AROUND THE STATE
OR THE COUNTRY. HOW WE DOING
ANYMORE THAT YES THE WESTS
CERTAINLY REACHING OUT TO WITH
BEING- VISITING VARIOUS- POLICY
GROUPS AN TALKING WITH
DIFFERENT ALLIANCES ABOUT WHAT
WE'RE DOING NOT ONLY FOR THE
SAKE OF WHAT WE'RE DOING WHICH
IS TO RAISE THE AWARENESS OF
THE- THE REAL EMERGENCY THAT
WE'RE FACING IN THE YOUNGER
POPULATION- THE WORK FORCE OF
THE FUTURE I MEAN YOU SHARE THE
CHEN I THINK IT WAS AGAIN. HE'S
STILL A WITH THIRTY SIX
THOUSAND STUDENTS IN FIVE- SOME
FIVE PROFESSIONAL YES TWO OF
THOSE INTERNS RATE SO. IF YOU
HAD A MAGIC WAND WHAT WOULD BE.
APPROPRIATE LEVEL OF STAFFING
TO REALLY- BUT BY THE SUPPORT
THAT STUDENTS MIGHT NEED. TO
ANSWER THAT QUESTION THERE WILL
NEVER BE ENOUGH COMMISSIONS TO
ADDRESS THE NEED. AND SO WHILE
THERE IS AN IMPORTANT PLACE TO
CONDITIONS THAT'S WHY NOW MODEL
CLINICIANS ARE RESERVED FOR THE
ONE FOR THE INDIVIDUALS WHO WAS
MOST SEVERE REALLY IT DOES NOT
MAKE SENSE TO GIVE AN ONLINE
THERAPY PROGRAM. BUT MILD TO
MODERATELY DISTRESSED
INDIVIDUALS WILL RECEIVE IF
THEY DO THE PROGRAM AND THAT'S
WHERE THE COACHING COMES IN
WE'LL GET AS MUCH BENEFIT FROM
THAT AS THEY WOULD FOR MANY IN
PERSON THERAPY VISIT. AND IT
PREVENTS THE ESCALATION UP TO
THE HIGHER LEVELS SO WE SEE
THESE THINGS IS WORKING
TOGETHER WE NEED MORE UNDER
CONDITIONS. BUT THAT'S RIGHT.
MORE QUESTIONS AND USING
TECHNOLOGY AND TOGETHER
REDUCING THE BURDEN ON THE ON
THE COMMISSION YEAH SO IT MAY
BE TOO EARLY BUT DO YOU ARE YOU
COLLECTING DATA DO YOU HAVE ANY
DAA TO SHOW. YOU SHARED SOME
NUMBERS OF STUDENTS WHO HAVE
ACCESS TO. THOSE THAT HAVE GONE
TO A MORE SEVERE CATEGORY BUT-
ANY METRICS OF HOW THAT EARLY
INTERVENTION HAS KEPT PEOPLE
THOUGH NOT MANAGEABLE LEVEL YEP
SO OUR RESULTS SHOW THAT I
SHOULD PUT IN A FLOOD OF OUR
RESULTS WITH OUR RESULTS SHOW
THAT THOSE WHO AND WHO ARE IN
THE MILDER LEVELS INTO THE
ONLINE THERAPY. THE SYMPTOMS
REDUCE ON AVERAGE DOWN TO A
NORMAL TO MILD LEVEL- AND THOSE
WHO COMING TO US VIA- CATEGORY
AT FIRST RESPOND VERY
POSITIVELY TO THE TREATMENT SO
WE'RE GETTING VERY GOOD RESULTS
WE DON'T HAVE. RANDOMIZED
CONTROLLED TRIALS WITH THIS.
BECAUSE IT'S AN IMPLEMENTATION
STRATEGY OUR GOAL IS TO SEE
THROUGH COMPARING STUDENTS WHO
ENROLL WITH US TO STUDENTS WHO
DON'T IN ROLE WHAT HAPPENS TO
THEM OVER TIME THREE WELL THANK
YOU THINK THAT DATA WOULD BE OF
INTEREST AS WELL AN INMATE.
BULLS EFFORTS TO MORE FOR. TO
EXPAND THE- THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER. HELLO THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE
I THINK I HAD ALREADY READ THIS
REPORT AND- A FEW MONTHS BACK I
BELIEVE- AND I HAD SPENT SOME
TIME IN EAST LA COLLEGE AND-
WELL FIRST AND FOREMOST I WANT
TO. JUST HIGHLIGHT AND THINK
THE ENTIRE COMMUNITY AROUND
EAST LA COLLEGE BECAUSE IF
REALLY STEPPED UP. THEY FOUND A
REALLY HUNGER IS ONE OF THE
BIGGEST ISSUE THAT OUR STUDENTS
ARE FACING IT IS. IT'S A CRISIS
AND DOES SOME OF THE BUSINESSES
AROUND THERE HAVE. STARTED TO
OFFER VOUCHERS FOR STUDENTS TO
COME IN AND HAVE A MEAL- MANY
REPORTED HAVING. ONE MEAL A DAY
AND THAT IS. VERY MINIMAL AND
SO SOME OF THE BUSINESSES
STARTED SAYING THAT IF THEY
CAME IN WITH A VOUCHER FROM THE
SCHOOL THEY WOULD FEET I'M IN
AND NOT TELL STUDENTS HAVE BEEN
GETTING BY. I'M HOPING TO
EVENTUALLY EXPLORE THIS HOW WE
CAN DO THIS ACROSS THE STATE
WHERE. MAYBE OFFERING TAX
CREDITS FOR BUSINESSES A
PARTICIPAR AROUND COMMUNITY
COLLEGES BUT BUT THAT WAS THE
LEADING CAUSE OF THE STRESS AND
ANXIETY FROM THE STUDENTS THAT
I SPOKE TO- NOT HAPPY MEALS
AND- NOT KNOWING WHERE THEY'RE
GOING TO SLEEP IN. AND SO THIS
IS VERY PROMISING TO ME- AND I
HAD THE SAME QUESTION I
BELIEVE- THAT THE CHAIR ASSN IN
REGARDS TO THE DIFFERENT.
APPROACH FROM EAST EAST LA TO
UCLA IT'S COMPLETELY DIFFERENT
IN TERMS OF. THE COMMUNITY
WE'RE DEALING WITH IN
PARTICULAR BECAUSE I KNOW SOME
OF. THE COMMUNITIES IN THAT
AREA. ARE NOT VERY- WILLING TO
EXPRESS THEY HAVE INSIDE EITHER
NOT WILLING TO COME OUT AND
SAY. THEIR FOR THEIR SUFFERING
FROM TRAUMA THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT'S BEEN. STIGMATIZED FOR A
LONG TIME AS MISTER MONEY
MENTION IT'S REALLY. DELICATE
TO ENSURE THAT THE INFORMATION
DOESN'T LEAK OUT BECAUSE YOU
KNOW THEY'RE ALREADY DEALING
WITH. THAT THE INSECURITY OF
FOOD AND HOUSING AND NOW HAVING
TO BE LABELED- YOU KNOW. IT AN
ARC. I REMEMBER I WENT TO EAST
LA COLLEGE IT WAS SOMETHING YOU
WOULDN'T TALK ABOUT. AND DOES
BUT SHOULD BE LABELED LIKE
EITHER MENTALLY DISTURBED OR
CHALLENGE I MEAN THAT CARRIED
WAIT AROUND TO SOME OF OUR-
COMMUNITY MEMBERS SELL. SUFFERS
ABOUT THANK YOU FOR THE WORK
THAT YOU'RE DOING A IT'S REALLY
PROMISE YOU KNOW I'VE BEEN.
READING ON THIS AND- JUST.
BEING REALLY SENSITIVE ABOUT
THE APPROACH AND I HEARD YOU
SAY EARLIER THAT YOU'RE- A VERY
PARTICULAR ABOUT HOW YOU PULL
APPROACH LATINOS AND LATINAS
IT'S COMPLETELY DIFFERENT. BUT
YOU KNOW I WANT TO CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION WITH YOU OFF LINE
AND HOPEFULLY WE CAN. FIGURE
THIS OUT BUT AGAIN I WANT TO
TAKE THE TIME TO THANK THOSE.
BUSINESS HIS AROUND EAST LOS
ANGELES COLLEGE WHO HAVE. UP AN
OFFER OUT. BUT STUDENT COMES IN
WITH THAT NO FROM THE SCHOOL
AND THEY- FREE. AND SO THAT'S
AND- TO ENSURE THAT OUR KIDS
ARE ABLE TO EAT AND AT LEAST
HAVE WARM MEAL A COUPLE OF
DAYS. I MEAN START COUPLE OF
TIMES A DAY SO THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU SIR
THANK YOU FOR. OBVIOUSLY BEEN
WORKING ON A SUCH WONDERFUL
VERY. GOOD GREAT STORY OF THE-
COMMUNITY COLLEGE COMING
TOGETHER ON A- IT'S BEEN GREAT
TO WORK WITH- ELECTIVES
RELIGION REALLY INSPIRING AND
SIR MORE ART THANK YOU MEASURE
THANK YOU DOCTOR I AM CURIOUS
HOW MANY PSYCHIATRIST. DOES
UCLA PRODUCE EVERY YEAR. WELL
THAT IS THE QUESTION I DON'T
HAVE AN ANSWER I DON'T KNOW OF.
PSYCHIATRISTS I DO NOT KNOW THE
ANSWER TO THAT RESTAURANTS ARE
WAS I WAS HOPING IT SAID LIKE
THIRTY UCI'S PRODUCING ABOUT
NINE YEARS I'M THINKING. THAT
WAY HAS MORE THAN THREE TIMES
THE POPULATION OF ORANGE COUNTY.
INSIDE PSYCHOLOGY WE PRODUCE
ABOUT. TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR
AM OF CLINICAL PSYCHOLOGISTS-
BUT PSYCHIATRY BECAUSE I MAINLY
SITUATION THE PSYCHOLOGY
DEPARTMENT I'M NOT AS FAMILIAR
WITH THE NUMBER. BUT CERTAINLY
NOT ENOUGH IS THE ISSUE AND AS
I SAID BEFORE THIS. WE NEED
MORE COMMISSIONS WE NEED TO
BUILD UP THE WORK FORCE BUT WE
CAN'T I DO THINK ASSUME THAT
THAT WILL BE SUFFICIENT IT'LL
NEVER BE SUFFICIENT WHEN YOU
THINK AT. AT UCLA WHICH ALREADY
HAS IN A VERY GOOD AND SERVICES
WE STILL NEED TO DO THIS
PROGRAM BECAUSE THE SERVICES
ARE OVERWHELMED. WITH DEMAND ON
HEALTH. I LOVE YOUR LOS ANGELES
ACCENT. THE TRICK A STRELA. I'M
CURIOUS WHEN A STUDENT GOES
ONLINE TO DO THE SCREENING AND
TREATMENT. WHAT WHAT'S THE
DROPOUT RATE MONTH SAYS HE THE
CONSENT FORM AND YES ALL THE
REST OF YOU KNOW THEY COULD
CALL ME YOU KNOW I. WOULD THINK
THAT THAT THAT'S GOING TO BE A
LITTLE INTIMIDATING THERE IS A
HIGH DROPOUT RATE- SALUTE THE
IT'S INTERESTING THE THIS THE
THERE'S A DROP OUT FROM THE
POINT TO. DOING A CONSENT TO
DOING THE SCREENING THEN ONCE
HAVE DONE THE SCREENING THERE'S
A DROP OUT FROM THERE TO THE
TREATMENT ENGAGEMENT. MORE WITH
THE DIGITAL ONLINE THERAPY THAN
WITH THE ACTUAL IN PERSON
THERAPY- AND SO WE'RE WORKING
WITH- OF. WE ARE VERY SIT TENSE
TO EDUCATION AROUND THE VALUE
OF THE ON LINE THERAPY PROGRAM-
WHEN IF PEOPLE STAY WITH THE
PROGRAM THEY DO VERY WELL AS I
SAID BEFORE. BUT THAT'S TRUE
THAT DROP OUT IS CHARACTERISTIC
EVERYWHERE. EVEN IN COMMUNITY
CLINICS WHERE YOU HAVE IN
PERSON THERAPY THE AVERAGE
NUMBER SESSIONS THAT PEOPLE
ACTUALLY GET IS ONE. ONE
SESSION. SO IT'S A PROBLEM
EVERYWHERE AND- OCEANS THANK
YOU RICHARD YOU SHOW YOUR TIME
AND I'M REALLY EXCITED ABOUT
THE WORK. OKAY WE'RE- DOWN TO
OUR NEXT PANEL WE'RE GONNA HAVE
TO PEOPLE COME UP WE'RE GONNA
HAVE- SERGIO DOCTOR SERGIO
ANGRY ARE ON DECK SO YOU'LL GET
X. YOLO. SORRY SEARCH SHOWS
FROM USE UC DAVIS AND- AS I
SURGERY EARLIER- CENTER FOR
REDUCING ELSE DISPARITIES AND
PROFESSOR. OF CLINICAL INTERNAL
MEDICINE CHRISTINE SMITH IS
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF MENTAL
HEALTH CALIFORNIA. AND THEY'RE
GOING TO TALK ABOUT. SERVE THE
DIST SURGEONS GOING TALK ABOUT
DISPARITIES IN THAT SUBJECT
CHRISTINE'S GONNA TALK ABOUT
THE YOUTH LISTENING SESSIONS-
OF PATHWAYS TO THE RING
CULTURALLY RELEVANT TREATMENT.
TWO IMPACTED USE AND OUR
BROTHER BE WELL PROGRAM SO. I
GUESS SURGERY YOUR FIRST DAY
WELL THANK YOU- MISTER CHAIR
AND THANK YOU SENATE PERSON
THANK YOU BYE ANYA FOR THESE
CAN BE PATIENT THROUGH CHAIR
SWAMP THOUGHTS ABOUT. A TOPIC
THAT I'M VERY PASSIONATE ABOUT.
IN WHEN I HOPING TO BLOOM. I
KNOW THAT WE ARE CHORE ON TIME
HE IS- WHY MENTAL HEALTH
MATTERS. TO HIGHLIGHT
DISPARITIES IN ACCESS TO CARE
AND UTILIZATION OF SERVICES.
AND FINALLY TO TALK A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT SOLUTIONS TO THOSE
DISPARITIES. IN I'LL TRY TO DO
SOMETHING THAT IS CHALLENGING
WHICH TO SUMMARIZING ABOUT
THIRTY YEARS OF RESEARCH ON YP
MENTAL HEALTH MATTERS. A IN
JUST OVER A THREE FOUR MINUTES
A BUT BUT I THINK THAT IS
IMPORTANT TO PUT THIS IN
CONTEXT ABOUT RELEVANCE IN
MAGNITUDE OF MENTAL DISORDERS.
WELL A I BELIEVE THAT YOU HAVE
A SLIGHT DAY SO- PLEASE. A BEAR
WITH ME ABOUT THAT. THERE ARE
SIX THAT I WANT TO ABOUT THE
MENTAL DISORDERS THE FIRST ONE
IS THAT ARE AMONG THE MOST
PREVALENT CLASSES OF CRIME BCC
CHRONIC DISEASES IN THE GENERAL
POPULATION HOW FREQUENT ARE OUR
DAY. WELL THE CHANNEL FOR
DECADES NOW OF THE FREQUENCY OF
MENTAL DISORDERS IN THE GENERAL
POPULATION IF WE CONSIDER
LIFETIME. PREVALENCE LIFETIME
PREVALENCE IS ABOUT 50% OF THE
POPULATION. IF WE CONSIDER
TWELVE MONTHS. ONE ZERO FOUR
FOUR ONE OUT OF FIVE DEPENDING
ON WHO WE ARE TALKING ^UT.
ARE SUFFERING CURRENTLY OF ONE
OR MORE MENTAL ILLNESSES SO
VERY FREQUENT SECOND IS THAT
BIG CALL CURT. WITH THE CHARTER
SERVE SOMEONE SUFFERS FROM
DEPRESSION HE'S VERY LIKELY.
THE WILL SUFFER FROM MY THE OR
SUBSTANCE ABUSE OR DIABETES OR
OTHER CHRONIC CONDITIONS. SO
THIS IS THESE ARE WHAT WE CALL
CALL MORE THESE. THIRD IS THAT
TYPICALLY HAVE MUCH EARLIER
AGES SELF CONCEPT NINE BOULDER
CHRONIC DISEASES. AND I'LL GIVE
YOU A FEW- AP PIECES OF
INFORMATION ABOUT THAT BUT BASS
THIRD VERY EARLY IN LIFE. A TO
THE POINT THAT THE CALL YOU OF
MIND WHO HAS SPUR THE USE THIS
NATIONAL SURVEYS THAT THE WRONG
CANCER FROM HARPER HIGH SCHOOL
THEN THE CRONY CONDITIONS OF
THE U. YOU KNOW BERRY. I CAN
TELL YOU THAT. HEY 50% OF
MENTAL DISORDERS ARE MANIFESTED
BY AGE FOURTEEN AND BY AGE
247075% GAME THERE IS A LITTLE
BIT MORE INFORMATION BUT I
WOULD LIKE TO DISCUSS AND SHARE
WITH YOU AT IN IN THE NEXT FEW
MINUTES. A THE ONLY THING IS.
THAT MENTAL DISORDERS ARE AMONG
THE MOST DISABLING AWFUL
CHRONIC HEALTH CONDITIONS.
DOCTOR CRASKE ALREADY PER SHARE
WITH US. SOME OF THE- FREQUENCY
I MEAN THE IMPACT IN TERMS OF
THE STABILITY LEASE. BABETTE
BEATTY'S EXCUSE ME DEPRESSION
PRODUCES. BUT IF WE CONSIDER.
THE FALL PAIN COURSES SO BE
SEVERELY. INTERNATIONALLY
CERTAINLY HERE IN THE US FIVE
OR THE OZARK MENTAL DISORDERS
NUMBER ONE. THE CRASH. BUT THE
YOU KNOW THAT OUR- OLDER
SUBSTANCE ABUSE IT'S CENTER. IN
BEING BE. ALSO A SOURCE. WITH
SIGNAL AT BIRTH SO SIDE COSTS
IN I'LL JUST MENTION BRIEFLY
SOMETHING RELATED TO THAT THEY
ARE VERY COSTLY NOT ONLY ON
ABSENTEEISM NO PEOPLE CONTROL
TO WORK- AT BECHTEL SUPPRESSION
V. SOME PEOPLE COME TO WORK BUT
BE ARE ON THE MOON. IN ALL THEY
ARE NOT REALLY PRESSING A TO DO
THAT WORK WHICH IS VERY
DANGEROUS BECAUSE FAR YOU KNOW
ESPECIALLY IN IN OCCUPATIONS.
THAT THE REQUIRED A LOT OF
CONCENTRATION. FINALLY IN
CITY'S THE ONE I WOULD LIKE TO
CONTINUE TO DISCUSS WITH YOU
THESE ONLY A MINORITY WITH
MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS RECEIVE
TREATMENT. IN THE PRECEDING
YEAR. MORE TO COME ABOUT THAT.
OTHER THINGS THAT I WANT TO
MENTION ABOUT MENTAL DISORDERS
AND NOW YOU'RE READY MENTIONED
THAT HOW MAY IN FACT THAT THEY
HAVE ON DISABILITY THAT THE 26%
OF BUBBLES AND ONLY A BABY ARE
DISABLED RELATED TO MENTAL
DISORDERS SPECIES BUT A HUGE
NUMBER. AND 6% WHO SUFFER FROM
CHRONIC IN SERIOUS CONDITIONS
BY PER WEEK COLE SET BEARD AND
PERSISTENT MENTAL ILLNESS. THE
OTHER ONE THE THIRD YOU NOTE
CURRENT. THAT MENTAL DISORDERS
ARE NUMBER ONE LOST WAGES
YOU'RE READY MENTION RELATED TO
WHAT. NUMBER ONE BECAUSE OF
INJURY DATA SPECIFICALLY BY
SUICIDE. NUMBER ONE MOST COSTLY
BIOMEDICAL PROGRAM AIMED NUMBER
ONE MOST AND THEY'RE FUNDED BY
YOUR MEDICAL AREAS
UNFORTUNATELY EVEN WITH HOW
FREQUENT IN BE MADE AT THE
BEING BACKED UP MENTAL
DISORDERS CáC. UNFORTUNATELY
THEY CONTINUE TO BE THE ACTOR
THAT CLEAN OF FOR A PUBLIC
HEALTH. A MORE GAINES CUT BEEN
DONE IN THE AREA MY TO HAS TO
BE DONE. THE OTHER THING THAT I
WON TO. WELCOME TO. INFO SEES.
THE HOW HOW CEASE TO PLAY OUT
IN THE GYM POPULATION. NOTE A
B. S. A. CANCER FAMILY
FOUNDATION A DIVA STUDY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA THIS IS A STATE WIDE
AND THEY FOUND THAT MEANT THE
HELL WAS THE NUMBER ONE HEALTH
CARE PRIORITY FOR CALIFORNIANS.
AIM BE SAME AS STATEWIDE POLL
SHOWED THAT BIT POP HELPED THE
SHOW ISSUE THAT CALIFORNIA'S
ONE BETTER WARNER IN LEGISLATOR
TO ADDRESS HE'S MAKING SURE.
THE TREATMENT IS AVAILABLE FOR
WITH MENTAL HEALTH PROBLEMS 88%
CALL IT EXTREMELY OR VERY
IMPORTANT. YET THE MOST THE
MOST CALIFORNIA'S THING THAT
THERE IS NOT ENOUGH MENTAL
HEALTH CARE AVAILABLE IN THE
STATE. ESPECIALLY EVE DATE
TRIED TO GET IT NBC'S BORN A
GOAL ONCE AGAIN ABOUT WHAT THE
SCHOOL THE TREATMENT GAP IN IN
A MINUTE I'LL. EIGHT EMPHASIZE
SOMETHING SOME OF THAT. TWENTY
THAT IS IMPORTANT TO GREED
ABOUT MENTAL DISORDERS IS THAT
THEY'RE ABLE TO BE HERE LEON
SAID THAT THEY HAVE. THAT THE-
THIS USUALLY FROM THREE TO FOUR
YEARS. INTERVAL BETWEEN THE
FIRST SYMPTOMS AND A FULL BLOWN
PROGRAM WHICH IS A WINDOW OF
OPPORTUNITY FOR PREVENTIVE
INTERVENTIONS FIFTIES. SO THE
ONSET PASSING MENTION THE
MENTAL DISORDERS OF USUALLY
OCCURS IN CHILDHOOD OR
ADOLESCENCE. IN UNFORTUNATELY
THE TREATMENT THE PIGGLY
DOESN'T BEGIN UNTIL YEARS LATER
YOU KNOW WHAT NATION WHY THE
ESTIMATE SEES THAT A IT TAKES
ABOUT ELEVEN TO THIRTEEN YEARS
FOR PEOPLE WITH MENTAL
DISORDERS TO RECEIVE TREATMENT
FOR THE FIRST TIME. IN THE
MEANTIME IT CALLS TO SELL LARA
HIGH BOOK T<c.cyan>PERSONAL LIVES</c>
AS WELL AS FAMILY LIVES AS WELL
AS- AS WELL AS COMMUNITY HE'S
REALLY IN TAX. THAT THE BILL
MENTAL TRAGIC THIRTIES OVER
THOSE WHO SUFFERED FROM MENTAL
ILLNESS. SCHOOL DEVELOPING A
MENTAL DISORDER AT THE VERY END
OF THE AGE MAY HAVE SIGNIFICANT
EFFECTS ON EDUCATIONAL
ATTAINMENT. WORKFORCE
PARTICIPATION INTERPERSONAL
RELATIONS SUCH AS MARRIAGE AND
THE MORE THEY BORDERS AND EVEN
SOUP SEQUIN DISABLING FIVE
PHYSICAL CONDITIONS SOMETHING
THAT I YOU ALSO WANT TO
EMPHASIZE TO YOU SIR AND YOU
MENTION YOU SENATE SORT MORNING
MENTION ABOUT THE ADVERSE
CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCES. WELL
BASED STRONG THIS PREDICTOR OF
AIR LEóN SAID MENTAL ILLNESS
IN ALSO A ON SIT BOTH A
PHYSICAL CHRONIC CONDITIONS
THESE ARE A BURST CHILDHOOD
EXPERIENCES SO IF A KID
EXPERIENCES EARLY AND DIVE ANY
KIND OF FIVE USE. EMOTIONAL
PHYSICAL SEXUAL. A THREE
NEGLECT DOMESTIC BY. BAY A XP A
MAN HEALING IN THE FAMILY YOU
KNOW WONDER ONE PARENT THAT
COMMITTED SUICIDE OR SEVERE
MENTAL DISORDERS HAVE BUILT A
MENTAL ILLNESSES TO
SCHIZOPHRENIA DOES COUNT I SAID
A IS THAT BETTER SEE A BURST
CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCES. ONE
THING THAT I WANT TO EMPHASIZE
ONCE AGAIN IS THAT THE FULL THE
STATE OF THAT I CHAIR WITH YOU
WIND UP WE OUGHT TO BE LOOKING
AT THESE WHAT WE CALL THE
TREATMENT GAP. NO IN BODIES THE
FACT THAT BETWEEN 95290% OF
PEOPLE WITH SERIOUS MENTAL
DISORDERS. HAVE NOT RECEIVE UP
BROKE. MENTAL HEALTH CARE IN
THE PREVIOUS YEAR. SAM BETTER
TREMENDOUS TREMENDOUS
DISPARITIES HERE ON HOW THIS
HAPPENS FOR EXAMPLE A EVEN GOAL
I GROWING PERCENTAGE OF
CONVALESCENCE REPORTED
EXPERIENCING DEPRESSION
INCREASING YEARS AS YOU CAN SEE
IN THE ONE OF THE SLIDES. THAT
THAT'S WHERE THE SEIZE REPORTED
HAVING A MAJOR DEPRESSIVE
EPISODE IN THE PAST YEAR. A. N.
BADDIES SO THE BAD NEWS FOR
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE SINCE TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN THE TRAIN HIGHS
BE COMPARED TO THE NATION THE
TREND HAS BEEN THAT OF A MAJOR
DEPRESSIVE EPISODES EPISODES
ARE OP WORK. K. ANY SPITE OF
THAT- LISTENING ONE REPORTED
PRESS TREATMENT WHICH IS IN THE
NAY LIFE. A LET ME CHAIR WOULD
YOU A BIGGER PICTURE AND THIS
IS MADE UP AT CAMP FROM SAM'S
SO. A BAD PC'S PASSED YOUR
DEPRESSION TREATMENT AMONG
ADOLESCENTS AGE TWELVE TO
SEVENTEEN. IN YOU IF YOU LOOK
AT TE SLIDE- OVER 70% DEEP NOT
RECEIVE TREATMENT. EIGHTEEN IN
THE IN WOMEN A ABOUT 60% IN IN
THE WHITE POPULATION IT NEARLY
60% BUT THE IN BLACKS AND
LATINOS THOSE PERCENTAGES OF
THE TREATING THAT ARE EVEN
HIGHER. YOU KNOW A IN THIS IS
THIS BY THE CONSEQUENCES IN THE
B. C.'S BURTON BED THIS
TREATMENT GAPS- CONTINUE TO
HAPPEN. ONE OF THE CONDITIONS
THAT AREJUST THESE MATING IS
THAT THOSE WHO SUFFER FROM
SUBSTANCE ABUSE DISORDERS ABOUT
92% THE RECEIVE TREATMENT. IS
THE UMBILICAL. GAME AIN'T BUT
THEY'RE OLDER. OLDER MENTAL
ILLNESSES A BAD- I'M NOT
RECEIVING TREATMENT WINDOW
TREATMENT EAST NEED. WHY IS
THIS TREATMENT GAP WELL THERE
ARE SEVERAL REASONS FOR THAT
THEY BETTER FROM A BEING THE
BEETLE LABEL FOR EXAMPLE SPEAK
MY ALREADY WISEMAN CHIN AND
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT IS OF
CRITICAL IMPORTANCE TO. TALK
ABOUT BECAUSE CHANGE OF CAR
BEING A MENTAL ILLNESS YOU KNOW
A- A HE IS A MAJOR BARRIER FOR
PEOPLE TO SEEK SERVICES THAT IS
ONE OF THE MOST IMPORTANT
ASPECTS OF A STATEMENT IN THE
SURGEON GENERAL AT THE NATIONAL
AGO A RECOGNIZE THAT IMPORTED
IN REPORTS A COUPLE OF REPORTS
THAT BABY BABY RELEASED AT THE
COMMUNITY LEVEL- A IN A YOU
SENT UP FOR- AND MENTION A
ABOUT THE LACK OF CULTURAL
LINGUISTICALLY. APPROPRIATE
SERVICES. THESE CAN BE AN EXAM
WHAT BAY A BECOME LEVEL AT THE
SYSTEMIC LEVEL THEY LACK OF SO
IN THE RESOURCE. IMPORT LIVING
CONDITIONS IN THERE WE SOBRE
OVERALL A LACK OF ENGAGEMENT IN
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CARE YOU KNOW
PEOPLE HAVE ALL SORTS OF IDEAS
AS TO WHY THEY ARE NOT A YOU
KNOW ACCESSING ACCESSING CARE.
A I WILL. I WILL GO THROUGH
SOME OF THE SLIGHTS BERRY
WEEKLY BECAUSE OF TIME- BUT- IN
TERMS OF THE SOLUTIONS THAT I
WAS TALKING ABOUT. THERE ARE
SEVERAL SOLUTIONS THAT I WILL
DISCUSS WITH YOU BRIEFLY ONE OF
THEM IS SOMETHING THAT. OUR
CENTER FOR RELEASING KELLY
SPIRIT THESE HE'S DOING IN
SOLANO COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH. IN WITH- MADE SEVERAL
COMMUNITY PARTNERS. IN AND YOU
KNOW SOLANO COUNTY- HE SAID A
RULE- IS HAVE YOU BEEN TO
RURAL- COMMUNITY. IN NBC SO THE
EIGHTY EIGHT THE PROJECT FUNDED
BY THE OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION UNDER
DATE INNOVATIONS PROJECT- THIS
IS A MULTI YEAR PROJECT- I
INCLUDED IN THAT A IN THIS
LIGHT BACK SOME DETAILS THAT I
WON WILL THROUGH- YOU CAN GO.
THROUGH THEM- YOURSELF BUT THE
BIG GOALS OF THIS PROJECT WHERE
TO IMPROVE ACCESS TO AND
UTILIZATION OF MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES FOR THREE HISTORICALLY
UNDER SERVED POPULATIONS IN
SOLANO COUNTY. AND THOSE ARE
LET THINGS PHILIPPINES AND LGBT
Q. CAN ALSO TO INCREASE
WORKFORCE THEY BURIED BY THEIR
CITY. AND TO HELP THE COMPANY
THE BILL OF POLICIES PROGRAMS
AND SUPPORT SYSTEMS TO ENSURE
THAT THE SERVICES THAT THEY
PROVIDE ARE APPEALING TO THOSE.
POPULATIONS. PHONE I AM VERY
SAY A SLIGHT ON WHY HE SAID
THAT WE HAVE ON IOWA GO THROUGH
WITH BUT WHAT I WILL TO IN THE
THAT BIG WHEN THEY TO OUR TO
SEE IF WE COULD CALL DAY
PROVIDE DISPARITY SEEN LIKE
BEING LISTEN BEING A SET THAT
TIME THAT WORKS HISTORICALLY
THIS. I'M VERY HAPPY TO READ.
THE BASED ON. REPORT THAT CAN
OUT OF THE CAR HEALTHCARE
FOUNDATION A FEW- YOU KNOW ONLY
ON DECEMBER TWENTIETH
SPECIFICALLY. THAT THE FROM
200-015-2000 EIGHTEEN THE
NUMBER OF CLIENTS WHO RECEIVE
MEANT TO HELP ACCESSING SOLANO
COUNTY INCREASE. 49% FOR
LATINOS IN 12% FOR PHILIPPINES
SO SOMETHING WE A WHOLE WE ARE.
AT LEAST PRELIMINARILY I'M
HAPPY TO TELL YOU THAT WE ARE
MOVING THE NEEDLE. BUT IT TAKES
A LAURA FORCE AND COMMUNITY
MOBILIZATION IN ORDER TO DO
THAT. ALL THEIR SOLUTIONS THAT
I WON TO INFO. OUR IS THE
MEMORY EFFORTS AND THAT
INCLUDES FOR A ALL THE AUDIO
VISUAL TOOLS AND SOCIAL
MARKETING CAMPAIGNS. TO COMBAT
A STIGMA OF MENTAL ILLNESS BUT
SOME OF THESE HAS BEEN. DONE
THROUGH THE MHA STATEMENT TO
SAY RESOURCES BY THE WAY ALSO
EVIDENCE BASED TREATMENT
APPROACHES. AND COMMUNITY THE
FIND EVIDENCE AND THIS BRINGS
ME TO A MAJOR INITIATIVE THAT
HE'S- FOCUSING ON THEIR BY
VERSE COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE
STATE WHICH IS THE CALIFORNIA
REDUCING DISPARITY PROJECT. A
SIXTY MILLION- INVESTMENT THAT
IS UNDER WAY IN WHICH THAT ARE
THIRTY FIVE COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE BEING
FUNDED TO PASS.A PROMISING
PRACTICES TO SEE IF WE CAN MOVE
THE NEEDLE COLLECTIVELY IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES SPECIFICALLY
IN THE START WITH VERY DIVERSE
COMMUNITIES. AND FINALLY A
PERSON CENTER CULTURAL
LINGUISTICALLY COMPETENT
RICKOVER ORIENT THAT TRAUMA
INFORMED. CARE WHICH IS VERY
VERY CRITICAL TO THE- LAST.
THING THAT I WANT TO MENTION
TALKING ABOUT THE TRAINS HE'S
THE SUICIDE RATES. THAT ARE YOU
KNOW. A CHEST ALARMED ME. THERE
HAS BEEN THE CITY'S EVERY THAT
SWEET SO RATES IN ALMOST EVERY
pSTATE I'D BE FOR LEVEL BUT FIVE
FORTY NINE OF THE STATE'S HIGH
SPEED A SCENE- INCREASES CAN I
INCLUDED A SLIGHT OF BETA THE
BETA BUT LESS PROVIDED BY
SCIENCE HE'S THE MOST RECENT
DATA BUT IF YOU TAKE IT THE
PERCENT CHANGE IN SUICIDE RATES
BY DEMOGRAPHICS IN GEOGRAPHY
WHAT YOU GET. IS THAT THE A BIT
TREND IS THAT THE ETHNIC GROUP
THAT IS KIND OF IN THE HIGHEST
RATES FROM TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
THE TWO THOUSAND AND SEVENTEEN
ARE LATINOS I WAS SURPRISED TO
SEE THAT ACTUALLY I TOLD THAT
THERE WERE GONNA BE OLDER OLDER
GROUPS BUT THE EYES OPEN HERE
BUT I WANT TO EMPHASIZE HERE IS
THAT OF FULL THE AGE GROUPS
THAT ARE INCLUDED HERE. BIG
GROUP WITH THE HIGHEST
PERCENTAGE OF SCIENCE THROUGH
FIVE SUICIDE RATES ARE A EIGHTY
EIGHT CHILDREN AND ADOLESCENTS
ZERO TWO SEVENTEEN YEARS OF AGE
EIGHTY SUCH TRAGEDY WE NEED TO
DO SOMETHING COLLECTIVELY TO
CIRCUMVENT THAT PROGRAM IN SAME
THING HAPPENS IN TERMS OF
SERIOUS THOUGHTS AT THOSE WHO
MADE A PLAN IN THOSE WHO
ATTEMPTED STREETS THREE SITES.
IN IN YOUNG PEOPLE. IN THIS IS
CAP ABSOLUTELY HERE IN CAN YOU.
AS WELL CHEST TO GIVE YOU A SAY.
A MORE THAN FORTY EIGHT
HUNDRED. DIED SWISS IN TWO AND
SEVEN. I FEEL 2% INCREASE FOR
TO PASS. AND EIGHTEEN IN ONE
AND THE PROBLEM I WEST
PARTICULARLY PRONOUNCED FOR THE
YOUNG SOUL SUICIDES AMONG
ADOLESCENTS AGE 15219% IN
CALIFORNIA INCREASED BY SIXTY
THREE PERCENT. SO WITH THAT A I
WOULD LIKE TO EMPHASIZE WHEN WE
THINK ABOUT THE TOTALITY OF
WHAT ARE THE SOLUTIONS. TO AND
REALLY A LOOKING TO THEIR
DIRECT YOU SEEN THE THREATENING
GOT PORTING PROVING THAT THREE
AND GOT. AND THE BEST WAY TO
ACCORDING TO- YOU KNOW I
SENATOR ACTUALLY MET AT A YEAR
SEVERAL BY WILLIAM. BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND AND FIVE BEING KEPT
AFFAIRS HE WAS SAYING THE BEST
WAY TO ELIMINATE HEALTH
DISPARITIES EAST THROUGH
IMPROVEMENTS IN CARE WE'VE BEEN
DEEPER. TO EACH PATIENT. WHICH
WITH COFFEE BATES I HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM THAT ENCOURAGES
PROVIDERS AND PATIENTS TO WORK
TOGETHER TO IMPROVE CARE
BECAUSE WHAT WE USUALLY DO BY
MY PHYSICIAN YOU KNOW I'M A
PROVIDER I HAVE BEEN A PROVIDER
HE SAID. BUT WE DON'T. GREAT
THE PATIENCE INTO THEIR OWN
TREATMENT IN THE SOME THAT WE
OUGHT TO BE DOING MUCH MORE
OFTEN SOMEONE STOP. YOUR
CHRISTINE. FOR MENTAL HEALTH.
WILL OPEN UP FOR QUICK BECAUSE-
THANK YOU SOME. TO CHEER THANK
YOU ALSO SENATORS FOR BEING
HERE TODAY WE'VE BEEN WORK OVER
THE LAST YEAR OR SO WITH
PERMANENTE. ON SERIES THAT WE
TOOK AROUND NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
CALLED THE YOUTH LISTENING
SESSIONS I JUST WANT TO GIVE
YOU A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF THAT
TODAY AND IT'S REALLY AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR SYSTEM
IMPACTING YOUTH SPECIFICALLY
THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM AND- YOU
FROM THE JUVENILE JUSTICE
SYSTEM- TO COME TOGETHER IN A
PRIVATE PROCURED MANNER-
LIMITED SPACE IN EACH OF THE
SESSIONS- THROUGH. SACRAMENTO
OAKLAND AND FRESNO WE HAD A
SEPARATE ON ADVERTISE SESSION
IN OAKLAND I WILL TALK ABOUT
JUST A MOMENT- IT'S REALLY A
FORM FOR THEM TO TELL THEIR
SIDE REALLY WHAT IS GOING ON
WITH THEIR EXPERIENCES IN THE
SYSTEM. IN  OF SWEEPING EFFORT
TO- MITIGATE TRAUMA TO DEAL
WITH TRAUMA ASUS AND THE THINGS
THAT THE YOUNG PEOPLE ARE
DEALING WITH ON A DAILY BASIS-
IS REALLY- HAD IN A LON IMPACT
ON THE ADULTS IN THE ROOM. I
CAN TELL YOU THAT WE ARE
WORKING ON A FINAL REPORT WHICH
WILL SHARE WITH YOU SHORTLY-
BUT WE- TOOK A DIFFERENT
APPROACH TO PUTTING THE
SESSIONS TOGETHER IT'S IT
WASN'T IT LOCAL LISTENING
SESSION IT WAS REALLY- TAILORED
TO THE CULTURAL LANGUAGE OF THE
YOUTH. AND WE- ARE TO USE WE
HAD I A GOING ON WE TALKED
ABOUT INNOVATION. ABOUT THE
TOOLS THAT CURRENTLY YOU IS
THAT THE CLIPS TO INTEGRATES
EDGY FOR HEATING TRAUMA. AND WE
HAD A PANEL OF EXPERTS SAID
EACH EVEN FOR YOU ADVOCATES
WHO- HAD CYST INVOLVED. SOME
RETAIL STORY THE- OUR ABOUT
THEIR- THAT WAS LED BY A CALL
WHO WAS WITH THE ON THE IN TWO
WAR AND THEN THERE WERE OTHER
COME THAT AS SPOKEN MORE THAT
JUST CHANGED THE WHOLE
ATMOSPHERE OF THE ROOM- THE
PERSON THAT WAS ON OUR TOUR
WITH US HAD- TRAUMA IN HIS
BACKGROUND ALSO HE HAD A
BACKGROUND WHERE HE'D BEEN SHOT
HE HAD A BAD EXPERIENCE
VIOLENCE IN HIS COMMUNITY IN
FACT THE OF VALLEY HIGH
COMMUNITY RIGHT HERE IN
SACRAMENTO- BUT THE ABILITY TO.
RESONATE WITH THE YOUTH AND GET
THEM TO OPEN UP WAS- REALLY
IMMENSE SO- WE ALL TOOK THAT TO
ANOTHER LEVEL LATER ON IN THE
SESSIONS WITH THE OPPORTUNITY
TO BRING IN ARTIST- TO EACH ONE
SO E DID EMOTIONAL EXPRESSION
THROUGH ART- THERE ARE FIVE
DIFFERENT ARTISTS THAT EACH OF
THE SESSIONS AND WE ALSO HAD
OPEN ENDED QUESTIONS HAD SOME
OPEN DIALOGUE ABOUT TRAUMA AND
ASUS AND THEN WE USED A SURVEY
WE DID DEMOGRAPHIC SURVEYS WE-
SERVICE ABOUT A SPECIFIC
TRAUMATIC EXPERIENCES THAT WERE
REALLY REVEALING- WE ALSO
TALKED ABOUT SAFETY IN THE
SYSTEM AND ASK THEM. DIRECTLY
DO YOU FEEL SAFE IN THE SYSTEM
AND IF YOU GRADUATED FROM A
SYSTEM DO YOU FEEL SAFE NOW
WHERE YOU ARE- SOME DID AND
SOME QUICK LEAD DID NOT SO- THE
YOUTH LISTENING SESSIONS- WAS A
PATHWAY TO GREATER
CONVERSATIONS WITHIN THE
EXORCIST. IT'S A THEY'RE NOT
UNITY TO RE COMMUNITY DOLLARS I
AM ALWAYS BEEN THE CAN BE BET
DAHLE. AND LOOK AT IN IN WAY TO
GET THE MORE RELEVANT SERVICE
TO THE U. AFTER THE CHANCE THAT
THEY ALL IN WHICH MEANS FLIGHT
PATH. A V. R. IN E. GAIN
BECAUSE THEY'RE IN SPACE ALL
BUT WE ALSO NEED TO LOOK AT TO
THEIR A- THROUGH SCHOOL PARTNER.
WHICH KAISER HOW KERN AND WE
DON'T REALLY KNOW WHAT THE NEXT
STEP WOULD BE THIS IS ONE THE
REASON WE WANTED TO LISTEN BUT
THE NATIONAL OFFICE AND THE
REGIONAL OFFICES AND ALSO THE
LOCAL COMMUNITY BIT OFFICES OF
KAISER. ALL HAVE A TREMENDOUS-
FOCUS ON ACES IN TRAUMA AND THE
DOLLARS TO BACK IT UP SO THERE
ARE GOING TO BE SOME NEW
PROGRAMS- NEW ARE PEAS NEW.
PARTNERSHIP OPPORTUNITIES AND
REIMAGINING SOME. OF THE
EXISTING PROGRAMS THAT ARE ON
THE GROUND. THE SESSION THAT WE
HELD WAS WOULD ONLY WITH
VIOLENCE IMPACTED YOU IN
OAKLAND- THESE WERE RIVAL.
RIVALS IN THE ROOM AND THEY
WERE THIRTY OF THEM THERE WERE
TWENTY EIGHT MALES AND TWO
FEMALES- ALL VIOLENCE IMPACTED
YOUTH. THAT SESSION WASN'T
ADVERTISE WE HAD A PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE CITY OF OAKLAND OFFICE
OF VIOLENCE PREVENTION TO DO
THIS WORK. AND WHEN YOU WALKED
INTO THE ROOM YOU COULDN'T TELL
THAT THERE WAS ANY RIVALRY OR
ANY OF THAT GOING ON- THEY WERE
ATTENTIVE OF QUIET- ENGAGED-
AND WHEN YOU BRING IN A
CULTURAL BROKER LIKE THE- THE
SPOKEN WORD ARTIST WHO HAD A
SIMILAR BACKGROUND BUT IT
CHANGED HIS LIFE AROUND THERE
WAS. A LOT OF CAMARADERIE IN
THE ROOM AND THAT BY THE TIME
WE FINISHED- WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT EMOTIONS WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT- CULTURAL ISSUES THE
PRESSURE THAT MALES HAVE ON
THEM TO YOU KNOW NOT SHOW
EMOTION- WE WERE ALKING ABOUT
CRYING. AND THE DIRECTOR CAME
IN WITH TEARS IN HIS EYES AND
IT WAS REALLY A DIFFERENT
SETTING THAN THE OTHER YOUTH
LISTENING SESSIONS- BUT IT WAS
SIMILAR TO SOME OF THE TRAINING
THAT WE DID PREVIOUSLY- WITH
MALES OF COLOR- WHEN WE TAUGHT
MENTAL HEALTH FOR STATE IN A
CULTURALLY RELEVANT MANNER.
THEY WERE THE MOST OPEN AND
TALKATIVE GROUP OF ALL OF THE
GROUPS SO- THERE IS A WAY TO
REACH PEOPLE IN THE COMMUNITY
BUT THE PATHWAY I NEED TO BE
NONTRADITIONAL NEEDS TO HAVE
PEOPLE FROM THE COMMUNITY.
INVOLVED THESE ARE THEIR
MENTORS THAT. THERE IS THERE
LEADERS AND SO THE BLEND OF
THESE PERSPECTIVES IS REALLY
USEFUL IN TERMS OF YOU CAN
GAUGE MEANT. AND ENTER A SO A
LITTLE ALSO ON THE BROTHER BE
WELL PROGRAM IT IT SPEAKS TO
THE NEED TO CONTINUE THESE
CONVERSATIONS IS A NEW CONCEPT-
THAT WE ARE- IN TALKS WITH OUR
COUNTY ABOUT FUNDING. AS A
PREVENTION AND EARLY
INTERVENTION PROGRAM-
SPECIFICALLY FOR MALES OF COLOR
BUT IT WOULD ALSO. BE OPEN TO
SCHOOLS IT'S A REALLY A PROJECT
FOR HIGH SCHOOLS AND FOR
COLLEGES- THIS YEAR HEALTH
FOUNDATION IS ONE OF OUR
PARTNERS- WE ALSO HAVE- THE
ALLIANCE FOR BOYS AND MEN OF
COLOR. SO THAT THIS PROJECT CAN
BE SCALED INSTANTLY BRINGING
TWO HUNDRED COMMUNITY PARTNERS
TO THIS PROGRAM- WE ALSO HAD
THE STATEWIDE JOB CORPS SYSTEM-
SAMUEL MERIT UNIVERSITY THAT
BRINGS THE NURSING EXPERTISE TO
OUR PROGRAM- AND THEN WELL AS
TOGETHER FOR THERAPEUTIC
INTERVENTIONS. AND THAT PRO. IS
REALLY IT'S A SAFE SPACE IS
WHAT YOU CALL SAFE COMMUNITY
IT'S A SAFE SPACE WHERE THEY
ALL THESE. MALES ARE SO OPEN
AND YOU DO HAVE TO HIM THOUGH
GET HIM TO PIPE DOWN AFTER A
WHILE BECAUSE- THEY DON'T HAVE
MANY OPPORTUNITIES FOR
EXPRESSION. AND IN SOME OF OUR
HOW ARE OUR HOMES THERE JUST
ISN'T CONVERSATION ABOUT MENTAL
HEALTH. THIS IS THE KIND OF
PROGRAM THAT MY FAMILY ME BEING
A FAMILY MEMBER WITH LIVED
EXPERIENCE COULD HAVE USED A
FEW DECADES AGO- AND SO- IT
DOES GIVE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
TEACHING TRAINING.
INTERVENTIONS OPENING THESE
CONVERSATIONS AND IN OUR
RESEARCH SOME OF THEM- A VERY
CREATIVE MUSIC AND HUMOR ARE
TWO OF THE BIGGEST ASKS IS FOR
SOME OF THESE PROGRAMS- IS SO
WE ARE INTEGRATING SOME OF
THOSE THINGS INTO A DIGITAL
PLATFORM. THAT HAS THEM ON THE
GROUND OPPORTUNITIES FOR-
GETTING TOGETHER TO BE TRAINED
TO HEARFROM EXPERTS- AND TO DO
IDEATION IDEATION AND HACKING.
ARE TWO OF THE THINGS THEIR ON
GOING BECAUSE THEY NEED TO BE
INVOLVED WITH THEM ON THIS
PROGRAM. REALLY DRIVING A LOT
OF IT TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE
OPPORTUNITY BUT ALSO. TO TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY. FOR OUR HEALTH
IT IS THAT. MATTER MENTAL
HEALTH MATTER WE EXPECT FOR OUR
PARTICIPANTS TO- GET INVOLVED
AND TO REALLY TO. THAT NEXT
STEP IN TO CAN. THESE
INTERVENTIONS IS JUST A PART OF
THEIR HEALTH. SO AS WE THE WORK
WILL KEEP YOU UP. ON THE
OUTCOMES OUR CHI. USED SESSIONS
THERE MAY BE SOME MORE OTHER
COMMUNITIES HAVE ALREADY ASKED
FOR THESE. HI THERE IS YOU KNOW
IS- KIND OF SPLIT DOWN THE
MIDDLE THEY HAVE A SEVEN
CALIFORNIA SYSTEM THEY'RE
CONSIDERING DOING SOME THINGS
OUT THERE- AND THAT WILL KEEP
YOU INFORMED ALSO THE
DEVELOPMENT OF OUR BROTHER BE
WELL PROGRAM. THANK YOU. OKAY
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS OF A
CENTER RUBIO. THANK YOU AND I
HAVE A QUESTION FOR. WITH HIM
IN SEARCH OF BY ME- THINK CAN
YOU REFRESH MY MEMORY JUST
DISCUSS HOW CALIFORNIA IS
GROWING AT A LARGER RATE IN
TERMS OF FIVE MENTAL HEALTH
DISORDERS IN THE UNITED STATES
HAS THAT BEEN TRADITIONALLY
BECAUSE I'VE LOOKED AT THE
CHARGE AND STARTED IT SEEMS
LIKE IT'S BEEN GROWING SINCE I
THINK YOU HAD TWENTY LIVE IN AN
UP. AND I WENT UP FROM. NINE
POINT TWO IN TWENTY ELEVEN TO
TWELVE POINT THREE AND TWENTY
FOURTEEN I HAVE I DON'T HAVE
THE PREVIOUS YEARS BUT- HOUSE
THAT. TREND CONTINUED TO GROW
WERE WE EVER AT A LOWER HIGHER
RATE PRIOR TO THE- EAST WEST
INDIES HE SAID SPECIFICALLY
ABOUT MAJOR DEPRESSION.
EPISODES OF IS NOT ALL OF THE
MENTAL DISORDERS. A YOU KNOW A.
B. FOUR TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN THE
LAST ON AVERAGE BECAUSE THERE
ARE DIFFERENCES ALSO BY THREE
JUNE A DIFFERENCES BY AGE AGE
GROUPS- A PORN AVERAGE A. B. IT
HAS REMAINED A KIND OF LEVEL.
BUT SOMETHING HAS BEEN
HAPPENING- IN IS NOT THE ONLY
CALIFORNIA BASIS NATION WIDE-
IN THE LAST THE AT LEAST TEN
YEARS BY P. ET SO IT IS
AFFECTING AT THE POPULATIONS
BAT EIGHTIES WAR SING
CALIFORNIA COMPARED TO THE
NATIONAL- LABEL. IF I MAY I
JUST ME WHEN YOU SET THAT
BECAUSE I MEAN I KNOW THAT
THERE'S SO MANY REASONS WHY YOU
KNOW OUR POPULATION IS TO PRESS
THE VANS PERSONAL HISTORY. BUT
YOU KNOW WHEN I GO BACK TO- MY
EXPERIENCE AS AN EDUCATOR I
MEAN I REMEMBER PRIOR TO THAT
THE DEPRESSION ARE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. WHICH IS TWENTY
EIGHT EIGHT OR NINE WHERE YOU
KNOW A LOT OF PEOPLE LOST THEIR
HOMES IN. AND SO THERE WERE SO
MANY CUTS IN THE EDUCATIONAL
SYSTEM AND I REMEMBER WE USED
TO HAVE FULL TIME COUNSELORS.
AND I CAN TELL YOU HOW VALUABLE
THOSE COUNSELORS WORK TO ME IN
TERMS OF HAVING STUDENTS WITH
ISSUES THEY WOULD GO TO THE
COUNSELOR THAT COUNTS FOR NOT
ONLY WOULD WORK WITH THE
STUDENTS BUT- THEY WOULD
CONNECT WITH THE PARENTS AND
THEN HELP THEM NAVIGATE THE
COMPLICATED SYSTEM OF THE
INSURANCE AND HOW DO YOU GET.
OUTSIDE HELP AND SELL THAT
EARLY TREATMENT. WAS ESSENTIAL
AND I JUST WONDER THERE'S A
CORRELATION BETWEEN. ALL THE
SERVICES WE'VE LOST IN THE
SCHOOLS AS IT PERTAINS TO
MENTAL HEALTH LIKE OUR
COUNSELORS AND- AND YOU KNOW WE
USED TO HAVE THERAPISTS. LOSING
THEM AND NOW NOT HAVING
ANYTHING IN SCHOOL TO KINDA
HELP THE EARLY STAGES AND- I'M
JUST WONDERING IF. YOU HAVE ANY
THOUGHTS ON THAT BECAUSE IT
LIKE AGAIN WE HAD SOMEONE THAT
WE CAN SEND. OUR STUDENTS TO
THAT WOULD HAVE A ONE ON ONE
AND I THINK MRS SMITH YOU
MENTIONED SOMETHING ABOUT.
HAVING A RELATIONSHIP MENTORS
YOU KNOW STUDENTS ARE OR AT
LEAST OUR YOUTH ARE. MORE
INCLINED TO SPEAK UP AND THEY
HAVE A RELATIONSHIP LOW OF IT
SOMEONE THAT THEY BUILD A
RELATIONSHIP WITH. AND SO I'M
JUST WONDER IF YOU HAVE ANY
THOUGHTS ON THAT. YES IT'S A
GREAT POINT BY A NINETY AYE
EVA. I THINK THAT THERE IS A
RELATIONSHIP. A UNFORTUNATELY I
THINK A- THAT BY WE HAVE INDOOR.
AS AS GOOD A JOB AS WE COULD.
IN PARTNERING WITH SCHOOLS. FOR
EXAMPLE SO TEACHERS. ARE
BEARING FORM. ON HOW TO
IDENTIFY. SYMPTOMS US. ORDER OR
SIGNS. A SURLY S. PORTABLE.
AIN'T BEEN UNFORTUNATELY. IS
STILL. YOU KNOW THE BETTER
TEACHERS THAT TALK ABOUT THE-
DIESEL BEATING KIDS. OR OR KEY
STEP BUT YOU KNOW JUST THEM PAY
ATTENTION. WITHOUT THINKING
THAT. SOMETHING MIGHT BE GOING
ON. IN THEIR LIVES. EIGHTEEN
AND I THINK. THAT WE HAVE SEEN
ALSO CLASSES THAT TEND TO BE
BIGGER. THAN BEFORE SO THEY
MORE- A PERSONALIZED SO
ATTENTION. HE NOT BEAR.
SOMETHING GOOD BUDDIES-
HAPPENING RIGHT NOW AND USE- IS
IN THE THIRD BILL HAD BEEN A
CHAMPION OF THAT THESE-
WELLNESS CENTERS. YOU KNOW IT
IS A HOW TO COME UP. WITH THE-
A. INTERVENTIONS. PREVENTIVE
INTERVENTIONS IN SCHOOL
SETTINGS. THAT WOULD ALLOW THE
KIDS ALONG WITH A BIT THE
PARENTS AND ALONG WITH THAT A-
ADMINISTRATORS AND THE
TEACHERS- I IDENTIFY- DAY SIGNS
WHEN THEY ARE THERE OR- AIM FOR
A- DREAM FORCE. A WELLBEING
RELATED ACTIVITIES. AND THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THAT POINT AND
I THINK IT UNDERSCORES- THE
NEED FOR TEACHERS TED TO BE
EDUCATED IN THIS. IN THIS ARENA
IT'S INTERESTING BECAUSE AS A
TEACHER YOU'RE NOT TAUGHT TO BE
A MENTAL HEALTH SPECIALISTS AND
YOU'RE THERE TO TEACH AND-
BECAUSE OF THE LACK OF FUNDING
NOW. THERE IS NO RESOURCES SO
TEACHERS HAVE TO BE BAIT THAT
THEIR BEST SO TO SPEAK- AND I
THINK IT ALSO UNDERSCORES THE
NEED. FOR ARTS CENTERS COOL NO
ARTS TO. OVER THE YEARS A AND I
HEARD YOU SAY EARLIER I. MRS
SMITH DOT. KIDS X. THEM AND ARE
ABLE TO RESUME OF THE IN THE
KNOW THAT THINGS IDEA THEY'RE
FEELING THROUGH THE- AND I
THINK THAT'S ALSO THAT WE NEED
TO CONSIDER HOW IMPORTANT THE
ARTS ARE. HALF PLEASE IN
SCHOOLS ALL THAT IS COMMENTED
ON THE MANDATES AND TERMS OF
YOU KNOW MATH AND SCIENCE AND
IT JUST YOU KNOW THE CORE
CURRICULUM IS. YOU KNOW IT'S
IMPORTANT BUT I THINK WE'RE
FORGETTING HOW IMPORTANT IT IS
TO GET THOSE KIDS THAT NEED TO
EXPRESS THEMSELVES ANOTHER
AVENUE TO RELEASE OUR ANXIETY
AND BE ABLE TO EXPRESS WHAT
THEY'RE FEELING BUT I THINK I
JUST WANTED TO SEE BECAUSE WHEN
I LOOK AT THE THAT THE GRAPH
HAS IT. YOU KNOW STARTED UP
INCREASING I LIKE FROM TWENTY
ELEVEN TO TEN NOW AND IT'S JUST
IT'S GROWN DRAMATICALLY AND NOW
WE'RE ALL DOING- THE UNITED
STATES AND- AGAIN I KNOW FROM
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE FOR ME IS
SEEING. THE LOSS OF OUR
COUNSELORS IN OUR SCHOOLS- THE
LOSS OF OUR ART SYSTEM IN OUR
SCHOOLS AND SO ALL THIS HATING
PLAYS INTO WHAT WE'RE SEEING
NOW LATER IN LIFE BUT BUT THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CALL TO BE I THINK.
YOU'RE DOING A CREDIBLE WORK
AND I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
YOUTH LISTENING SESSIONS I
THINK IT' IMPORTANT TO HAVE IT
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT ART IS IN
MAKING IT OKAY TO SPEAK UP
ABOUT WHAT THEY'RE FEELING I
THINK IT'S SO IMPORTANT TO LET
OUR KIDS KNOW THAT. THAT IT'S
OKAY TO SPEAK UP AND GET HELP
AND SO WHAT YOU'RE DOING IS
INCREDIBLE. THANK YOU BOTH. YOU
ENTER MONNING. ONE THING YOU
BOTH FOR YOUR SOME A QUESTION
FOR MISS SMITH ON THE LISTENING
SESSIONS- THIS PROFILE THE
THREE THAT WERE HELD SACRAMENTO
OAKLAND FRESNO. SEEMS LIKE A
GREAT MODEL ARE THERE PLANS TO
TRY TO REPLICATE THIS WATER THE
LIMITATIONS WAS THE FUNDING
THROUGH KAISER PERMANENTE IN
ARE THERE ANY PLANS TO TRY TO
REPLICATE THESE SIR GIVE
STUDENTS WHO PARTICIPATED IN
ONE A CHANCE FOR FOLLOW UP.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR QUESTION
SENATOR- YES THESE ARE FUNDED
THROUGH KAISER PERMANENTE A THE
COMMUNITY BENEFITS DIVISION THE
REGIONAL DIVISION OUT OF
OAKLAND- AND AT THIS TIME-
THERE AREN'T PLANS TO FURTHER
AND THE YOUTH LISTENING
SESSIONS IN OUR- REGION BUT IT
DOESN'T MEAN THAT WE WON'T DO
SOMETHING IN THE FUTURE- WE
ALSO HAVE THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA COMMITTEE BENEFITS
DIVISION INTERESTED- SO.
HOPEFULLY WE CAN PUSH FORWARD
ON ON THAT- I THOUGHT THAT THE
YOUTH ADVOCATES WHO APPEARED ON
OUR PANEL WOULD BE FANTASTIC
SPOKESPEOPLE FOR A CONTINUED
SERIES- THEY'RE VERY- WELL
VERSED IN AND LOOKING FORWARD
TO OPPORTUNITIES TO ADVOCATE
FOR THEIR FOR THEMSELVES AND
OTHER YOUTH- BUT IT ALSO COULD
BE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR A
REIMAGINING SOME EL CAP
DOLLARS. THERE IS A FOCUS ON A
YOUTH OF COLOR OR I'M SORRY-
YOU TO OUR- UNDERSERVED- A
FOSTER YOUTH AND- THERE'S
ANOTHER. GROUP I DON'T REMEMBER
BUT- THAT'S ANOTHER WAY TO GET
THESE THINGS MOVING DIRECTLY AT
THE SCHOOLS- SO SOMETHING THAT
WE COULD PERHAPS PITCH RIGHT
WILL YOU READ MY MIND ON THAT
TRYING TO ORGANIZE A FREE
STANDING ON GOING. OPPORTUNITY
VERSUS PARTNERING SCHOOLS ALSO
WITH LIMITED RESOURCES BUT AS
YOU MENTION OF IT COULD BE
PRIORITIZED AS PART OF AN EL
CAP. PLAN MAYBE PICK A FEW
SCHOOL DISTRICTS WHO COMMIT TO
SOME EXPERIMENTATION LATE TEN
AT A HIGH SCHOOL IN LONG BEACH
A FEW YEARS AGO. WHERE STUDENTS.
ARE LET IN HERE CONVERSATION AS
AS AS A- CHRIS. CLASS
CURRICULUM FIRST THING IN THE
MORNING ONCE A WEEK IN THE
START IN SHELLS IN NOT BEING
OPEN IN THE END UP. BECOMING
FRIENDS AND ALLIES AND
SUPPORTERS AS THEY NAVIGATE
HIGH SCHOOL YEARS AND OTHER
HIGH SCHOOL CURRICULUM- SO IT
SEEMS LIKE. WHERE THE ATTENTION
IS PUT TO ALLOW YOUNG PEOPLE.
TO HAVE AVOICE THE RESULTS.
TEND TO BE POSITIVE SO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR WORK THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. OF OUR LORD THANK
YOU THANK YOU MISTER JUST QUICK
QUESTION DOCTOR SERGIO- HOW
MANY PSYCHIATRISTS ARE UC DAVIS
PRODUCING EVERY YEAR. IT IS NOT
ENOUGH CERTAINTY BUT I EIGHTIES.
THERE ARE GENERAL PSYCHIATRIST
IN BETTER CHILD PSYCHIATRISTS
IN THE IN THE GENERAL CATEGORY
HE PRODUCES- CERTAINLY MORE
THAN NINE. EIGHTIES ABOUT THE I
THINK THAT TWELVE FIFTEEN BUT I
CAN COME TO YOU WITH THAT
PARTICULAR NUMBER AS WELL. IN
BY THE WAY HE SAID GREAT THE
QUESTION AND- YOU KNOW WHEN
THAT IS PUTTING IN THE
PERSPECTIVE OF THE- A WAR FORCE
SHORTAGE THAT WE'RE HAVING IN
BAY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONS. HIS CHEST THE
DRAMATIC A UC DAVIS ONE THING
THAT WE HAVE BEEN DOING FOR
YEARS NOW. HE SAID NOT ONLY
TRAINING- IT TRAINING
INTERESTED DANCE A IAN COMBINED
PROGRAMS AS WE CALL THEM A
INTERNAL MEDICINE AND
PSYCHIATRY. OR FAMILY MEDICINE
AND PSYCHIATRY AND MORE
RECENTLY WE STARTED A TRAIN THE
TRAINERS PROGRAM BUT WE CALLED
PRIMARY CARE IN PSYCHIATRY. IN
THE LAST COUNT THE A. B. C. SO
I ONE YEAR CERTIFICATES IN THE
LAST COUNT. WE HAD TWO HUNDRED
LEARNERS TRAINED IN DEATH MORAL
BECAUSE THERE IS THE-
RECOGNITION THAT NEED TO TREAT
THE- EQUIP. OUR WORKFORCE
PRIMARY CARE WERE FOR FORCE
WITH BETTER TRAINING IN
PSYCHIATRY EIGHTEEN EIGHTEEN IN
ORDER ORDER- THE PRIMARY CARE
DOCKS FOR EXAMPLE FROM MY WILL
BE G. WAY IN TO PAY THE OUT
THREE. OF YOUR CREATIONS-
FAMILY MEDICINE IT BABY GET
BORN AVERAGE ABOUT TWO WEEKS OF
TRAINING IN PSYCHIATRY MODE
NEARLY ENOUGH. AND YET THEY ARE
THE ONES ON THE FROM THE YOU
KNOW- ROLE TO SEE THESE CASES
AND BURY SO THE YOU KNOW A NOT
THE UP APPROPRIATE
IDENTIFICATION AND THEREFORE
APPROPRIATE TREATMENTS FOR
THOSE. PEOPLE WHO NEED THEM.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER YOU.
OF THE STORE QUESTION FOR BOTH
THIRD THIRD. EARLIER IN THE
NUMBERS DON'T LIE THERE'S A
DISPARITY BETWEEN. THAT THE
HEALTH CARE OF USE THAT ARE
LATINO AND AFRICAN AMERICAN.
WHAT IS THE ANSWER THAT THE
STATE NEEDS TO HAVE ON THAT
ISSUE WHAT'S THE ANSWER HOW DO
I HOW DO WE ADDRESS THAT
DISPARITY AND DOES THAT REFLECT
LIKE WHEN YOU YOU GAVE US
INFORMATION AT AT. AFFECTS IS
YOU WERE BOTH. DISCUSSING
THINGS LIKE FOSTER CARE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE ALL THE- YOU
KNOW OTHER HEALTH CARE%
PROBLEMS- EDUCATIONAL
ATTAINMENT WORK ECONOMIC
ATTAINMENT ALL THOSE OTHER
THINGS ARE AFFECTED- WHAT WOULD
WHAT WOULD WHAT WE NEED TO DO
TO ADDRESS THE DISPARITY IN
YOUR OPINION- AND I KNOW YOU'VE
BEEN WORKING- A NATIONALLY IN.
THE CALIFORNIA OF. MENTAL
HEALTH CALIFORNIA IS PART OF
THE NATIONAL PROGRAM SO I'D
LIKE TO HEAR FROM THE TWO.
EXPERTS ON THIS DISPARITY ISSUE
WHAT WE CAN DO IN CALIFORNIA
WHEN I FIRST- THANK YOU. I
THINK THAT IT TAKES THOSE- ON
THE GROUND PARTNERSHIPS- FOR
EXAMPLE THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES HAS
RECENTLY CONTRACTED WITH THIS
YEAR HEALTH FOUNDATION TO
ADMINISTER THESE SUBSTANCE USE
PREVENTION PROGRAM IT'S A
TWENTY MILLION DOLLAR EFFORT-
THERE IS A MENTAL HEALTH
INVOLVED IN THAT DEALING WITH
ALL THE SOCIAL DETERMINANTS OF
HEALTH BUT THEY WANT THAT
COMPONENT AS WELL- IT'S SO THE
ZERO HEALTH FOUNDATION WITHIN
REACH INTO ITS NETWORK IT HAS
ITS- TENANTS ON THE GROUND. AND
IT WILL IT FIND PEOPLE WHO CAN
REACH THE PEOPLE DIRECTLY AND
THAT TO ME IS ONE OF THE WAYS
TO GO DIRECT TO THE SOURCE TO
GET THEM INVOLVED IN THE
PROGRAMS IT COULD BE A CHURCH
IT COULD BE A COMMUNITY CENTER
COULD BE AN AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAM- THEY ALREADY HAVE TWO
THREE FOUR HUNDRED YOUTH IN
THEIR PROGRAM IS NO REASON TO
REALLY REINVENT THE WHEEL. BUT
THOSE PROGRAMS TEND TO NOT HAVE
ANY MENTAL HEALTH EDUCATION AT
ALL OR CURRICULUM NOTHING SO-
IT'S A GREAT PARTNERSHIP IN
LOOKING AT HOW WE CAN. DEVELOP
THOSE GROUND PARTNERSHIPS AND
GIVE THEM TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
TO DO THE WORK THAT'S JUST ONE
OF THE WAYS THAT OF THE WE
COULD WE COULD GET THIS DONE.
THANK YOU YES QUE IF I CAN VERY
QUICKLY A- WHAT IS REQUIRED IS.
CIRCUIT EFFORT. ACROSS YOU KNOW
IT IS NOT CHEST THE HEALTH
SECTOR BOB THE SCHOOLS CHURCHES
LAW ENFORCEMENT A SOCIAL
SERVICES IT CENTER HAS TO BE IN
VERY OUR FOCUS ON PREVENT ON
EARLY IDENTIFICATION AND EARLY
PREVENTION IN WITHIN THAT'S
RAIL THERE ARE SO MANY THINGS
THAT CAN BE DONE. SENATE FOR A
THE A I HAVE A LEASE HERE OFF
AT LEAST EIGHT TEAMS THAT CAN
POSSIBLY BE DONE FROM
IDENTIFYING AND SUPPORTING-
KIDS AT RISK. EIGHT TO BE
COPING PROBLEM SOLVING SKILLS
PROMOTE CONNECT CONNECTEDNESS
WITH CHEESE WEB PAGE A ONE THE
CENTERS TO. A CREATE PROTECT
THE BEEN BARN MEANS A
STRENGTHENING AXIS IN BELIEVE
EVERY AT OF CARE. IN THE
STRENGTHENING ECONOMIC SUPPORT
IN A IN I THINK THAT ONE OF THE
BIG BIG CHALLENGES THAT WE HAVE
HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND
NATIONWIDE IS THAT WE DON'T
HAVE. THE COURT IN A CHILD
POLICY. BOB HOW ARE KIDS OUGHT
TO BE DEVELOPING THEMSELVES IN
THE SENSE THAT THAT. A OUR KIDS
YOU ARE NOT THAT WELL EQUIPPED
TO THINK TO- FOR THAT DALY.
THIS RACE THAT THEY ARE FACING
A SENATOR SO I THINK THAT IS SO
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE
WORK TOGETHER AND WE CAN COME
UP WITH THE- S. SERIES SOFA OFF
INTERVENTIONS- BY THE FAST TO
BE A CONCERTED. EFFORT A NECRO
SECTORS. PROMOTED YOU CAN GO
AND TO BECAUSE I WAS TO DEAL
WITH BUDGET. THE GENERAL I
THINK I JUST LIKE TO LAW LIKE
98% OF THE TIME THE OPPOSED ALL
THE MENTAL HEALTH BUDGET
REQUEST SO- IS THERE WAY TO
PROVE THAT THE THIS WOULD PAY
FOR ITSELF. IF WE HAD THESE
KINDS OF PROGRAMS. I THINK THAT
THE BAND ARE SO MUCH ECONOMIC-
A KONAMI SOCIETIES THAT HAD
BEEN DONE OF WHAT WOULD HAPPEN
FOR EXAMPLE OR WHAT ARE DAY
LOSSES A WHEN WE LOSE KIDS TO
SUICIDE FOR EXAMPLE YOU KNOW IN
BERRY SOME BUSINESS CASE THAT
CAN BE DONE. THAT I'LL BE MORE
THAN HAPPY TO CHAT WITH YOU.
WE'RE GETTING TO THAT TO THAT
POINT BY THE WAY ON ON HOW WE
CAN MAKE. THE CASE THAT BC SO A
GOOD RETURN ON INVESTMENT BUT-
OKAY WELL THANK YOU BOTH HIS
REMAINING- AND GIVE US
INFORMATION- WILL MORE UNDER
LAST PANEL AND THAT'S A MORE
USERS- BEAR ON AND- STEVE OLSON
THESE ARE. PEOPLE THAT ACTUALLY
RUN PROGRAMS THAT. DEAL WITH
CHILDREN AND- THEY'RE GOING TO
TALK ABOUT THE CONTINUE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES TO
PEDIATRIC CARE AND- THIRTY AND
THE FULL CONTINUES SERVICES
DIVERSION AND EXPANDING
SERVICES SO WELCOME GERMAN. AND
WAYS SHOULD TAKE YOUR FIRST
RIGHT YES THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
REALLY PUT THERE WILL HAVE
PUBLIC COMMON. APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE AND
THANK YOU ALSO FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP IN ADDRESSING THIS
ISSUE SOME BRING AWARENESS VERY
IMPORTANT SELECTJUST TAKE A
MINUTE TO INTRODUCE THIS ON
THE- CENTER FOR CHILDREN SO
THAT WE CAN PROVIDE SOME
CONTEXT ON THE WORK THEY WERE
DOING WE ARE THE OLDEST
NONPROFIT SERVICING CHILDREN
AND YOUTH IN SAN DIEGO
CELEBRATING ACTUALLY THIS MONTH
A HUNDRED THIRTY THREE YEARS
I'LL- BE PROVIDE A CONTINUUM OF
THERAPEUTIC AND EDUCATIONAL
SERVICES- TOUCHING THE LIVES
ABOUT A THOUSAND PEOPLE. IN SAN
DIEGO COUNTY- EVERY SINGLE DAY
AND WE'RE ALSO NATIONALLY
ACCREDITED WE'RE ALSO PROUD
MEMBERS OF THE CALIFORNIA LINES
FOR CHILD AND FAMILY SIR THIS.
HAS SOME OF THE HUNDRED THIRTY
FIVE ON A FORTY AND
ORGANIZATIONS AND I THINK THAT
WE'RE GONNA SUCH AS LIKE
BECAUSE LIKE MY COLLEAGUE
CAUSING CASA PACIFICA ARE IS
THAT WE REALLY GET TO PARTNER
WITH A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
SYSTEMS OF CARE WE HAVE
CONTRACTS WITH COMPANIES WHICH
SCHOOL DISTRICTS WITH
COMMERCIAL INSURANCE COMPANIES
AND WE KNOW THE NONPROFIT. SO
WE'RE ON THE GROUND REALLY
TRYING TO NAVIGATE FOR THE
NEEDS OF THE SYSTEMS OF CARE
AND THERE ARE SOME THAT IS WHAT
WE HAVE LEARNED SOME IDEAS THAT
HAVE A FOR HOW WE MIGHT BE ABLE
TO IMPROVE- OF CARE I'M NOT
GOING TO SPEND A LOT OF TIME
TALKING ABOUT DATE OUT BECAUSE
I WAS. HAPPY AND RELIEVED TO
SEE THAT THERE STEP THAT I
CONSISTENT WITH WHAT HAS BEEN
THERE'S A INSTEAD DID HOMEWORK
WELL I TERMS OF BEING ABLE TO
ADDRESS THAT. A COUPLE ARE NOW
WHAT ABOUT APPROXIMATELY 25% OF
CHILDREN IN YOUTH IN OUR IN OUR
OUR COMMUNITIES X. A MENTAL AND
BEHAVIORAL DISORDER. ALL THE
INDICATORS OF A KEY T. THIRTY
ARE GOING IN THE WRONG
DIRECTION. JUST TO PUT IT IN
PERSPECTIVE. BOB GREATEST HALL.
IN SAN DIEGO ONE OF OUR
PARTNERS IN. THE IF THAT WE'RE
PUTTING. REPORTED ANY. OF EIGHT
PER. NUMBER ROOM SEKAI EMERGE.
IN IN THE OF EIGHT YEARS THAT
NGUYEN FROM IT FOR HER. TO TWO
EIGHT AND AS WE BEFORE ALSO
WERE VERY CONCERNED A SUICIDE
HAS NOT BECOME THE SECOND
LEADING- BECAUSE OF DEBT IN CAN
CHILDREN ARE AND YOU. SO WHEN
WE WHEN WE TALK ABOUT WHAT WHAT
CAN BE DONE I THINK THAT IT'S
IMPORTANT TO PAY ATTENTION TO
THE ISSUE OF ACCESS AND ACCESS
TO CARE- WE KNOW IT WAS SAID
BEFORE THAT WHEN WE LOOK AT THE
RANGE OF MENTAL HEALTH PROBLEMS
ARE BEING SPRINGS BUT I
COMMUNITIES 50% OF THEM
MANIFEST THEMSELVES FOR SAID
BEFORE BY AGE FOURTEEN SO I
CANNOT THINK OF ANY OTHER TYPE
OF INTERVENTION TO POTENTIALLY
COULD TARGET 50% OF THE PROBLEM
BY PAYING ATTENTION TO IT SO WE
WERE TO PAY ATTENTION TO
CHILDREN AND YOUTH. THAT NONE
OF FOR SOME OF THESE CHALLENGES
EARLY ON WE WOULD BE ABLE TO
HELP WHERE SIGNIFICANT IMPACT
AND WE ALSO KNOW THAT EARLY
IDENTIFICATION AND EARLY
INTERVENTION ARE KEY TO
POSITIVE OUTCOMES THE SOONER WE
CAN IDENTIFY THESE PROBLEMS TO
BETTER IT IS VERY CONCERNING
THAT SOME MOST STUDIES INDICATE
THAT 6280% OF YOU IN CALIFORNIA
IN OTHER COMMUNITIES AS WELL
DRAW THE COUNTRY ARE NOT
GETTING THE HELP THEY NEED WHEN
THEY NEED IT SO IT'S NOT
SURPRISING THEN THAT THESE
PROBLEMS CONTINUING DEVELOPED.
TO SOMETHING THAT IS MORE
CHALLENGING AND WE'RE STARTING
TO SEE OTHER SYSTEMS OF CARE
BEING IMPACTED WEEPING IN
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE AMERICAN
ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS THE
CHAPTER IN SAN DIEGO AND THEY
RIP TO GET THROUGH SEARCH MORE
THAN 25% OF THE CASES IN THE
PRACTICES ARE RELATED TO MENTAL
EMOTIONAL BEHAVIORAL DISORDERS
SO THEY'RE SEEING A NEED TO DO
MORE AND THEY'RE SEEING A NEED
TO MAYBE DO MORE SCREENING SO
NOW WE'RE GOING TO HAVE THE IS
A SCREENING SOLD HAPPENING
PEDIATRIC PRACTICES. BUT THE
QUESTION IS WHAT HAPPENS DâN.
I THINK ANOTHER IMPORTANT COME.
IS TO THINK A IT FROM THE FIRST.
OF A FAN SIX HELP. OUR IF YOU
HAVE A CHILD WITH EXPERIENCE
SOME CHAO. FOR TO BE TO ATTEND
WOMEN GOING ON. WHERE TO GO HOW
TO ACCESS SERVICES TO HAVE THE
RIGHT NEEDS. ARE THE RIGHT
RESOURCES WHERE DO I GO WHAT IS
THE APPROPRIATE PROVIDER OF
CARE. THAT CAN BE VERY VERY
CONFUSING. BUT I WOULD LIKE TO
CALL YOUR ATTENTION. TO PAGE
FIVE FROM THE PRESENTATION THAT
YOU HAVE TO CHARGE IT LOOKS
LIKE THIS. YEAH ARMED AND I
JUST WANTED TO MENTION IT VERY
VERY QUICKLY BECAUSE WHEN WE
THINK ABOUT MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES MOST PEOPLE THINK
ABOUT HOW PATIENT. AND THEY
THINK ABOUT IN PATIENT THOSE
ARE THE KIND OF MORE
TRADITIONAL COMPONENTS OF
PEOPLE. EQUATE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES WEEK. REALITY WE NEED
A FULL CONTINUUM OF MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES THAT GOES FROM.
INTEGRATED CARE THAT HAPPENED
IN IN THAT CAN HELP. TO
PRACTICES OF PATIENT MENTAL
HEALTH WHICH MOST OF US ARE
FAMILIAR WITH. BUT THERE'S ALSO
IN HOME THERAPEUTIC SERVICES
THAT COULD BE VERY VERY
EFFECTIVE AND THEY'RE VERY
VASTLY UNDERUTILIZED. ON A MORE
INTENSE WARY WAY OF PROVIDING
INCOME THERAPIES WRAPAROUND.
MOBILE CRISIS BECOMES ALSO AN
IMPORTANT WAY ON MY COLLEAGUES
GOING TO BE TALKING MORE ABOUT
THAT. AND WE ALSO HAVE HOSPITAL
DIVERSION PROGRAMS THAT CAN BE
MORE COST EFFECTIVE. SO JUST
INTENSIVE OUTPATIENT PROGRAMS
ON A PARTIAL HOSPITALIZATION WE
HAVE RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT ARE
WE HAVING PATIENT. THEN WHEN
YOU LOOK T THE DIFFERENT PAIRS
OF THE SERVICES WHICH WOULD BE
COMMERCIAL INSURANCE ABOUT
COVERING ABOUT THE LOSS ABOUT
THE- SEVEN PERCENT. MANAGE
COMMITTEE CAL ABOUT FIFTY
PERCENT. AND MENTAL HEALTH PLAN
S COUNTY BEHAVIORAL SERVICES
ABOUT FOUR TO SIX PERCENT. YOU
CAN SEE RIGHT AWAY THAT THERE'S
A NUMBER OF SERVICES THAT ARE
NOT BEING COVERED BY SOME OF
THE SYSTEMS OF CARE. ARE THE
BEST. SO FOR EXAMPLE COMMERCIAL
INSURANCE IS NOT COVERING. IN
HOME THERAPEUTIC SERVICES AND
ACTUALLY WEEPING IN
CONVERSATIONS TOGETHER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED CARE
HEALTH SERVICES. TO BE ABLE TO
CONVENE AN OPPORTUNITY WITH
OUR- A- HEALTH INSURANCE
COMPANIES COMMERCIAL INSURANCE
TO BE ABLE TO SEE THE BENEFITS
ON THE- NOT ONLY FROM. A CARE
POINT OF VIEW BUT FROM A
FINANCIAL POINT OF VIEW. TO BE
ABLE TO DELIVER THE SERVICES.
AND ALSO THESE CHALLENGES THAT
EXIST BETWEEN MANAGE COMMITTEE
CALENDAR NOT. THE SERVICES ARE
BEING PROVIDED AND ALSO WITH
MENTAL HEALTH PLANS. SPEAKS TO
AN OPPORTUNITY THAT EXIST TODAY
WITH THE MEDICAL HELP YOU
CALIFORNIA FOR ALL. TO REALLY
ADDRESS THE CHALLENGES THAT
EXISTING MOVING PEOPLE FROM ONE
SYSTEM TO ANOTHER. AND THREE
ABLE TO ACCESS TO THE SERVICES
THEY NEED SO WE FEEL THAT THIS
IS VERY IMPORTANT. SO SPEAKING
ABOUT SOLUTIONS. WHAT WE HAVE
DONE. FIRST ARE WE BELIEVE THAT
IT WAS IMPORTANT TO THINK ABOUT
WHOLE FAMILY. AND TO BE
THINKING A FAMILY CENTER. TO BE
THE WITH THE FOOD DEVELOPMENT.
THAT WE CALL EMPOWER FAMILIES
WHERE WE CREATED AN ASSESSMENT
TOOL THE BEEPING WORKING ON FOR
A NUMBER OF YEARS. THAT WILL
HELP ASIDE INTO WHAT ONE OF THE
NEEDS NOT ONLY OF THE U. BUT
ALSO OF THE FAMILY AS THE
RELEASE OF TAKING CARE OF THEIR
NEEDS. SO WE'LL DO THAT WE LOOK
AT CHAO FUNCTIONING AND THE
CONCERNS OF THE PARENTS OF CARE
GIVERS HALF. LOOK AT THE NEEDS
OF THE FAMILY WHAT KIND OF
COMMUNITY BASED SERVICES
THEY'RE ACCESSING. AND ALSO
WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH THE
NATURAL SUPPORTS OUR- TO THE%
EXTENT THAT THOSE CAN BE ARE
ALSO. A OBTAINED WE HAVE.
WORKED WITH A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT POPULATIONS HELP PUT
THESE RESOURCES ON A WEB BASED
APPLICATION. SO WHEN FAMILIES
COME TO SEE US WE ALREADY HAVE
A LOT OF THIS INFORMATION ABOUT
WHAT THE CONCERNS ARE IN A MORE
HOLISTIC WAY. AND OUR TEAM.
PUTS TOGETHER THE STATE OF THIS
FAMILY NEEDS ASSESSMENTS INTO
COMPREHENSIVE PLANS OF ACTION.
IS SENDING HAND SCARE APPROACH
WHICH WE CALL FAMILY ACTION
PLANS SO NOT ONLY WE ADDRESSING
THE SPECIFIC NEEDS OF EARLY
WITH FAMILY WRAPAROUND. IN A
WAY TO THINK ABOUT IT SO WE
IDENTIFY WHAT IS HIS FAMILY
NEED AND HOW WE NEED TO SUPPORT
AND TO GET WHAT THEY NEED. SO
WE'VE BEEN PILOTING THESE WORK
FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS. AND WE
HAVE ARE GETTING SOME VERY GOOD
RESULTS ARE IN TERMS OF. THE
IMPACT ON THE OUTCOME TO PASS.
SO THE NEXT OF FOR RULES WAS TO
PARTNER WITH WOULD RATED
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL IN SAN
DIEGO. AND WE HAVE CREATED AN
INTEGRATED QUICK CATCH A QUICK
PACE APPROACH SO WE'RE PLACING
MENTAL HEALTH PROVIDERS IN
PEDIATRIC CLINICS. ARE IN IN
OUR COUNTY. AND WHEN THE
PHYSICIANS IDENTIFY A FAMILY
BECAUSE THEY'RE DOING
SCREENINGS THAT REQUIRING SOME
COUPLE SUPPORT. THEY WILL REFER
THEM TO US AND THEY DON'T HAVE
TO BE CONCERNED ABOUT SENDING
THEM OUT. INTO THE COMMUNITY
AND FREQUENTLY EXPERIENCING THE
FRUSTRATION OF NOT KNOWING
WHERE THEY'RE GOING TO GO OR
HOW THEY'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO
ACCESS SERVICES. WE'RE ABLE TO
SEE THEM RIGHT THERE ARE THE
SAME PEDIATRIC CLINIC. BY THE
TIME THEY COME TO SEE AS WE
ALREADY HAVE. HELLO OF DATA
ABOUT WHAT THE NEEDS OF THE SAN.
IS AN WE CAN. TO IT EMPLOY THE
RANGE OF. WE CAN ALSO PROVIDE
CON. TO THE VISIT. AND THE TO
MAKE CRISIS RIGHT THERE. AT THE
PEDIATRIC CLEAN. USING THIS
KIND OF. A FOR LOST CONNECT ON
THE- AND WE- NOW. JUST ABOUT
ONE OF THE UNIQUE NEEDS OF
PARKING. THAT SCARY FOR A CHILD
OF THE MENTAL DISABILITY. OR A
CHILD WITH A MENTAL HEALTH
PROBLEM AND WE HAVE SOME DATA
ON IT PUT AN EXAMPLE OF THE
BACK OF HIS PRESENTATION.
ABOUT COLLABORATIVE CARE AS
WELL. SO WE BELIEVE THAT IT IS
IMPORTANT TO BRING THE SERVICES
TO WERE FAMILIES ARE AN
INTEGRATION WHICH IS ONE OF THE
GOALS OF AN MEDI CAL A
REIMAGINING THAT'S TAKING PLACE
IN THE STATE'S IS AN IMPORTANT
COMPONENT SO WE ALREADY WORKING
ON TRYING TO MAKE THAT WORK AND
TRYING TO IDENTIFY HOW THIS
DISC WITH THIS COULD FUNCTION
IF YOU COULD IF I COULD CALL
YOUR ATTENTION TO SLIDE. EIGHT
THERE'S ANOTHER IMPORTANT
COMPONENT THAT I WOULD LIKE TO.
BRING UP TO YOU. SO THE WAY THE
SYSTEM COULD WORK IS THAT IF
THE PEDIATRICIAN IS WILLING TO
SCREENING AND IDENTIFY AS EARLY
AS CAN BE THE CHALLENGE OF THE
PROBLEMS ARE THAT YOU TO THE
FAMILY MAY BE EXPERIENCING.
MAKE A REFERRAL- TO THE FAMILY
NEEDS ASSESSMENT TO OUR TEAM TO
BE ABLE TO IDENTIFY WHAT THE
FAMILY NEEDS WE'RE NOT ONLY
GOING TO PROVIDE THE CARE FOR
THE FAMILY. MODELS FOR THE USER
BUT ALSO IDENTIFY WHAT KIND OF
COMMUNITY BASED SERVICES THEY
NEED. AND THE OTHER THING THAT
WE'RE DOING IS THAT WE ARE
BUILDING THIS CONTINUUM OF
THERAPEUTIC SERVICES. FROM OUR
PATIENTS SCHOOL BASED SERVICES
INTENSIVE IN HOME SERVICES
HOSPITAL THE VERSION AND
RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT AND NOW
WE CAN LINK THE SERVICES. WITH
PEDIATRIC CARE. SO IT'S A FULL
CONTINUUM THERE WERE BUILDING
IN SAN DIEGO IN PARTNERSHIP A
TRADE IS A CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL.
THAT REALLY HAS THE POTENTIAL
TO TAKE US FROM ONE END TO THE
OTHER AND STEP YOUTH UP OR
DOWN. DEPENDING ON ON WHAT WE
NEED- AND WE BELIEVE THAT THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT WE REALLY
NEED TO FOCUS ON AND WHAT
POTENTIALLY COULD BE THE
FUTURE. SO. VIEW OF. ABLE
MINUTES AGO A QUICK WAS BEING
ASKED ABOUT WHAT WOULD YOU DO
IF YOU HAVE A- WAND SO I WOULD
GRAB. ALLOW RAPID THAT THIS WAS
GOING IF I MAY. UM A THING ON
THE ONE HAND ORGANIZATIONS LIKE
COST. ARE THERE ARE DOING THE
WORK AND WORKING AND
INTERACTING WITH THESE
DIFFERENT SYSTEMS OF CARE A
LOOKING FOR SOLUTIONS AND I'LL
TESTING SOME OF THE SOLUTIONS.
WE WOULD REALLY WORK ON THE
OPPORTUNITY. AND RADIUS
CHILDREN HOSPITAL WELCOME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PARTNER WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. TO ASSESS THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THIS MODEL
BECAUSE IT COULD BE REPLICATED
HE COULD BE THEN BROUGHT INTO
ALL THE COMMUNITIES. AND WE
COULD IDENTIFY THE WASTE THE
WAY TO BRING IT TO SCALE. UP
TO. HEAR THE WORD THAT IT'S
BEEN DONE NOW WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED
HEALTHCARE MAY HELP ALLOWS TO
REALLY CREATE A MORE ROBOTS
CONTINUUM FOR THOSE WHO ARE
COVER. TO COMMERCIAL INSURANCE
AND WE REALLY WOULD LIKE TO
EMPHASIZE- DOT COMPONENT
BECAUSE WE FEEL THAT IT WILL BE
VERY IMPORTANT- IS ABSOLUTELY
CRUCIAL TO REMOVE. ANY KIND OF
BARRIERS THAT EXIST TODAY
BETWEEN MANAGE CARE MEDICARE
AND THE HEALTH PLANS. IS REALLY
A CHALLENGE IS DIFFICULT AND
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE REALLY
TO FORKS. AND THE LAST THING I
WOULD LIKE TO BRING. IS A
COMPONENT TO WORK FORCE ON.
THAT IS AN IMPORTANT CONCERN
FOR ALMOST PROVIDING SERVICES.
FIRST OF ALL WE DON'T HAVE
CLEAR DATA ABOUT THE DATA BALK
WITH THE VISITATION RATES FOR A
MANAGED CARE- MENTAL HEALTH A
MEDICAL PLANS. SO WE DON'T KNOW
EXACTLY WHAT PERCENTAGE OF THE
POPULATION TO COVER ARE
RECEIVING AND PLUS ESPECIALLY.
BUT PROVIDERS. IF THE POP. FOR
MANAGE CARE A MEDICAL PROBLEM
EIGHT COME. TO PROVIDER A TO BE
TO. A ACCEPT AND BE ABLE TO
CREATE THE- INTERNS UNDER SUPER.
TODAY A WHEN WE HAVE A CONTRACT
WITH COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH. THAT
DRAWS MEDI CAL DOLLARS TO
PROVIDE THE SERVICES FOR
SPECIALTY HELD. WEEKEND
CREDENTIAL INTERNS FROM THE
SUPERVISION AND WE CONTROL MEDI
CAL WELL THE COUNTY CONTROL
MEDICAL DOLLARS TO BE ABLE TO
CALL THIS A- COVER THE COST OF
THOSE SERVICES. BUT THAT'S NOT
THE CASE WITH MANAGED CARE MEDI
CAL. AT NIGHT OF. GAVE YOU A
COPY ALSO IN THE PACKET TO A
MEDICAL UPDATE. HE WAS A BULLET
TEEN FROM AUGUST TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN. THAT IN THE CASE THAT
THERE'S NOTHING IN MEDICAID OR
MEDICARE AL THAT PREVENTS STOP
FROM HAPPENING. WE BELIEVE THAT
THIS WILL BE A HELPFUL SOLUTION
BECAUSE IF MEDI CAL RATES OF
REIMBURSEMENT FOG. OR TEND TO
BE LOWER. AREN'T THERE A LOT OF
PROVIDERS THAT ARE NOT ABLE OR
WILLING TO BE ABLE TO TAKE THIS.
ARE AND WE KNOW THAT THERE'S A
SHORT. OF PROVIDERS IN THE
COMMUNITY. IF WE WERE ABLE TO
TAKE ORGANIZATIONS LIKE COSTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE THAT
EXIST. AND BE ABLE TO HAVE
INTERNATIONAL THE SUPERVISION
WITH- WITH PROGRAMS THAT ARE
NATIONALLY ACCREDITED. TO BE
ABLE TO OUR WORK WITH INSURANCE
NOT ONLY WILL BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE TO TRAIN PROVIDERS AND
MAKE SURE THAT THEY GOING TO
THIS LINE OF WORK WE WILL BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE THE SERVICE IN
A COST EFFECTIVE MANNER. SO
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT I WANTED
TO BRING UP AND I JUST WANTED
TO ALSO MENTION TWO TWO AND-
AGAIN WE HAVE DATA ABOUT THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THIS APPROACH.
BUT WE ALSO HAVE DATA THAT
SHOWS THAT FAMILIES WHEN THEY
COME TO GET SERVICES REALLY
BRING IN MORE MORE THAN JUST A
CONCERN THAT THEY HAVE ABOUT
THE CHILD'S BEHAVIOR SYMPTOMS.
MAY HELP THERE'S MULTI SIX TO
MAKE CHALLENGES AND THE THING
IS IMPORTANT FOR US TO ASSESS
THEM SO THAT WE CAN DEVELOP
LISTED PLANS. TO BE ABLE TO
RESPOND TO THAT. OKAY THANK YOU
THANK YOU WOULD GO TO LAST. NO
SOME POOR NEAR FROM PUBLIC. SO
STEVE WILSON IS THE CHIEF
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR CASA
PACIFICA. CENTERS FOR CHILDREN
FAMILIES AND- I TURN IT OVER TO
USE THE FOR YOUR PRESENTATION
WELL- FRANK HERE THANK YOU FOR.
PUTTING A SPOTLIGHT ON THIS. ON
THIS REALLY IMPORTANT TOPIC
I'LL BE BRIEF AND TURNED OUT TO
BE. DUPLICATIVE OF FOUR TURRET
AND TALKED ABOUT BUT A BRIEF
INTRODUCTION- TO CASA PACIFICA
WE'RE LOCATED IN VENTURA COUNTY
IN CAMERA RIO ACTUALLY WE HAVE
A TWENTY FIVE ACRE CAMPUS. WE
WERE LAUNCHED- TWENTY FIVE
YEARS AGO TO FOCUS ON KIDS WHO
WERE. IN THE CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM- AND. FOR TWENTY TWO
YEARS TWENTY ONE YEARS OF OUR-
EXISTENCE WE'VE EXCLUSIVELY
SERVED KIDS IN THE PUBLIC
SECTOR AND THAT'S ABOUT FORTY
THOUSAND CHILDREN WERE IN BOTH
SANTA BARBARA AND VENTURA
COUNTIES NOW PROVIDING
COMMUNITY BASED AND CAMPUS
BASED SERVICES. WHERE ALSO IN
APA PER PRE DOCTORAL INTERNSHIP
PROGRAM. ONE OF THE FEW IN
CALIFORNIA REALLY IN THE
COUNTRY- SPECIALIZING IN
CHILDREN AND ADOLESCENTS AND-
WE GET TO A- UNIDADES PRODUCTOR
CANDIDATES IN PSYCHOLOGY FROM
ALL OVER THE COUNTRY WHO. WHO
WE WANT TO WORK WITH KIDS WHO
ARE ON THE DEEP END OF SYSTEM
WHICH IS THE WAY WE THINK I
THINK ABOUT SO ONE OF THE
THINGS I WANTED TO FOCUS ON WAS
THE- DIFFERENCES IN IN
INSURANCE- PROVIDERS SO IF YOU
THINK ABOUT MEDICAID AS A- AS
BASICALLY A HEALTH INSURANCE
PROGRAM. CAN YOU LOOK AT THE
SPECIALTY MENTAL HEALTH KERR
ABOUT THE BENEFIT PACKAGE
THAT'S AVAILABLE TO KIDS WHO
WHO MEET MEDICAL NECESSITY. IS
REALLY A RICH BENEFIT PACKAGE
EPS D. T. YEAR EARLY PERIODIC
SCREENING DIAGNOSIS AND
TREATMENT THE PROGRAM. THE
MANDATED PROGRAM FOR CHILDREN-
THE ENTITLEMENT PROGRAM FOR
CHILDREN WHO MEET MEDICAL
NECESSITY AND ARE ARE RECEIVING
MEDICAID IS REALLY A RICH
BENEFIT PACKAGE. ON THE OTHER-
ON THE PRIVATE SIDE IN THE
COMMERCIAL WORLD THE BENEFIT
pACTUALLY PRETTY SLAM.
TRADITIONALLY AND MARCH THIS IS
ALREADY POINTED THIS OUT WE
THINK ABOUT- HOSPITALIZATION OR
IN THE OFFICE OUT PATIENT
SERVICES AND THAT'S THAT'S
ABOUT IT WHILE ON THE MEDICAID
SIDE THERE'S- WE CAN BE IN WHAT
I WOULD CALL IS SEEKING MODE
RATHER THAN A WAITING MODE THE
TRADITIONAL. SORT OF SERVICES
ARE DELIVERED IN THE OFFICE YOU
YOU WAIT FOR THAT CLIENT
PATIENT TO COME TO YOU. VERSES
IS SEEKING MODE WHERE YOU'RE IN
THE COMMUNITY AND YOU'RE
DELIVERING SERVICES WHERE. THE
PROBLEMS EXIST SO I THINK
THERE'S A- HUGE DIFFERENCE THAT
WE'VE EXPERIENCED BETWEEN THE
COMMERCIAL PLANTS EMPLOYER
BASED INSURANCE EVEN. IN THE
INDIVIDUAL. AND WHAT'S
AVAILABLE IN THE MEDICAID SIDE
SO WHEN I TALK DIRTY IT'S NOT
PARITY SO MUCH BETWEEN PHYSICAL
AND MENTAL HEALTH A LITTLE BIT
SO. THAT IS A HUGE ISSUE IT'S
PARITY BETWEEN PORTS AVAILABLE
ON THE PUBLIC SIDE IN WHAT I
THINK SHOULD BE AVAILABLE ON
THE PRIVATE SIDE. SO WE
LAUNCHED- INTO THE COMMERCIAL
WORLD IN TWENTY SIXTEEN WE'VE
BEEN PROVIDING SERVICES TO A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT INSURANCE
CARRIERS- WE HAVE CONTRACTS
WITH KAISER. ANTHEM BLUE CROSS
AT NOW. OPTIM ARE WE ALSO DO
SINGLE CASE AGREEMENTS WITH A
NUMBER OF OTHER. INSURANCE
CARRIERS- AND WE NOW PROVIDE A
FULL CONTINUUM OF CARE- REYES
AND THIS IS NOW AVAILABLE.
THROUGH SOME PILOTS THAT HAVE
BEEN- SORT OF ORCHESTRATED OR.
KIND OF FACILITATED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED
HEALTHCARE AND OTHER COMMERCIAL
INSURANCE COMPANIES WE HAVE
RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT PARTIAL
HOSPITALIZATION INTENSIVE
OUTPATIENT WHICH ARE KIND OF
TRADITIONAL SERVICES. BOTH
ANTHEM BLUE CROSS AND KAISER. I
HAVE GOTTEN INTERESTED IN
WHAT'S AVAILABLE ON THE PUBLIC
SIDE AND I THINK THEY SEE IN
HOME SERVICES AND IS SEEKING
MODE AS- AS BEING GOOD FOR
BUSINESS IT'S KIND OF A BOTTOM
LINE DECISION FOR THEM. AND SO
WE'VE BEEN PILING THAT FOR A
NUMBER OF YEARS. RESERVE KIDS
AGE NINE TO SEVENTEEN OUR IN
HOME SERVICES GO AS LOW AS FOUR
YEARS OLD. KIDS WITH EMOTIONAL
DYSREGULATION HIGH RISK
BEHAVIORS. AND CO OCCURRING
DISORDERS SUBSTANCE ABUSE. ARE
WE BEGIN TO SPECIALIZE IN WHAT
WE CALL GENDER EXPANSIVE
SERVICES LGBTQ COMMUNITY. THAT
KIDS WHO- IDENTIFY A AS A
GENDER EXPANSIVE ARE-
DISPROPORTIONATE IN TERMS OF
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES THAT
THEY NEED. OUR TREATMENT MODEL
IS DIALECTICAL BEHAVIOR THERAPY
PRIMARILY ALTHOUGH WE USE A
BUNCH OF EVIDENCE BASED
PRACTICE BUT IN TERMS OF THE
WILL OF PHALLIC BELIEVE HALOTI
OF THE BEHAVIORS THAT WE SEE DB
TIAS THE- TREATMENT OF CHOICE.
WE NOW HAVE FOUR LEVELS OF CARE
AS MUCH AS SAID KIDS CAN STEP
UP AND DOWN DEPENDING ON WHAT
THE NEEDS ARE PRIMARILY
STEPPING DOWN FROM RESIDENTIAL
INTO PHP IOP AN ENTITY AND HOME
COMMUNITY- SERVICES ON AMAZON
SKIP OVER THESE SLIDES THE-
BUT- I ALREADY MENTIONED WHAT'S
AVAILABLE THROUGH MEDIC COW.
STARTING WITH A MOBILE CRISIS
RESPONSE WHAT WE'VE SEEN WE
OPERATE THE MOBILE CRISIS
RESPONSE TEAM IN SANTA BARBARA
COUNTY RIGHT NOW FOR
ADOLESCENTS. THE COUNTY HANDLES
THE ADULTS SO- WHAT WE'VE SEEN
IN THE PAST HISTORICALLY WHEN
WE PROVIDED. MOBILE CRISIS
SERVICES RESPONDED TO A CRISIS
FOR A FAMILY THAT HAS
COMMERCIAL INSURANCE WE TALKED
TO THE INSURANCE KERRIER ABOUT-
BILLING THEM THEY SAY THAT'S A
LAW ENFORCEMENT FUNCTION. WHERE
WE DON'T PAY FOR THAT ANTHEM
HAS TAKEN A DIFFERENT TACT AND
THEY'VE ACTUALLY- NOW ARE
SUPPORTING. FAMILIES WHO HAVE
THEIR OWN INSURANCE IN SANTA
BARBARA COUNTY THAT STARTED OUT
AS A PILOT THERE SO MOBILE
CRISIS WE CAN BILL AND TOM AND
WE CAN MAKE ASSESSMENTS AND
DETERMINE WHAT THE FAMILY OR
THE USE NEED IN ADDITION
THERE'S CRISIS STABILIZATION.
CRISIS STABILIZATION SKEWS ME-
TWENTY THREE OUR SERVICE
WRAPAROUND WHICH I THINK YOU'RE
FAMILIAR WITH AND THERAPEUTIC
PAYROLL SERVICES BOTH THE HOME
AND COMMUNITY SERVICES. WE'VE
HAD A LOT OF EXPERIENCE OVER
THE LAST FOUR YEARS- RUNNING-
WELL OVER SIX HUNDRED EPISODES
IT'S ABOUT THREE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY CHILDREN- CAN YOU WE'RE
SAYING REALLY GOOD OUTCOMES THE
REFERRALS. IN THE COMMERCIAL
INSURANCE WORLD COME PRIMARILY
FROM INSURANCE PROVIDERS AND
HOSPITALS. INTERESTINGLY
ENOUGH- AND- WE'RE SITTING
REALLY GOOD RESULTS WE- SEE A
REAL SHORTAGE OF- BOB PROVIDERS
THE BIGGEST STRUGGLE THAT WE
HAVE IS HIRING CLINICIANS WHO
CAN DELIVER THIS SERVICE- FAN
IF THERE'S ANYTHING YOU CAN DO
TO HELP THAT- WORKFORCE
SHORTAGE THANK EVERYBODY IN THE
ROOM WOULD. APPRECIATE THAT. I
AND OUR OUTCOMES ARE VERY
POSITIVE SO WHERE ARE THE
OPPORTUNITY THAT MY SIS
MENTIONED. WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF MANAGED HEALTHCARE- CAN- IT
SOUNDS LIKE THEY'RE GONNA DO A
CONVENING WHERE WE CAN TALK
ABOUT OUR EXPERIENCE WITH
KAISER ANTHEM BLUE CROSS. AND
SUGGEST THAT OTHER CARRIERS SO
LOOK AT EXPANDING THEIR BENEFIT
PACKAGE WHICH WOULD BE IN THEIR
INTERESTS FINANCIALLY SO-
PREVENT WITHOUT OUT IN TEN. THE
APPARATUS QUESTIONS. SO WHEN
YOU TALK ABOUT THE- AND YOU'RE
SAYING ESSENTIALLY THAT MEDICO
IS BETTER WIDER BROTHER SERVICE
THEN THIS IS FOR BOTH YOU GUYS.
THEN THE PRIVATE INSURANCE LAWS
AT THIS TIME IN CALIFORNIA SO
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING YES OKAY AND
I DON'T KNOW THAT IT'S POSSIBLE
TO REALLY DICTATE A BENEFIT
PACKAGE WELL HERE'S BUT BUT I
THINK- THERE IS WE CAN DO A
LAWN OKAY. BUT TRIED FOUR TIMES
GOOD THE P. I THINK IF A RANGE
OF SERVICES IT'S I THINK IT'S
IN THEIR FINANCIAL INTERESTS TO
BE PROVIDING SERVICES IN HOME-
AND AVOIDING HOSPITALIZATIONS
DO YOU GO AHEAD YEAH I JUST
WANTED TO ADD TO THAT- THAT A I
THINK THE DEFINITELY THERE'S
GOING TO BE ROOM TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE CONVERSATION WITH
COMMERCIAL INSURANCE AND
REALIZING THE BENEFITS OF DOING
THIS. ON THE MEDICAL SIDE YEARS
OR MORE RANGE OF OPTIONS BUT I
THINK THAT THE CHALLENGE THAT
WE HAVE IS LIKE THIS TO SYSTEM
NOW WE HAVE BETWEEN MANAGED
CARE MEDI CAL AND WHAT'S
HAPPENING WITH THE WITH THE
COUNTIES OF MAKES IT SOMETIMES
DIFFERENT DIFFICULT FOR PEOPLE
TO NAVIGATE THOSE TO SYSTEMS
EVEN THOUGH THE BENEFIT MAYBE
THERE SOMETIMES YOU MAY BE
CHALLENGING CHALLENGING TO
ACCESS IT SO THAT'S AN
IMPORTANT THING THAT WILL BE
IMPORTANT TO A. TO INVESTORS AS
WELL. DID YOU DO. THANK THE
BEACH THE TWO SYSTEM. IF THE
REMAIN LIKE TO ARE THERE WOULD
BE. PEOPLE IN FAMILIES THAT
WOULD DROP INTO THE MEDI CAL
SYSTEM FROM PRIVATE INSURANCE
OR IS IT HAPPENING NOW. WHERE
THEY HAVE PRIVATE INSURANCE
WELL THEN THEY DON'T GET THE
TYPE OF SERVICES. MAYBE THEY
NEED THROUGH THE PRIVATE
INSURANCE AND THEY WOULD. THEN
RETRIEVE THOSE SERVICES FROM
THE MEDICAL SYSTEM OR SOME
OTHER PUBLIC SYSTEM IS THAT IT
IS A THAT DOES HAPPEN NOW DOES
HAPPEN NOW YES OKAY YEAH SO
THAT'S A COST TO THE STATE AND
EARLY IT IS THE CAR THROUGH THE
MEDICAID SYSTEM FOR US YES THE
ONE THING TO JUST CLARIFY THERE
REALLY ARE THREE SYSTEMS THURS
WHAT'S AVAILABLE IN THE
COMMERCIAL AND THEN YOU HAVE
ALL THE DIFFERENT PLANS
EMPLOYERS MAY GO FOR. THEN YOU
HAVE THE MANAGED CARE MEDI CAL
WHICH IS BEEN GIVEN OVER THE
COMMERCIAL INSURANCE COMPANIES
WANT ONE MORE SYSTEM X. ABOUT
LOW RATES AND YOU SAY MANAGED
CARE YOU MEAN THOUGH LIKE THE
COUNTY POWER MANAGE CARE THE
IT'S THE IT'S THE A MILD TO
MODERATE- YOUTH WHO ARE. QUOTE
MILD AMOUNT. INTERNALS OF FOR
MEDI. AND THE U. COMMERCIAL
INSURANCE COMPANIES HAVE A LOT
OF THOSE PLANS THAT'S UNDER THE
MANAGER ON TRUCKS WITH THE
RIGHT. WITH WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF MANAGED CARE PARTNER OF
HEALTH CARE RATHER AND THEN
THEIR SPECIALTY MENTAL HEALTH
OF THE COUNTY'S HANDLE IT STAB
SYSTEM THAT BREAKDOWN IS
HANDLE. THAT HAS THE LARGER WAS
A TERROR ATTACK. OKAY TWELVE
YEARS OF. HOW ABOUT THE COUNTY
MENTAL HEALTH MANAGED CARE
SYSTEMS THE PART OF THE MEDIC
YOU CONSIDER THAT PART OF THE
MEDICAL SYSTEM RIGHT YES OKAY-
DO DO YOU FEEL THAT-
FINANCIALLY. AS WE HAVE THE
PREVIOUS PANEL TALKED ABOUT
CLEAR EVIDENCE THAT. WE'RE
CATCHING PEOPLE TO LAY THE
YOUNG KIDS TOO LATE RIGHT DO
YOU AGREE WITH THAT AND WHAT
CAN YOU KIND OF TALK ABOUT THE
CONSEQUENCES OF THAT IN TERMS
OF THE PROGRAMS THAT YOU
OPERATE- I CAN GIVE A AN
EXAMPLE REAL QUICKLY- IN
ADDITION TO JUST THE SUFFERING
WHICH IS DIFFICULT TO MEASURE-
IF YOU THINK ABOUT THE COST OF
HOSPITALIZATION. TWO THREE DAYS
OF HOSPITALIZATION OVER
HOSPITALIZATION EPISODES
IMPATIENT OF EPISODE MAYBE
EQUIVALENT TO MAYBE FIVE TO
SEVEN DAYS OF RESIDENTIAL
TREATMENT MAY BE EQUIVALENT TO
A FULL MONTH OF INTENSIVE IN
HOME THERAPY SERVICES SO WHEN
YOU JUST THINK ABOUT THE COST
EFFECTIVENESS. ARE IN INPATIENT
UNITS ARE TELLING US OTHER FULL
THERE'S A LOT OF RECIDIVISM
BECAUSE THEY'RE STRUGGLING IN
BEING ABLE TO PLACE YOU WITH
THE APPROPRIATE LEVEL OF CARE
SO AS A RESULT OF THAT THEY'RE
COMING BACK AND GETTING SOME OF
THE MORE SIGNIFICANT- GUN
CLOSELY TYPES OF TREATMENTS
WHAT'S HAPPENING EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENTS IS SOMETHING THAT I
ADDRESS BEFORE IS VERY
SIGNIFICANT AND VERY VERY
COSTLY. HE WE WERE ABLE TO
EXPAND THIS CONTINUUM AND MAKE
IT EASIER FOR FAMILIES TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
SCARE NOT ONLY IT WILL BE
BETTER FOR THE FAMILY FOR THE
YOUTH BUT HE WILL ALSO BRING
SIGNIFICANT SAVINGS WHICH IS A
LOT OF THE MOTIVATION. BELIEVE
US TO US WE'RE ALSO HAVING
CONVERSATIONS WITH COMMERCIAL
INSURANCE TO OPEN UP THIS WHOLE
AREA BECAUSE THERE IS A SENSE
OF THIS COULD BE VERY COST
EFFECTIVE. THE RIGHT NOW RIGHT
NOW ALL OF THE MIDDLE HEALTH
SYSTEM. I MIGHT. IS OR IS NOT
TOWARDS. KIDS IS MORE OR AND
TOWARDS ADULTS WOULD YOU AGREE
WITH THAT STATEMENT YES OKAY
SO- THE WHOLE SYSTEM IS
ORIENTED TOWARDS. WAITING UNTIL
THEY BECOME ADULTS IF YOU WANT
TO SET THAT WAY AND THEN.
PROVIDING THROUGH THE COUNTY
MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM. MEDI CAL
OTHER KINDS OF SERVICES- AND
MAYBE THROUGH THE ADULT
INSURANCE PROCESS OTHER KINDS
OF SERVERS WE DON'T CATCH THE
CHILDREN WHILE THEY'RE IN
SCHOOL OR OR- BECAUSE OF THIS
THE ISSUES WE HAVE THE PREVIOUS
PANEL STIGMA ALL THOSE KINDS
OF. THE ROOM THE RACIAL OF
DISPARITIES SO- ETHNIC
DISPARITIES ISSUE ALL THOSE
KINDS OF ISSUES. WHAT WHAT
WOULD YOU SAY IF WE TOOK MORE A
OF OUR MEDICAL SYSTEM AND MAYBE
RE RE RE INVIGORATED THE
CHILDREN'S PART OF IT HOW WOULD
YOU HOW WOULD YOU GO ABOUT
DOING THAT. A INTERFERE A FULL
OF THINGS AND I'M SURE THAT
STEVE HAS SOME IDEAS AS WELL
YEAH- FIRST OF ALL IT WOULD
WHEN WE THINK ABOUT THE MORE
TRADITIONAL APPROACHES TO THE
MENTAL HEALTH ATTEMPTING TO BE
VERY KLEIN TO INDIVIDUAL CENTER
WHICH IS THE ADULT MODEL
SYMPTOM REDUCTION ALSO THE OF
THE OLD MODEL. CHILDREN LEAVING
FAMILIES FOR HOPEFULLY THE
BELIEVE IT IN IN FAMILIES IT
HAS TO BE A FAMILY CENTRED
APPROACH SO WHAT ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT THAT TENDS TO
HAPPEN I THINK THE SOMETIMES
THE BENEFITS ARE CONCEIVED- AND
THEN WE PROVIDERS NEED TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO NAVIGATE
THEM. TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
CARE IF WE COULD LOOK AT MODELS
THAT REALLY ALLOWS TO
EFFECTIVELY CARE FOR THE YOUTH
AND THE FAMILIES AND THEN
IDENTIFY HOW TO TAKE THE
BENEFITS AND BE ABLE TO REALLY
HELP SUPPORT THAT. TO BE ABLE
TO- MAKE IT COST EFFECTIVE THAT
COULD GO A LONG WAY BUT WE
WOULD SAY THAT FAMILIES CENTER
IS VERY VERY IMPORTANT AND ALSO
WE BELIEVE THAT INTEGRATION
THAT'S ONE OF THINGS THAT WERE
FINING WITH PRIMARY CARE IN
PEDIATRIC OFFICES IT'S ALSO
VERY IMPORTANT THE OTHER
COMPONENT IS. OF COURSE WITH
SCHOOLS THAT ARE EXPERIENCING
THAT SO THAT THE COMBINATION OF
THOSE FACTORS TOGETHER PROBABLY
COULD HAVE A SIGNIFICANT IMPACT.
YOU KNOW ONE THE THINGS THAT'S
INTERESTING TO ME HIS LOOK AT
THE DATA. THE REDUCTION OF USE
IN THE JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM
IT'S BEEN A HUGE ARE HUGE
DECLINE AM VERY PURPOSEFUL !S
OF OUR COMMUNITY SERVICES THAT.
THAT SYSTEM IS PROVIDING BUT IF
YOU TALK TO THE CHAU OFFER
FOLKS. THEY WILL SAY YEAH NOW A
LOT OF THOSE KIDS ARE WINDING
UP IN OUR SYSTEM. AND THEN YOU
LOOK AT THE DATA IN THE CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM AND THAT'S ALSO
DECLINING THEY'VE HAD SOME REAL
GOOD SUCCESS WITH COMMUNITY
SERVICES FAMILY SUPPORTS. JUDY
CATION TYPE SERVICES THAT THEY
DELIVER AND SO THEY'VE BEEN
ABLE TO REDUCE THEIR THEIR
POPULATION THEN YOU TALK TO THE
EDUCATORS AND SAY YEAH WE HAVE
ALL THOSE KIDS. AND YOU THINK
ABOUT THE- WHAT KIDS GO THROUGH
NOW IN SCHOOLS THEY GO TO
SCHOOLS AND THEY'RE ACTUALLY
DOING ACTIVE SHOOTER DRILLS.
AND NOW THAT IT IS A LITTLE. I
THINK IT CREATES SOME OF THOSE.
ONLY THAT'S NOT ADVISABLE WELL
I THINK IT DOES CREATE SOME
REAL STRESS ANXIETY ON THE PART
OF THESE KIDS IT'S A TRAUMATIC
EVENT IN AND OF ITSELF JUST THE
REHEARSALS AND- DESCRIPTION.
DESCRIPTIONS THAT THEY GET ON
WHY THEY'RE DOING THAT- SO
SCHOOL SERVICES WHICH MORE CSUS
MENTION IN TERMS OF EXPANDING
THE- MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ARE
AVAILABLE TO KIDS SCHOOLS ARE
REALLY AN IMPORTANT. SPOT WHICH
SHOW WE'VE ALSO HEARD FROM A
COUPLE OF OUR PANELISTS AT
THAT'S WHERE- MORE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES NEED TO BE ABLE
TO BE DELIVERED. YEAH I HAVE
ONE MORE QUESTION AND MAYBE
CENTER MAROC BUT- IF WE-
REINVIGORATED THE USE THE
MENTAL HEALTH. SYSTEM WOULD WE
RECEIVED AS A STATE I'M TALKING
ABOUT THOSE PEOPLE THAT.
RECOMMEND VETOES IN BUDGET CUTS
FOR. ALL THE BILLS THAT WE
PROPOSE FOR YOUTH MENTAL HEALTH
PROGRAMS OVER THE LAST THIRTEEN
YEARS I'VE BEEN HERE A LIST OF
IF WE REINVIGORATE. THE USE
MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM. WOULD RE
RECEIVE DIVIDENDS IN TERMS OF
LESS FOSTER KIDS JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM- BETTER
EDUCATION- RESULTS- BETTER
ECONOMIC FUTURES. CAN YOU
COMMENT ON THE. THE SIDE OF THE
BENEFITS OF CATCHING EARLIER AT
THE MENTAL HEALTH PROBLEMS WHEN
YOU HAVE KIDS. OUT THERE IS NOT
REALLY NO DOUBT ABOUT IT AND
YOU CAN YOU MENTION A NUMBER OF
THE POTENTIAL BENEFITS- THERE
ARE SOME STUDIES THAT THE THAT
SHOW ON. I HOPE THAT I CAN PUT
IT CORRECTLY THAT SOMETIMES A
ONE DOLLAR. INVESTED IN EARLY
THAT IDENTIFICATION AND
INTERVENTION CAN SAVE FIVE TO
SEVEN. LATER ON SO IT MIGHT BE
POSSIBLE TO REALLY I IDENTIFIED
THAT THE BENEFITS OF BEING ABLE
TO ADDRESS AND IDENTIFY THE 50%
OF MENTAL HEALTH PROBLEMS THAT
ADULTS WITH HAPPY FOR THE AGE
OF FOURTEEN. IF WE COULD DO
THAT AND INTERVENE EARLIER
BEFORE THEY BECOME CHRONIC
CONDITIONS OF BEFORE THE BECOME
MORE ACUTE CONDITIONS WE MAY BE
ABLE TO GET BETTER RESULTS I
NEED SOME HE WILL BE OF A WISE
INVESTMENT. TO BE ABLE TO DO
THAT. IT WOULD THERE BE A
MULTIPLIER EFFECT FOR. LATINO
AND NON. AFTER AMERICAN OF.
FAMILIES A IN THAT IN THAT
REGARD WITH THE BE A MULTIPLIER
EFFECT IN TERMS OF THE BENEFITS
YOU KNOW WHAT WE'RE FINDING IS
THAT THEY HAVE LESS WE SAW THE
DATA EARLIER THEY HAVE FAR LESS
SERVICES WHAT WHAT SPECIALLY
FOR KIDS BUT WE'RE IDENTIFYING
IS THAT THAT'S PART OF THE
REASONS WHY A FAMILY CENTER
APPROACH IS IMPORTANT. TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE THE DATE THE
CULTURAL AWARENESS OF WHAT
REALLY- RESONATES AND WHAT DO
YOU REALLY NEEDS TO HAPPEN TO
BE ABLE TO STOP THEIR SOME
CREDIBILITY BUT IF YOU WORKING
WITH THE FAMILY HAVING A MORE
HOLISTIC APPROACH THE IMPACTS
ARE COULD BE VERY VERY
SIGNIFICANT AND BENEFICIAL AND
WHAT WE'RE SEEING THAT
HAPPENING IN THE WORK THAT WE
DO HAVE SOME OF THE ITEMS THAT
WE HAVE. SOME OF OUR PROGRAM. I
THINK IT'S OF IT THE IS NOT
SOME MENTAL HEALTH WHERE. IT
THAT NEEDS BIG IN FOR. OF
RESOURCES. BUT IT'S ALSO THE
SOCIAL DETERMINANTS OF MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUE HEALTH AND MENTAL
HEALTH AND THOSE ARE MUCH
BIGGER POLICY ISSUES I THINK
THAT. COULD AB AVERAGE FUTURE
IMPACT ON WHAT WE'RE SEEING NOW
OKAY CENTER OKAY OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR INPUT YOUR
SERVICE- WE'RE GONNA OPEN UP
FOR ANY IS THERE ANY PUBLIC
COMMENTS GOING TO SEE CHAU
HANDS ANYBODY OKAY PLEASE COME
TO THE MICROPHONE ALL ALLOW- OF
SOME TESTIMONY HERE. IF YOU
COULD LIVE YOUR REMARKS. THAT
WOULD BE PER FOR OF ALL GO
AHEAD PLEASE I THANK YOU
SENATOR PELL AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- APPRECIATE BEING ABLE
TO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TO YOU TODAY FOR A SHORT
PERIOD OF TIME. MY NAME IS PAM
HAWKINS AND I AM WITH AN AGENCY
CALLED UNITED PARENTS WE ARE
MADE UP OF FAMILIES WHO HAVE
CHILDREN WHO HAVE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH ARE NEEDS SO WE
ADVOCATE ACROSS THE STATE FOR
THOSE FAMILIES. I WANTED TO LET
YOU KNOW THAT- WE- ARE. BIG
ADVOCATES FOR THERAPIES THAT
INCLUDE FAMILIES AND THERE ARE
SEVERAL. EFFECTIVE PRACTICES
WHEN I SIT BACK TO PRACTICES
WHAT I REALLY MEAN AS AN
EVIDENCE BASED PRACTICE. A
PRACTICE THAT HAS A RESEARCH
AND A BASIS TO LET US KNOW THAT
IT'S SOMETHING THAT WILL WORK.
SO WE ARE ADVOCATES OF AFFECTED
PRACTICES THAT INCLUDE
FAMILIES. ESPECIALLY FAMILY
THERAPY IS. WE TALK ABOUT
FAMILY THERAPIES AND- YOU DON'T
OFTEN SEE THOSE IN EITHER THE
MEDICAL SYSTEM FOR THE PRIVATE
SECTOR THE REASON FOR THIS I
THINK IS THAT HIS FAMILY
THERAPIES AND THERE ARE-
SEVERAL FAMILY THERAPY SO I'LL
MENTION ONE IT'S CALLED
FUNCTIONAL FAMILY THERAPY IT
HAS FOR DECADES OF RESEARCH
THAT SHOWS THAT IT'S AN
EFFECTIVE PRACTICE WITH. OUR
CHILDREN WHO ARE IN THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM WITH
CHILDREN WHO ARE IN THE CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM AND WITH
CHILDREN WHO ARE ONLY IN THE
MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM SO YOU SEE
POSITIVE RESULTS ALL ACROSS THE
BOARD BUT- THERAPIST WHEN
THEY'RE IN GRADUATE SCHOOL ARE
NOT TAUGHT TO DO FUNCTIONAL
FAMILY THERAPY SO IT IS
INCUMBENT UPON THE PROVIDER OF
SERVICE WHAT CASA PACIFICA OR
SAN DIEGO CENTER FOR CHILDREN
FOR EXAMPLE TO PAY FOR THE
TRAINING FOR THEIR CLINICIANS-
TO. BE ABLE TO PROVIDE THESE
SERVICES IT'S EXPENSIVE AND
ONGOING TRAINING TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE- MODEL THAT'S FAMILIES
RECEIVED AS A MODEL IT HERE
HUESO THAT THEY'RE DOING WHAT
WAS INTENDED TO DO SO THAT YOU
GET THE AFFECT ABOUT COM OR THE
POSITIVE OUTCOME. SO I THINK
THAT I JUST WANTED AT HAVE YOU
THINK ABOUT. A VERY SMALL PER
OF CHILDREN CAL ACTUALLY
RECEIVED A FOR. AN AFFECTED
FAMILY THERAPY. SO SOMETHING TO
THINK ABOUT THANK YOU. YES
PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON THANK
YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK- THERE A COUPLE OF THINGS
THAT CAME UP FOR ME AS I WAS
LISTENING AND IDENTIFY YOURSELF
YES MY NAME IS TANYA MCCOLLUM
AND I LIVE IN ALAMEDA COUNTY
OKAY AND- I AM AND ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT CAME UP WAS ABOUT
DISPARITIES AND SERVICES. AND
AS A PARENT OF A YOUNG BLACK
MAN YOUNG BOY WHO WAS IN SCHOOL
I A CAN SPEAK TO THAT BEING A
STATISTIC IN TERMS OF THE- BOYS
OF COLOR BEING SUSPENDED AND
EXPELLED FROM SCHOOL AT HIGHER
RATES THAN THEIR COUNTER THEIR
WHITE COUNTERPARTS. FOR SOME OF
THE SAME OFFENSES. AND ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT I'VE SEEN
THAT'S BEEN EFFECTIVE IN
HELPING THAT IS REALLY A
PREVENTION AND EARLY
INTERVENTION- MODEL IS ALSO
EVIDENCE BASED. AND IT'S CALLED
MENTAL HEALTH CONSULTATION
WHICH IS ACTUALLY DONE AT THE
PRESCHOOL LEVEL BECAUSE THE
SUSPENSION AND EXPULSION RATES
START THAT EARLY. AND IT
ADDRESSES THE SYSTEM AS OPPOSED
TO- NECESSARILY PUTTING
CHILDREN SERVICES. EIGHT
THERAPISTS OUR CLINICIANS ARE
BROUGHT INTO THE- A SCHOOL
SETTING BUT THERE'D BE HEADS
PROGRAMS OR HATEVER. TO
EDUCATE THE PROVIDERS TO
PRESCHOOL PROVIDERS ON
BEHAVIORS THAT THEY MAY BE
SEEING IN THE IN THE CLASSROOM
SETTING. SO IT REALLY THE IN
THE ADDRESS IS THE SYSTEM WHICH
I THINK IS REALLY WHAT WILL
HELP TO DEAL WITH DISPARITIES
IN THAT WAY. AND WHAT I'M
NOTICING IS THAT WITH THE
MANAGED CARE MODEL THAT THAT
PART OF THIS OF INTERVENTION IS
BEING CUT. BECAUSE THERE'S MORE
OF A- EMPHASIS AT CONDITIONS
BEING ABLE TO BUILD A MAN AND-
MIL HEALTH CONSULTATION IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT'S MEDI CAL
BILLABLE. SOUL I WOULD. LIKE TO
SEE THAT THAT BE ADDRESS THAT
THAT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT'S
TAKEN AWAY BECAUSE IT'S A VERY
VERY VALUABLE RESOURCE. AT AND
IT DOES HELP IN AND KEEPING
KIDS IN SCHOOL AND ALSO
IDENTIFYING THEM IF THEY DO
NEED SERVICES. THANK YOU LOVE
TO HAVE SOME MORE INFORMATION
ABOUT THAT IF YOU GET OKAY.
OKAY THANK YOU. NEXT WEEK
REPLACE. HI MY NAME IS BURKE
RADIUM THE DAVIS HEALTH SYSTEM-
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CENTER OF
EXCELLENCE AND I APPRECIATE
THIS OPPORTUNITY AND I
APOLOGIZE IF THIS IS- A SILLY
QUESTION BUT I THINK YOU SAID
THAT 98% OF LEGISLATIVE FUNDING
IS DENIED AT THE BUDGET LEVEL
IS AND WHAT WHAT I SAID WAS SO
WITH WE DID A STUDY OF- LIKE
THE BILLS THE LEGISLATIVE
PROPOSALS. AND IN TERMS OF THE
ROOM YOU KNOW THE IN A TO GET A
BILL THROUGH THIS DIFFICULT.
SURE ESPECIALLY ONE I DO.
CENTER MORAL ARE CAN SAY IT'S
EVEN WORSE FOR RIGHT. FOR BUT
YOU GOT TO BE YOU GO IT YOU CAN
GOT A REAL THAT YOU'RE GOING
THROUGH A LOT BARRIERS AND ONE
OF IS THE FINANCE. AND WHAT
THEY DO IS THEY THEY LIKE TO
SAY NO. AND THEY SAY NO 90% OF
TIME FOR MENTAL HEALTH BILLS I
UNDERSTAND THAT. BUT BUT I
THINK WHAT THEY DON'T SAY. THEY
DON'T SEE IS THE WAY THEY LOOK
AT THINGS IS MAYBE A LITTLE
WRONG. IN TERMS OF LOOKING AT
SOMETHING IN TERMS OF SAVING.
THE TAXPAYER AND THE COMMUNITY
MONEY. IN TERMS OF FEEL A
FORGET ABOUT THE VALIDITY OF
THE SERVICE BUT LOOKING AT
THINGS IN TERMS OF. DOES THIS
HAVE A RETURN ON INVESTMENT.
FISCALLY FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. WELL IT SEEMS LIKE
EVERYBODY HEARS SAYING IF YOU
DO STUFF. WITH THE KID EARLIER
IN ALL AT THE KID WAIT UNTIL
THE KID GETS WORSE AND WORSE
THAT'S ONE OF THE MOST COST
EFFECTIVE THING SHE CAN
POSSIBLY DO THE- LONG TERM LIFE
FOR THAT CHILD. ESPECIALLY WITH.
THE DISPARITIES NUMBERS FOR A
SUIT WHY I KEEP BRINGING THAT
UP. FOR THE LATINO AND AFRICAN
AMERICAN KIDS IT'S JUST SO
OBVIOUS IT'S LIKE AN OBVIOUS
THING I MEAN YOU'RE GOING TO
SAVE MONEY AND THEN AND THEN
BROUGHT UP THE POINTS ABOUT
HOSPITALIZATION. WAS ACOSTA PUT
ONE PERSON A. A THOUSAND
DOLLARS I THINK IN OUR AREA IN
THE BAY AREA PROBABLY I WOULD
SAY THAT. SO THAT'S WHAT THAT'S
WHEN TALKING ABOUT A WHAT DO
YOU THINK CAN CHANGE THAT IS IT
MORE DATA THAT'S NEEDED ON IT
MEANS THEY HAVE TO CHANGE THE
WAY THEY THINK AND THEY CAN
HAVE SOMEBODY WHO WHO THEIR
BOSS. IS UP THEREYOU KNOW OVER
DOWN ON THE FIRST FLOOR.
BECAUSE TONE TO. CHANGE THE WAY
THEY'RE DOING THINGS THERE
MAYBE BUT THAT'S THAT'S
BASICALLY IT. YOU HAVE A NAME A
SHEKEL LOBBY IS SERVICE NEWSOME
NEWSOME. HAS SAID GO TALK TO
THE- EXECUTIVE BRANCH WHERE THE
LEGISLATIVE BRANCH. IF YOU KNOW
IT BUT HE'S BUT HE'S EXPLORING.
AS THE OUR DEPUTY SECRETARY
SAID HE'S EXPLORING ALL THIS
ISSUE IN TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
HE LIKES TO THINK ABOUT THIS IN
TERMS OF A STRATEGY. IS THE
FIRST GOVERNOR MY OPINION FOR
GOVERNORS AND ON BY BEFORE WE
HAD SOMEBODY TALK THIS MUCH
ABOUT MENTAL HEALTH IS
GOVERNOR'S SOME. TO BE HONEST
ABOUT IT THAT'S TRUE OKAY. SO
I'M REALLY PLEASED AND I JUST
THINK THAT WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
YOU GOT TO THINK ABOUT THE-
INSTITUTION HOW YOU HAVE TO.
CHANGE SERVE THE INGRAINED.
WAYS OF THINKING ABOUT THINGS
AND MAKE IT A LITTLE DIFFERENT
FOR THE BENEFIT OF OUR OUR
STATE. THAT'S ALL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH YEAH I'M SORRY I WENT
ON AND ON BUT I HAVE STRONG
OPINIONS. OKAY GO AHEAD HI MY
NAME IS JENNIFER SAID
BRANSTETTER I'M NOT HERE ON
BEHALF OF ANYONE OTHER THAN
MYSELF BUT I WAS A PUBLIC
SCHOOL EDUCATOR FOR SIX YEARS
NAME A CURRENT NURSE HERE UC
DAVIS AND THEN I DO SEXUAL
ASSAULT NURSING. FOR THE COUNTY
OF SA JOAQUIN SO I'VE HAD A
LOT OF EXPERIENCE WITH THIS- MY
QUESTION FOR USE IN MEDICINE
THERE'S A TREND WHERE WE'RE
GOING FROM CULTURAL COMPETENCY
TO MORE OF A CULTURAL HUMILITY
APPROACH. WHERE WE'RE GOING
FROM THE COMMUNITIES THEMSELVES
TO HELP DIRECT HOW WE BEST. A
PUT MONEY BACK INTO THAT
COMMUNITY FOR EFFECTIVE
RESULTS. IN MENTAL HEALTH AND
THINGS LIKE THAT HOW ARE WE AS
A LEGISLATIVE BODY- GOING TO
ENSURE THAT WERE REALLY GETTING
COMMUNITY DRIVEN. INITIATIVES
AND SUPPORTING THOSE AS OPPOSED
TO KIND OF TOP DOWN MAYBE FROM
THE OUTSIDE OF THE COMMUNITY
PROJECTS. WELL IN THE REGULAR
GOOD POINT BECAUSE I THINK WE
HAVE TO DO IT THAT WAY FOR
GOING TO BE FAMILY ORIENTED. SO
WE HOW EVERYBODY'S EVERY AREA
HAS A DIFFERENT SET OF
DYNAMICS. IT TAKES A LOT OF
INPUT AND DISCUSSION. AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL I HOPE THAT THIS.
NEW BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CARE TASK
FORCE. THAT WERE STARTED WILL
DO A LOT OF COMMUNITY OUT
REACH. IN THE LOCAL COMMUNITY.
IN TERMS OF LISTENING. TWO
DIFFERENT APPROACHES THAT WORK
IN CERTAIN AREAS AND DIFFERENT
COMMUNITIES I THINK IT'S-
PROBABLY TRUE WITH THE BIG
STATE LIKE WE HAVE THAT THAT'S
PROBABLY THE CASE. WHAT WORKS
IN SAN JOSE WHERE I'M FROM MY
NOT WORK AND- STOCKTON IT'LL-
ABSENT MIGHT BE DIFFERENT NO.
SO I THINK YOU I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE DO THAT
THAT'S MY OPINION OKAY IS THERE
ANY STRUCTURES IN PLACE TO HELP
FACILITATE THAT OR TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT REMEMBER WE HAVEN'T
GOT THE WORD ABOUT THIS
SCHEDULE THE SURGERY
UNDERSECRETARY WILL. THERE'S
JUST GETTING ORGANIZED RIGHT.
THIS SO WE NEED A KIND OF HAVE
A THIS KIND OF LISTENING KIND
OF ACTIVITY. IN ALL DIFFERENT
ART PARTS OF THE STATE
BASICALLY. WHICH I HOPE IT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH YOU'RE
WELCOME. THIRTY ONE A REPRESENT
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL NURSE ARE YOU
TODAY- I THINK WHEN WE LOOK AT
THE ISSUES THAT WE'RE
DISCUSSING TODAY HALF OF ALL
KIDS ARE COVERED BY MEDICARE.
WE HAVE FIFTY EIGHT COUNTS ARE
COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION.
SIX MILLION CHILDREN IN THE
SCHOOLS TEN THOUSAND SCHOOLS IF
WE'RE GONNA TALK ABOUT
PREVENTION AND EARLY
INTERVENTION SCHOOLS WHERE THE
CHILDREN ARE. WE'VE ALREADY
IDENTIFIED THE FACT THAT THERE
IS A VERY RICH BENEFIT PACKAGE
UNDER THE PST T. OUR THAT WOULD
LOOK AT MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY LOOK AT
PHYSICAL HEALTH ISSUES. IN THE
SCHOOLS WE HAVE A VERY LOW
RATIOS OF CREDENTIAL SUPPORT
PERSONNEL THAT WILL BE YOUR
SCHOOL COUNSELORS AS MENTIONED
BY SENATOR- RUBIO. YOUR SCHOOL
PSYCHOLOGIST YOUR SOCIAL
WORKERS YOU SCHOOL NURSES ALL
OF WHOM CAN PROVIDE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES. WE ALSO HAVE A
FUNDING A PROCESS ELLIE A MARK.
WHICH ON AT THIS PRESENT TIME
ONLY COVERS KIDS WHO HAVE I. E.
PEACE BUT- ONCE WE GET THE SPA
APPROVED BY STATE PLAN
AMENDMENT PROVED BY A CMS. ALL
MEDI CAL CHILDREN IF WE'RE
PROVIDING SERVICES FOR THEM
IRRESPECTIVE OF WHETHER THEY
PHYSICAL MENTAL WE CAN CLAIM
REIMBURSEMENT SO WE BELIEVE
THAT THERE ARE SOME OPTIONS OUT
THERE TO LOOK AT. PROVIDING
PREVENTION AND EARLY
INTERVENTION SERVICES FOR THESE
CHILDREN. THANK YOU I THINK THE
SCHOOLS NEED TO APPROACH THAT
MULTIPLE- FUNDING FOR- SCHOOL
BASED MENTAL HEALTH SERVICE
SCHOOL BASED HEALTH CARE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES. OF WHEN I WAS
COUNTY SUPERVISOR WE STARTED A
OF PROGRAM FOR THAT. IN SANTA
CLARA COUNTY- USING. THE Mà
FUNDS MEDICAID MINISTRY TO
MEDICAID MINISTRY PROGRAM. AND
WE FUNDED A LOT OF THE SCHOOL
NURSES AND- STAFF IN THE
VARIOUS. L. JUNIOR HIGH AND
HIGH SCHOOLS IN- IN OUR COUNTY.
AND I THINK- SUCH A SYSTEM
WHERE THERE'S SORT OF.
COLLABORATION OF FUNDING- IS
HAS TO BE REINVIGORATED IF YOU
WANT TO SAY THAT WHAT WE HAVE
TO. WE HAVE TO READ TO RE
CREATE THE OUT I THINK IT HAS
TO BE STARTED OUT THE- COUNTIES
ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR HIM. THEY
HAVE BEEN VERY- RETICENT
RELUCTANT. FOR IN SOME CASES
JUST NOT WANT TO- PARTNER WITH
THE SCHOOLS AROUND HEALTHCARE
ISSUES AND NOT JUST MENTAL
HEALTH THANK YOU- PRIMARILY
MENTAL HEALTH BUT ALSO WE-
HAVEN'T REACHED OUT TO THE
HEALTH PLANS AND THEY PLAY
OBVIOUSLY A LARGE ROLE IN TERMS
OF- YOU KNOW COVERING THE BED
THE BENEFIT PACKAGE IN A AND
ALSO THE FUNDING. SO ARE THERE
STILL A LOT OF WORK TO BE DONE.
ONE LAST THING. WITH THE
HEALTHY ARE CALIFORNIA FOR ALL
THEY'RE TRYING TO REDO
REORGANIZE MEDI CAL BUT THERE'S
BEEN NO DISCUSSION ABOUT THE
ONLY A Mà PROGRAM AND SO WE
ARE STILL TRYING TO MEET WITH
THEM TO BRING THAT TO ATTENTION
BECAUSE THAT NEEDS TO BE LOOKED
AT AS WELL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OKAY THANK YOU OF WELL. I THINK
WE HAVE A LOT OF WORK TO DO BUT
I THINK THIS IS OUR FIRST-
SELECT COMMITTEE ON ON- MENTAL
HEALTH FOR THE STATE SENATE OF
THIS IS GOING TO BE AN
IMPORTANT TOPIC IT RELATES TO A
LOT OF- THINGS WERE WORKING ON
A LOT OF THINGS THE GOVERNOR
HAD IN THIS BUDGET. AND WE'RE
REAL EXCITED THAT WE'RE WE'RE
ACTUALLY TALKING ABOUT THIS
NOW. SO WILL CONTINUE TO
EXPLORE THE INPUT FROM ALL OF
YOU. AND HOPEFULLY PRODUCE- SO
EXCITING LEGISLATION AND-
BUDGET PROPOSAL SO SURE- WITH
THE REFORMS THAT WERE NOW
UNDERGOING WITH OUR MEDICAL
SYSTEM. IN OUR PRIVATE
INSURANCE PROGRAM SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. OF THIS METING IS
ADJOURNED.